Heat. Heat.
When darkness falls.
You are my light.
You take my hand
and hold it tight.
You are my home.
I know it now.
Don't let me go.
We're safe and sound.
I see your beauty shine.
You radiate with light. Our
hearts dancing twine.
You're one of a kind.
Shine
and feel my heart.
We're never lost.
Even when I'm gone
like cles
from near and far
above the flower bed
as we watch the stars I'll never be
lost.
You are my home.
You feel my pain.
My soul is yours.
Two souls the same.
With you I'm everything.
You never ask me to change a thing. They
set our world on fire. But our hearts
will burn for miles. I see your beauty
shine.
You radiate with light.
Our hearts dancing.
You're one of a kind.
Stars shining with us. Your fire is
contagious. I feel the moon on our skin.
Love glows out. Love strings in your
eyes shining through me like the way so
that we can see.
Feel the warmth of my love.
Shine
and feel the light and feel
even when I'm gone.
I circle
from
above the flower.
As we watch the sun
be
sleeps
down
every breath that I breach
The energy flowing in me is waiting for
release.
You won't
know
it in my bones
through the shadow. Can I fight the way
before me?
God through my soul
to guide us through the sorrow. Can I
drop this inside
a part of me that's under pressure
to make the earth shake
on my eyes
and you
Look at me.
Lose control
in my bones. Watch me through the
shadow. Can I fight the way before me?
It's God through my soul
to guide us through the sorrow. Can I
drop this storm inside me?
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat. Heat.
I fell in my bones
through the shadow
before me
through my soul
to guide us through the sorrow. Can I
come this storm inside me a
spark to
shadow? Can I make the way before?
It's crushing through my soul
to guide us through the sorrow. Can I
come this?
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Heat. Hey, heat. Hey, heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Incredible.
Come and play.
But I might shoot you in your face.
Bombs and bullets will do the trick.
What do we need here? Is a little bit of
panic.
Do you ever want to catch me? Right now
I'm feeling ignored.
So can you try a little harder? I'm
really getting bored.
Come on. Shoot faster. Just a little bit
of energy. I want to try something
better now. I get some people.
Let's put this in my shirt and see what
things. It's such pathetic cleanness,
but not for long. I still get kicked.
So much better.
So much fun.
That was crashing.
Blow up the sun.
Come on. Shoot. Just a little bit of
energy. I want to try something better
now.
Welcome to the first ever European
Riftbound regional qualifier. With 1,650
players, new legends will be forged this
weekend in Bologna, Italy. Just like the
rich culinary history of this beautiful
city, we're here to bring you the most
delicious plays and spicy decks. My name
is Amy Wley and I'm joined by the
fantastic Medic. How are we feeling
today? Oh,
>> I'm feeling amazing. I was here at about
8:30 a.m. There was already a massive
queue. People have been lining up for
hours to get in. And with the action
already kicking off as well, we're
starting to hear about some incredible
decks. It is just such a pleasure to be
here. It's an amazing event. Everyone's
been so kind and I'm really looking
forward to the next two days. Honestly,
the energy in the room is unmatched. I
think the player base is already so
dedicated. We were only just talking
about the mega Nexus night that we had
last night, finishing 11:30 p.m. and
people are already filtering into the
hall very early to get on with the
action and just enjoy Riftbound.
>> Yeah, it's it's incredible to see how
quickly it has got a grasp of kind of
the collective consciousness here. You
hear people talking about everywhere. At
breakfast, people are playing games over
their quason. So, it's like, guys, may
maybe take a second. You've got like 12
rounds of Swiss to go. You know, it's a
lot of action still happening. Uh, and
I'm really looking forward to seeing how
things begin to develop today and
whether we we get to crown a new Spirit
Forge champion as well with, you know,
some decks doing really well over in
China, but this is the first kind of
European uh Spirit Forge that we get to
see overall.
>> Exactly. And there's so much to play
for. There is so many events yet to come
as well. We are only the first European
event. Of course, we've already seen a
lot of love from Houston. We're here, of
course, in Bologna. Now, Spirit Forge
has released. We're off to Las Vegas, of
course, later in the month as well.
>> Yeah. And then after that, we have Leela
and Atlanta both in Spirit Forged as
well. Then we have the release of the
third set, Unleashed. We're going to
Sydney, get up into Canada as well. I
was in Vancouver for MSI last year.
Incredible city, amazing place to be.
And then back back into Utre and then
over to Hartford to round out our
Unleashed package.
>> I think that's a really nice unleash
package. We got four events in Unleash,
which is many more than than kind of our
other sets as we see that we join
Vendetta for Barcelona in August.
Singapore in September. And on to
Radiance.
>> Yeah, I'm looking forward to Radiance,
but TK used to be one of my favorite
champions in the league. And Radiance, I
feel has a gem sub theme. I have no no
indication of this apart from the fact
the logo is quite shiny and I think gems
are truly outrageous. So I I'd love to
see some TK love in Radiance.
>> Absolutely. And you know we've got so
much to look forward to. We can see that
road map clearly shows that the action
is just not going to stop. We are going
to bring backto back riffbound action
throughout the entire season and as we
very well should and of course you can
go and catch all of this this weekend
here in Bologna. Yeah, 13 rounds of
Swiss this weekend into the top eight
elimination. So, we have eight rounds
today. You need to go six and two
through those eight rounds to make it
into day two. And then we have five
rounds playing tomorrow morning before
we seed into that top eight. It's 11:00
a.m. C both days. And you can catch
everything on twitch.tv/playbound.
Oh, just riftbound. I think it's not
even playbound.
>> Absolutely. And honestly, it's a there's
all to play for. It's not just that top
spot. We have best of prizes.
My goodness, it's so exciting to have a
game that rewards innovation, that
rewards playing your favorite champion.
But we have so much prizing on offer. Of
course, top place, the champion prize
getting that Blade of the Ruined King
alt art playmat and promo and $6,000.
>> Yeah, the Blade of the Ruin King
actually you can see in the arena. I
went over and had a look at it. It's
behind some glass and then a vinyl case
as well to keep it protected. Looks
really cool. I love the art on it. I
really like this sort of blueprinty
style of art that they've gone for here.
And then everyone getting a bone shiver
as well for competing. Really, really
fun event. And obviously there are some
people competing for those top spots.
But as you said, the best of prizing
really allows you just to have fun no
matter what you're doing here.
>> Absolutely. If you chose to come in with
something, you might consider rogue.
That's still fine cuz you could walk
away with some phenomenal prizing with
those metal cards that we have on offer.
Whoever performs the best with their
chosen champion will walk away a winner
in their own right.
>> Yeah, unfortunately won't be me. I'm
still accidentally registered for the
event because I signed up as a
competitor. Went 02 in my first round.
What a surprise cuz I was doing
rehearsals backstage. But if you are
playing on, make sure to go like 3 and 0
so we can get you on a feature match
later on cuz I'd love to cast your
games.
>> That would be fantastic. I'm sure that
we're going to see a lot of different
champions as well today. We've had a
little brief peak of kind of what it
might look like in the room right now.
We've got a little bit of data which
we'll be able to share properly later,
but there is a rather large mix of
champions and some that I wasn't
expecting to be quite so high up in
those rankings.
>> Yeah, I think the fact that we've had
three big Chinese regionals has allowed
people to see more of a meta than
perhaps we saw in Origins where there
was just a lot of Kaiser really
dominating. Draven, I think most people
still see as the premier deck. Maybe the
S tier or the Z tier if you want to put
it even above that. But you're you are
seeing a lot of the chasing pack teching
to beat Draven. Yes. And then also
teching to make sure they are consistent
in their other matchups. Right. And it's
partly best of prizing. I think that
does increase meta diversity, but also
we've had enough time looking at Spirit
Forge and looking at the cards for
people to understand exactly how you
need to get over the monster that is a
Draven deck.
>> Absolutely. And that's the thing. We've
had time to practice now. Everyone's had
their Nexus Knights and Summoner
skirmishes at their local stores, which
we're going to talk about briefly now.
>> Yeah, Nexus Knights and Summoner
Skirmishes. If you aren't able to make
it to this event or if you did make it
here and you want to get smaller
practice tournaments in, Nexus Knights
and Summon Skirmishes are great for
that. Nexus Knights usually three
rounds. You get a reward of a three card
pack at the end of it. Much more about
having fun, enjoying yourself, being
part of the community. Summoner
skirmishes slightly bigger usually
happen about once a month or so, but you
can get buys for the regionals and those
buys stack up across the regionals as
well. So, if you want to join in,
organize play nearby, you can look at
those QR codes on the screen or you can
look up Riftbound store locator on
Google and click the link and you'll
find everything you want to get.
>> It's exactly that easy to get involved.
If you even need to learn to play, Nexus
Knight is your first port of call. You
want to make sure that you're getting in
there, jamming with other riftbound
players, picking your chosen champion,
and really going for it. And I think
that's what gives this game so much
prowess is that actually I can pick my
favorite, and that's okay. I don't have
to go, "Oh, but it's not very good." It
doesn't matter. I'm going to get my
Nexus Knight pack with three snazzy
cards. I'm gonna have the best time and
get ready for my summoner skirmish.
>> And eventually will be good. Okay,
eventually on is going to be meta
defining. Just you wait. Just cuz it's
not good now, you can get it on the
ground floor of the hype train. You can
do it.
>> You can do it. You can do it with any
champion.
>> No. Or on only.
>> I was wrong. It's on only or nothing.
>> Only.
>> But of course, if you want to brag about
your favorite champion, the best way to
do it is to hit us up on social media.
Make sure you're using #rq Balona and
you might get your socials post featured
on our broadcast this weekend. Tell us
what you're doing. Are you here? Are you
with us? Are you at home? Is your cat
watching? What's the jam?
>> If the cats are watching, we need cat
pics.
>> Yeah, like dress your cat up as Saraka
or Niti, you know, Bushwacks in the
game.
>> We need all of your cat picks. Before we
do get into the meat and potatoes of the
weekend, we as casters decided to make
some predictions of who we would think
would we thought would win the
championship. Now, I will say, and I'm
going to put this out there, I didn't
predict on, but that's only cuz I'm not
competing. I went for Civ. I think Randy
Civis that we uh we saw in the Chinese
regionals is really strong. I like what
this deck can do. It does suffer a
little bit to time. You need to be quick
at playing it and you need your
opponents to be quick at playing it. But
I think if one gets into the top eight,
it can definitely take down the
competition.
>> I've got to say, I know it's typical,
but I went with Kaiser, Daughter of the
Void. I think that having the practice
from Origins and then using that
knowledge and kind of experience that
the players have gained all the way and
bringing it through to Spirit Forge,
only having to learn how to combat the
newer champions. Actually, I think
that's a really fun way to think about
actually kind of the old dog can learn
new tricks.
>> Yeah, only having to learn the new new
legends, I think, is really important.
You you already know how your deck
plays. You're only adding in a couple of
cards. Uh but we do have on the end some
pretty like meta slaves really when you
think about it. Fiora and Draven. Uh
James and Leo, can you excuse yourselves
for these very very standard picks?
I need to excuse myself for picking like
the deck everybody thinks is going to be
really strong coming into this. Uh but
you know we can talk about our
predictions a little bit through the
day. James here with Leonard Kunig to
bring you all the action from round one
in Bolognia. Um and since we're actually
going into a match that features your
pick for the weekend, uh let's talk
about some Fiora. Leonard, why do you
think it's so good?
>> All right, so I think that Fiora,
especially with maybe a baited hook in
the deck, could be the deck with the
highest ceiling in the tournament. It is
a card game and even though there is
very little luck involved in rift bond I
might add still sometimes you need a
little bit of this extra oomph that you
want. So if you are playing an unsung
hero you equip a BF sword to it and then
you bait it to it away draw two card
find a harness dragon. Which deck is
going to match that really? Yeah I mean
the harness dragon when it drops on the
battlefield is really hard to deal with.
It's a big momentum swing and to be fair
we have seen Fiora putting up results
the first two Chinese regionals. So I'm
excited to see in this first round how
it does. I just to quickly explain my
Draven pick a little bit. I think it's
the obvious choice coming in. It b
basically is like you're playing across
two days. Consistency is key. It draws a
ton of cards. It sees a lot of uh the
the answers to things in the meta and it
doesn't really have too many bad
matchups if if any at all. So, a lot of
the players thinking that Draven really
is the deck to beat this weekend, but we
have a lot of room for surprises. The
last two weeks of regionals in China did
give us winners that were not Draven. Uh
so, anything could happen. We are going
to be jumping in to a very fun matchup
for round one that does not feature
Draven. We'll show you some Draven later
in the day. Uh we're actually going to
go into Fiora versus Victor. So, we get
a good look into two very different
types of of play style that come out of
Riftbound based around kind of like
swarming recruit units for the Victor
and then Fiora. All about making, you
know, fewer units bigger, get to that
mighty status and contest battlefields.
>> Yeah. And I think that is a very
interesting dynamic because the Victor
we're about to see I think it is a we
call it kill victor which is a deck that
just basically plays a lot of spells
that kill your opponent's units. So if
you're investing a lot of energy and
power into making big units chances are
you might be really disappointed if they
get removed by a drag under very
quickly.
>> I am so excited for this moment. very
first official Riftband competitive game
on European soil for our first regional
qualifiers here in Bolognia. So, as we
said, Fiora and Victor. So, what does
Fiora want to do? Fura wants to play
those big units, make them mighty, uh
playing the chosen champion Fiora
worthy. So, when you make a unit worthy
uh mighty, you basically get to untap it
and can move it into a battlefield or,
you know, any decision that you want to.
Uh and then when again when you make a
unit mighty, the fur legend can tap to
channel one rune exhausted. So a lot of
synergy around getting from that four
might point to five might point and then
you unlock a lot of the utility in the
deck. Yeah, definitely. I think what you
want to do versus that specific
iteration of the Victor deck is you want
to play with your unsung heroes, those
death units that draw you cards when
they get killed, especially when they
are mighty. So you profit first from
being mighty. You know, you get to
channel a rune exhausted, which is cool.
I mean, you might have actually invested
a rune already, but then you're getting
value out of your opponent using spells
to get rid of your runes. And for your
big units that you want in the end game,
you have Repost. That is another reason
why I think that Fiora might be able to
take down the tournament. Repost is, in
my opinion, the best signature card we
have for any deck. It is generically
countering spells. It doesn't have to
target anything. It can be off it can be
a big spell. It can be a small spell.
And it also helps you in combat. So if
you counter a singularity, that's great.
Your opponent is probably not going to
even go into the battlefield that you
are in already if you're pushing one of
your units there this turn at all. So
you take away the tempo. But if you use
it in combat
>> on a bigger spell, it's just crazy
cakes.
>> Huge swing. Yeah, we're past one of the
the the best spells I I would say
signature spells released with Spear
Forge for sure. Um, one of the
weaknesses I would say with Fiora, um,
both sets of the deck, um, as we go into
things, we'll we'll get the overlay
updated, uh, just shortly. It is Fiora
rather than Adarius. But one of the
things about uh the Fiora matchup is I
from what we've seen would say that
Fiora worthy is probably kind of like
the the the main part of the deck that
um is necessary to consistently pressure
the board to consistently be able to
play units that allow you to uh to to to
get out onto battlefields quickly.
>> I actually think in this matchup Fiora
victorious is also really really
important. Some people side deck it,
some people main deck it, but just
having a unit that has the keyword
deflect versus a deck like Victor is
crazy important just so you dodge some
of those spells or you actually just
stop your opponent from ramping up more
runes, more energy, and also Fiora gains
ganking. It's not the most relevant
thing in all the games, but if you're
playing in a VO slayer battlefield,
sometimes it's really hard to get out of
there. I mean, most of the time,
realistically, it's hard to get out of
there, but with ganking, you can just
you can just profit, honestly.
>> Yes. Yeah. Uh, I think when we're we're
looking at this match up, I I would say
it probably
>> the longer it goes might get a little
bit trickier for Fiora if you start
running out of units. So, this this
version already, okay, so what we've
seen already tells me this, we're not
going for the baited hook version of uh
Fiora. Typically, the Lucian version is
the more uh I think some people call it
like mid-range or a standard version of
Fiora where you're playing a lot more a
few more units. Uh they're a little bit
smaller at the beginning, but you run
more equipment, more abilities that
power up your units to make them uh uh
mighty and and get out onto the
battlefield. So, Lucian, one of the the
telltale signs that that we're probably
playing that version rather than the
baited hook. Lucian is an exceptionally
strong unit if it gets to stick around
um because of the way the mechanic goes.
When you conquer a battlefield, he's
actually going to ready himself and then
can move either to safety or if you're
you're playing a a version that can give
him ways of moving between battlefields.
Then you can kind of do the loop around
and score multiple times in a turn that
helps and that gets completely
hardcounted by the well layer.
>> Yes, exactly.
>> Because if you move in there, you have a
problem. And now I really like what the
victor player is doing because you just
push your recruit token into the V malls
layer and then if your opponent doesn't
combat this with a Lucian and Lucian
really doesn't want to go into the Wild
Mo's layer. Not a not a big 3v3 player.
I think you're just holding with a
recruit token and that's crazy.
>> Yeah. So Victor being played uh blue
Victor essentially when you play a spell
on your opponent's turn you're going to
be able to get a recruit token for that.
One thing about this though is Victor
being tapped out. There is a strike down
in hand for uh JW Anthony where that
that's a a spell that basically is going
to deal damage to an enemy unit and then
unequip uh an equipment that is attached
to a unit. So may very well see it come
out and and take out that Victor uh from
the backline. So it it it could be a
tricky situation being tapped out. A lot
of Victor's gameplay happens on your
opponent's turn. At least this version
of Victor loves casting spells not
during their own turn. You get a lot
more recruits that way.
>> I mean, it says it on the card, right?
It's like when you play cards on your
opposing turn, you get free recruit
tokens. But honestly, Fiora's deck, the
combination of order and body runes,
they have so many combinations of
getting rid of cards. Something like a
challenge or strike down is really,
really strong. And this is one of the
nicest combinations you can have. that
is Warmox armor versus or with the
monastery because you can actually just
sequence your triggers. You can just go,
"Hey, Warmox, I'm conquering. So, I'm
getting a buff." And then, of course,
the battlefield triggers as well. So,
guess what? I can spend a buff to draw a
card. And this is where Lucian Merciless
comes in heavy because you can just move
it back. And next turn, you're going to
go in there again. You're going to get
another draw. You're going to have a
great time. And if it's not a strike
down, a challenge will do the job as
well. Uh, consult the past was hidden on
the previous turn. One of the things
about this Victor deck, uh, you do have
a couple of hidden cards that you you
basically can play around. You you you
have, um, the hidden blade, which is
used a lot to kill your own recruits to
draw in a losing combat, but also then
of course consult the past. A lot of
that based around having cards in hand
to be able to kind of get yourself out
of situations in in following turns. And
here is one of those key cards in the
deck.
>> Fiora worthy being played. Uh if it
sticks around, which is dangerous
against this wig, the deck, uh this is
where you can get a little bit of tempo
from Fiora.
>> But I really like developing it in this
turn because our opponent is only at
five runes. So we are out of singularity
range. This is where it gets really
dangerous for you. Singularity is one of
the best midame removals. Actually, also
endame removals depending on what deck
you're playing against. It's really not
the greatest card versus decks that play
something like mind spplitters because
you know what? They just live. But
against those mid-range decks like a
Fiora, it's really strong at this point.
You could take out Lucian and Fiora. But
in the next turn, you know, if you're
leaving two runes open for your opponent
to anticipate what you could have, do
you drop a singularity into a possible
repost?
>> Well, as you said, we we see it in hand.
There's a couple other cards now to be
careful of. Uh, Drag Under is there in
hand as well. Uh, that is a a card that
basically um is to be honest, I think
it's a little bit difficult to um
actually get for the cost. you you
rarely want to play it like on your
turn. You're always looking to do it on
your opponent's turn. Try and get the
unit at a battlefield. But one of the
things about Fiora worthy is she
basically is never going to a
battlefield. If you start putting a
Fiora worthy to a battlefield, something
has gone a little bit wrong and you're
you're having to contest for points
>> or you're finishing the game.
>> Might as well if if you're getting the
winning point with Fiora worthy, then
you have my blessing.
>> But Dragon is an expensive card in my
mind. Like one of the benefits of when
you have the victory is you get a
recruit on the back end but there is the
dragon there. Luckily the seal was
played earlier so able to compensate for
the the yellow recycle.
>> Oh and that does not look like there is
a big good answer for that. There is no
repost and that is also another good
thing about the Victor deck. You don't
need a lot of tempo. You can basically
waste your energy away. You have a few
good kill spells. You have a few
expensive kill spells. And in other
decks, you're like, "Oh my goodness, I
have to be as efficient with my runes as
possible. You know, I have to place some
spells, make sure I can still develop
some units on the field." No, Victor
does that for you.
>> And one of the things that I was looking
at this match up of it kind of depends
which kill spells or or damage spells
Victor draws in which order because Fura
can go over the top of them. Like you
can protect units to survive through
damage and then once those big spells
are out, suddenly Victor's not not so
difficult to deal with. But I will say
this like direct kill spell like single
target remove a unit doesn't matter how
much might it's got is a lot harder to
deal with. And here's where the fur can
run into a few problems when you start
losing units. You only have a finite
amount in your deck. Whereas Victor is
just going to be like, "Yep, here's
another recruit. Here's another recruit.
Add another one to the board. Keep
swarming you." And now I think we're
already at pivotal point of the game
because Riftbond is so incredibly
dynamic, right? You have so many
decision trees already. There is two
battlefields open. Your opponent is
tapped out. You could go for points
here. You could just really greed into
it. But do you want to risk your Furow
worthy?
>> Here's one thing though that to know
about Set. Um because of the way that
the mechanic works with Set, he's going
to enter as a four uh and get the buff
up to become five. So Fiororthy is going
to allow you to play Set as like an
active unit that turn and start moving.
Um, I feel like that is normally the
interaction you would see was uh set is
going to be able to to to move, but
hasn't
this turn? Unless I'm mistaken on that.
>> I mean, do you want to push it into the
vile moss layer? We're already at the
point where you have quite the big
investment on your units. And I think if
you invest too much here, you might run
out of cards soon. But I really like
that we're going for a draw here. Fiora
worthy in this matchup. The question is
how important is it for you to get your
units ready in the turn you play them?
Because versus Victor, you know that
you're not going to combat the biggest
fields, right? You you have even a
rookie, a two might unit can just get
you the same amount of points as your
set brawler.
>> Yeah, I guess that that's kind of a fair
point as well when looking at things. um
with the Victor tapped out as well, the
Fiora being able to go and come back is
is not the end of of the the way because
the way that it was played uh with the
warmarks, Fiora actually comes up to
five, gets the buff and and basically
becomes mighty. You can recycle rune and
protect Fiora. So I I can understand the
line there now that we've seen it. It's
not necessarily so much of a a line that
I seen in that one.
>> Oh, we're going for an Imperial decree
here. Every damage that is going to be
applied to units is going to be lethal
now. And that's a Bellow's breath if
I've ever seen one. Completely tapped
out. What a turn. That is a massive
push. And that is devastating at this
point of the game. Like you just spent a
lot of resources to develop that board
into three units and thinking they're
protected. But Imperial Decree, Bellow's
Breath, again, Bellow's Breath, one of
the newer cards coming from Spirit
Forge. Uh this time doesn't need to be
repeated because as you said Imperial
decree is going to mean any damage will
kill a unit. Bellow's breath deal one up
to three units at the same location. For
newer players the base is a location. It
is a selectable location with Bellow's
breath. That's exactly what we see here
from our Victor player and wipes the
backline. And from here Victor holding
both battlefields now know Fiora worthy
from the champion zone makes it kind of
tricky to to stabilize in this match up
for Fiora.
>> Definitely. And you know what is even
even more nasty in this one? You
invested a full rune. You drampmed
yourself to get your Fiora back to base.
If you didn't do that, the combination
wouldn't have worked.
>> It's it's the one time where it's the
wrong play, which or at least like a a
difficult play because you don't
necessarily have that information. Of
course, um it it you you maybe you're
thinking about playing around it, but
some point, you know, you just have to
go for it. You're kind of expecting,
okay, my opponent's going up past six,
probably a singularity. I'll probably
lose two units, so therefore I'll
develop a third.
>> Yeah. And I mean, honestly, how much
play testing do you have versus this
specific iteration of Victor or any
Victor really? It's not a deck with the
biggest meta share. So, it's really,
really tough to play test against all of
these decks that are in the room. Every
deck has the same chance. Every deck can
have the amount of the element of
surprise. Oh, and now we are spamming
recruits here. This is one of the win
conditions of the Victor deck. And a
couple of Victor decks have been playing
like the Jace version to try and cheat
out the Vanguard Armory. Uh when you get
to just play it because you're not
worried about what your opponent is
doing it, that that's a pretty good sign
for being in control of the game. A
Vanguard Armory, one of the new uh gears
from the set that you basically once you
play it, you can tap it every single
turn on your turn to play three recruit
tokens, which is quite good value when
you you know, every turn you get to do
it, you just are going to spam the
board, constantly have pressure. And we
said that the the disparity in this
matchup could come down to just who has
the units left. And Victor is always
going to win that one.
>> That's true. What I also think is
interesting is that you do it this turn.
You're holding your opponent only has a
pit rookie and you're at seven. So you
only need to hold one battlefield. Is it
necessary to tap yourself out here to
just exhaust all of your runes just to
get three recruit tokens? I mean, you're
going to get infinite value from now on.
That's a great thing for you, but I feel
like you could have won the game that
turn much quicker. However, it's not a
race yet.
>> Yeah, I'm looking at what's in hand. Uh,
it looks like a stupify. Uh, I think
it's another Imperial Decree. Obviously,
Singularity not usable on your
opponent's turn. So, I'm looking at like
what are the options available that
actually would would be able to hold
that. Um,
>> it's it's an interesting line to like
look through. I I also am along the same
line of like if you're holding tapping
out is a little bit dangerous because
Fura still does have power in the tank
to to like drop pit rookies and things
and start untapping and and and get a
lot of presence but it now is a lot more
dependent on what JW Anthony has in hand
whereas Victor is like well I've got
everything just on board on my next
turn. Also, actually, you know what? I
take it back. I think it's always the
better play because the only lose
condition you have at this point is
basically if the Vanguard gets stolen by
an AA.
>> Okay, that which is possible. Verod
decks do run action. I guess the other
side of this is singularity on your
turn, which you know you have, you can
just wipe both battlefields if if
there's only one unit on each and you're
not too worried from then. You just go,
"Okay, recruit to one, recruit to the
other. Off we go." And and we'll go to
game two.
>> And you do not have the best reactive
spells. Now look at this position Victor
is in. Forcing your opponent to play a
challenge from a pit rookie onto a
recruit token. That is absolutely nasty.
>> So we're going to recycle some rune.
Sabotage is going to be used and that is
bad news because possibly the best card.
>> And you see two singularities though. So
at this point you're looking at like
what is the thing that gets me out of
this situation? Um and yeah, you see two
singularities is like well I can't take
both of those. So, we're going to just
scoop it up and go to game two and look
at sideboards.
>> So, Anthony conceived this one versus OC
Kov. I I hope I got that name right, but
that was very impressive from the Kill
Victor deck. Victor Innovator,
the Mind Victor Chosen Champion. You
know, in in set one in Origins, there
was most of the time a Victor leader in
your deck. So, that was the order chosen
champion. that one whenever you pushed
another one of your units and it, you
know, got killed, you got another
recruit token.
>> In this build, there's not too many
non-recruit tokens or units that you
having. So, uh, that's that.
>> Yeah. And this is reminiscent of the the
Victor deck that came out right at the
beginning. Uh, when we were watching a
lot of best of ones coming from from,
uh, local and and and kind of regional
games in China before the first actual
regional qualifiers, we were seeing a
lot of this like no unit victor being
played. is very similar but with a
slight tilt on it. I know there are some
lines uh in the deck that does have a
unit involved. So for full context,
players that play on the feature match
um they do uh obviously we can see their
deck, we can see the cards in front of
them. We do have the deck list, but this
is a closed deck list tournament. So I'm
a little hesitant to reveal too too much
uh about each deck's specificity on
things. But the there obviously this
victor is a potent force when you do
have so many kill spells to be able to
control the game. So we're going into
game two uh obviously post sideboards
now uh and the battlefields have been
changed. So we're now on sunken
>> temple dreaming tree path
>> dream rockfall path I uh apologize I was
reading off my phone and
>> so the rockfall path is very very
interesting in this deck because units
can't be played there. So your opponent
is not going to able to use any units
from hand. Just put them there when they
control that battlefield. Makes it
really harder to hold that field and
gives Victor most of the time the chance
to just score a point off of a recruit
token and out grind your opponent or
outra your opponent while you're trying
to out grind them now that we have the
dreaming tree unsung hero. And I think
we have a BF sword equipped already
>> which means we're going to draw a lot of
cards off this battlefield.
>> Unsung hero drawing cards. dreamy tree
drawing cards uh you know
>> all the time
>> but I I you know last game we saw a card
in hand of a just going to call him that
now and that was a unit that is really
really cool the renata glass I
imperialist says your tokens enter ready
if you have this with the vanguard gear
that is a lot of might all of a sudden
>> yep a big swing of being able to put
recruits ready onto the board already a
good clutch of hand uh clutch of spells
in hand for a victor player.
>> I mean, you almost you almost feel like
a nexus, right? Spawning minions that
are just just running at your opponent,
but uh
Okovo, sorry, the the was wrong is now
contemplating what are we doing here?
So, there is of course an easy point to
take in the Rockfall path. You're not uh
really suffering from the downside of
that card because you barely play any
units. However, are you dealing with
that unsung hero? There's plenty of ways
for Victor to deal with it, but do you
just want to give your opponent draws
it?
>> Exactly. That that was going to be my
question is I can see uh I think there's
a call a week in hand, which obviously
is a really relatively cheap way of
dealing with it or you have to drag
under, which looks like will be the
option. Um so is going to come through.
Obviously, this is saying, well, I'm
going to give you a bunch of cards, but
I think it gets worse if this sticks
around. I need to stabilize the game a
little early on.
>> They will get the draw at some point.
>> Mhm. And one one reason not to go for
call the week here is a matchup specific
thing that I'm kind of like assuming
comes later. There are a couple of cards
in this Fiora deck that have deflect. Um
and and call the week kind of works
around that. Like if if you for instance
if your opponent taps out for like Fiora
victorious uh and that it's the only
unit there. Well then call the weak is
going to deal with that problem cuz you
just sack the recruit and you don't have
to deal with a deflect.
>> Speak of the devil and find him. I think
we just saw one in hand there. That is a
really really strong card. Getting so
many keywords all of a sudden by just
getting mighty somehow. There we go. Oh,
sabotage will do the deal.
>> Oh yeah. And that is again Imperial
decree bellow's breath combination I
think when you're looking at when you're
looking at that hand. Oh wow. Do you
It's so tough. You you don't take the
decree for for sure
>> cuz yeah there's two of them as well. So
you're like h maybe not so so bad. Also
I think knowing the bellow's breath
combo here is in hand. Maybe there's a
way you can play around it a little bit
better. I don't know whether it's call a
week, but certainly that's like in my
mind of like if I'm tapping out to play
a big unit, I really don't want to
invest and have it die. I could deal
with it now. You know, now that you say
it, I think it's 100% called the weak
that you're taking because you can very
well play through this Imperial Decree
and Bellow's Breath combination usually,
you know, by spreading your units
through different battlefields and your
base, of course. But then again, if your
opponent is playing a token deck and is
getting recruits out every day,
>> then uh it's going to be tough to keep
your unit safe at the battlefield if the
Imperial decree is just going to be
played. So that's that's a tough one
already, but you can't get rid of the
Imperial Decree because there's another
one. Yeah, that's uh that's always like
a frustrating position when you do have
your opponent reveal their hand and
you're you're taking cards out of it. Uh
and you're like, well, I I really want
to take one, but the fact that you have
two means I have to go a completely
different route.
>> We're going for a set brawler developed
here as well. And oh, that was the
repost from the side deck instead of a
exhausted rune that must be janled
there. Oops, that could happen.
Interesting that we did not sight in the
third repost because many people have
been going away from playing the triple
repost main bane deck because it's just
not that great versus Draven. So that's
that's some information there. He's
laughing.
>> Uh I I mean it's it's stage stage nerves
on day one. Uh
>> 100%.
>> Anthony, you're doing great. Don't worry
about that.
>> It's judge. My opponent revealed
information on himself and what what has
been sided in and sided out. Um
>> Oh no. Yeah, I know, right?
>> Oh, poor me. But yeah, we're going to to
to wait this out for a quick second.
Can't be too long. But what do you think
of the position Victor is in right now?
You are actually going to hold with a
recruit token. You have not developed
the one in the last turn. So that's a
very interesting thing to note here that
Victor that Victor had actually a point
in time where he couldn't give you a
unit and that is that is massive
sometimes
>> and I think looking at this match up a
little bit um I think Fiora when I say
is is like a little more stable compared
to the first round. Victor's about to
get to six and might be stuck in a loop
of like staying around this this amount
of of runes on the board where um oh it
looks like it actually uh came from
perhaps the main deck. Um so I uh was
getting set brawler up on on screen. So
I was going to say Victor goes up to six
and now if you want to clear units out
you're again going to have to recycle
down. Not having the gear in the early
game is is a little bit different. the
seal uh that allows you to tap to
instead of recycling does mean Victor
kind of stays in in a point where you're
you're recycling a lot to cast these big
spells.
>> That is true. And also sometimes when
you're only having those kill spells in
hand, there's not really a way for you
to interact with your opponent if
they're playing it calm, right? So the
set brawler is in base there. What are
you really doing? You can develop the
Victor Innovator. That's nice. But we
also know the hand. There's not too many
cards in your hand that can be played on
the opposing turn.
Maybe a hidden blade, finding some new
cards. That could work, I think.
>> And this is a situation where you're
like, well, the recruit's going to die
if you challenge this battlefield at
all. I'm just going to be okay with
drawing two cards, and that's totally
fine. I've developed on my turn. Also,
counts as playing a card on your
opponent's turn. So, you're going to get
that recruit back. So, essentially,
there's there's no real loss on uh
making that exchange. I think the
easiest way to explain why while hiding
a card and then playing it counts as
playing is Teemo.
>> Yeah, that's fair. The chosen champion
unit, the swift scout that just gets
plus three might when it's being played.
So, you hide it and then you, you know,
you flip it over and then it's all of a
sudden a four might unit for two energy.
But now, setler is going to conquer the
Dreaming Tree. I think Dreaming Tree by
now has to be everyone's favorite
battlefield.
>> It's not my favorite. I'll be honest. I
My opponents always draw off it way more
than I do. And I think that's more
saying things about me than it is about
I was going to say that could be a
driver versus car situation.
>> It certainly is. It certainly is. I'll
tell you that much. So taps the fur gets
a rune and um will pass. So no
opportunity to play the hidden blade
that turn cuz set goes to the other
battlefield. Of course that is one
limitation of hiding a card like hidden
blade is it uh is now kind of locked to
the battlefield that it is hidden at.
But I really like this. Uh I mean, you
wouldn't have activated to chain it to
any kind of spell or something except
for when it removes the recruit because
it just it just gives you another point.
The recruit is working over hours. You
get three victory points from one
recruit. That is insane. That might be a
world record actually.
>> I'm lying again. Sorry.
>> It it is uh a lot of a lot of momentum
gained by just a single recruit. Here's
the moment now where do you just eat the
deflect cost and say well I'm going to
well I guess now that we've paid paid
one we uh probably can't get there um
for singularity not an option so much
anymore
>> there's a BF sword as well so we're at
eight might
>> oh of course might we're not a defender
but
>> yeah so we are up above singularity
range that is one of those break points
that we were talking about in game one
can get up and out of uh singularity
range so now we start looking a little
bit further into the line of like okay I
have to either try an Imperial decree
with recruits or is there another way
like if there are any more drag unders
that type of playing
>> I think you're just chilling on the side
of Victor your opponent isn't running
away from you or anything they're just
at two points as well how important do
you think the salvage is that's in hand
for Victor um because there are not
amazing targets for you know you're not
looking at gas or anything like that
like a guardian angel to to to take away
so much at this current board state but
is removing the BF sword significant.
One of the things that Fiora can do is
like re-equip re-equip um uh gear like a
BF sword and go to battlefields multiple
times trading. Is it worth taking out?
I'm not sure in this current board
state, but it would take away all of the
keywords that that Fiora has.
>> Yeah, I think you're saving yourself the
deflect costs by just paying for.
But I mean, you put it at least into the
singularity range.
>> Mhm. The plus three might effect
aggressively for Anthony is not doing
too much. You know, there's almost
always going to be just a recruit in
those battlefields. So, doesn't matter
if you have two might or seven. There's
really no I mean with two might there
might be stupify, but that's a whole
different story.
>> But I think still the salvage is really
good. It draws you a card.
>> At some point you might have the chance
to play out of seals. You can basically
play it out for free. I think the only
problem you have with it is that it just
recycles a room.
>> Very true. Uh is action speed as well
though. So it will allow uh things going
to force out the the hidden blade. So I
guess
>> I'm looking at the the line here. So
wants to draw the cards to be able to uh
to just make sure you can play the rest
of the turn. I was uh working through
that match up. So does Fiora go to the
battlefield? Now that is the important
thing cuz you cleared it out. So, uh, I
guess you send him in.
>> That is very interesting. I was
wondering why Anthony targeted the
recruit and not the Victor Innovator
that is going to grab so much value,
especially when you play the salvage as
an action on the opposing turn to get
another recruit token.
>> I think he might have figured that the
hidden blade would be used on the Fiora.
And, you know, in Anony's position, I
understand that because you need to
value your units a lot more.
>> Yeah. And to be fair, this is where
having perfect information on the game
uh does change quite a bit where we we
know that that salvage is coming. We're
drawing just every card in the deck.
Super fire for minus one. Now that it
doesn't have the deflect.
>> Now Fiora is also at three might. So
this is wages of pain range.
>> M yeah, wages of pain
>> with two runes. I don't think that's
going to be a problem though.
>> Yeah, that's very fair. I was going to
say in uh you know, one of the new cars
that came with Spirit Forged, another um
direct damage ability that kind of can
deal with situations like this. Now that
Fiora doesn't have deflect, you uh
aren't paying so much. But look at how
much resources that Victor had to to go
through to get to this point. Even
without paying for deflect, you're like,
well, I'll recycle and recycle and keep
going.
>> But I mean, the the stupify also gave
you another token. So, I think just aken
>> get a token for one energy is fantastic.
>> And we know the follow-up is Imperial
Decree cuz there's two enhance. So,
you're saying, "I will trade a point on
this turn and let you have this, and I'm
just going to trade one recruit to each
battlefield for the next turn."
>> All right. Okay. So, we're at four
points for Anthony and three points for
Betovo.
And we're getting two more order runes,
which is important because previously we
couldn't have activated Imperial Decree.
Very true. It needs two order. We only
had one.
I'm wondering whether the math worked
out there that you knew a yellow one was
coming with five blues on the
battlefield already.
>> All right, we're going to use Imperial
Decree.
>> Oh, there's going to be some recycling.
Repost is huge here. That takes away so
much tempo. And now it doesn't really
matter how many. Oh, you can actually
just use your grand duelist as well now.
Wow, that we have boosted up the Fiora.
Two runes left open. We are deflecting
and we are mighty. Oh, and that is an
army of recruits. Ah, we're going to
start the glorious revolution and go
into the dreaming tree.
>> But alone, yeah, alone they can't
contest the Fiora. So, you need
something else on top of it. So, this is
just saying, okay, well, we're going to
have to clear set out. There's still two
open. And one of the cards that came in
uh Spirit Forge punch first. I think
I've seen one in hand for for JW Anthony
um damps you, but it will deal with
situations like this very effectively.
There are also other cards in JW
Antony's deck uh that can indeed uh you
know get you out of this situation, but
that is one of the best that that is
available. You don't necessarily need to
go that hard over the top. You only five
recruits in play, but
>> but I mean you can't choose always.
>> Yeah, sometimes you just got to use the
tools that are that are in the the hand.
>> I think if you trade a punch first and
it DMs you of course takes two power
costs. If you trade it for five tokens,
I think you're good with that trade.
Yep. And there is one energy. Two power
paid. Punch first is going to take away
those body runes.
>> And we think of how much Victor spent to
get those recruits on the last turn.
There was a lot of uh dramping and using
a stupify on, you know, in like a card
to to be used. Yes. Okay, you get the
card draw with it, but punch first is
just going to say, "Nope, we're going to
get through this moment." Now the
question is, do you take the the hidden
blade trade here and get rid of the set?
>> I think you want to actually because
then you get to keep all of your recruit
tokens. That is huge. What you can also
do is of course use it on one of your
recruit tokens, draw three cards because
of the dream, but also now that is only
one rune left open for Anthony. You
know, you're out of repost range. Yeah,
I think your opponent is playing heavily
towards keeping their own units. I think
you want to take out that set also
because if you let this go through, your
opponent goes to six while controlling
two battlefields with a deflect unit.
>> Yeah. And I feel like it's a question of
how much can Victor stabilize from a
situation where you lose all the
recruits. And I don't think it's as
anywhere near as easy as Fiora closing
out the game. So, I think that that is a
a a choice that makes sense from this
situation. Keep your recruits. uh allow
you to play for a further turn. But do
you think there is something that
Bachovo did not account for and that is
the ganking keyword on the V Victorious
Fiora? Because
>> if you boost that one up with something
like a BF sword that could get rid of
those recruit tokens really fast.
>> Yeah, let's see the hand of uh JW
Anthony. See what's there. See what
options are available to give that
keyword of ganking over. I mean, you
just need to give it one plus might.
There has to be something in your hand
that gives it one extra might.
>> We did just see the hand. I saw a lot of
units.
>> So, like illusion, I saw um
that is that is wild. I mean, ideally, I
think those are five five recruit
tokens, right? Ideally, you give the
Fiora plus two.
>> There's there's a non ideal line where I
think I saw a death grip in hand. Oh,
>> so do you play a unit, kill your unit,
give it to Fiora, and you just take that
trade and you say, "Well, Fiora is going
to be able to to to gank, but I have to,
you know, spend a lot to to do it."
Death Grip, again, a card that you kill
a unit, give its might to another
friendly unit. You do you do draw one as
well from it, so it it's kind of an even
trade. You're like, I'll take five
recruits in a draw. I think you do, but
with so many cards in hand, you have to
find a way. Oh, there is the Warmox.
Double Warmox brings us up to six smite
deflect and most importantly ganking. Of
course, we can also channel one rune
exhausted as well again with the Fiora
Grand Dualist. And now with the keyword
ganking on a completely exhausted rune
field from Bkavo, this is going to be
game for Anthony picking up the cards.
And this is how it can go too if you
can't start running away with the game
with Victor. And then we see Anthony
victorious revealing that repost. But
you know, eventually he probably got to
draw it anyways. And you know what?
Kum's good.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Pretty good card. Um those
warmogs as well just hiding tucked away
in the back of the hand. Uh
>> doing the easy job of just playing
playing a gear and equipping it rather
than finding the the convoluted line
that goes down uh a strange path. But
that means we're one and one in our
first series between these two.
Interesting to see how Victor was able
to, you know, take game one quite quite
swiftly, quite easily. And Fiora kind of
just like really fighting through those
those spells and going above and beyond,
making sure you're not in singularity
range, trying to trade as effectively as
possible.
>> I mean, when you're saying trade as
effectively as possible, we saw a drag
under used on an unsung hero that was
mighty. That is that is such a
discrepancy in value in these cards.
It's really hard to come back from that
with any deck. If you're using a five
energy, one power cost card
>> on a two drop essentially that draws you
two cards. It's tough.
>> And I think maybe not necessarily about
the players in this match specifically
because we are playing at a at a
regional qualifier level. So I expect
everybody in this room is very familiar
with card games. But for newer players
that might not understand how important
uh drawing cards is, it is possibly like
the strongest mechanic in the game. It's
like the more cards you have in in your
hand, the more you're able to play
around things. So, never never give your
opponent free cards if you don't have
to.
>> Exactly. And now, when you're talking
about drawing cards, there's something
that feels like drawing cards, and that
is for the Victor Innovator deck, the
Raven Bloom Conservatory.
This card is insane. When you're
defending there, you look at the top
card of your deck, and if it's a spell,
you get it to your hand. Victor has so
many of those, so you're almost always
going to draw one of those. You start
with a recruit token, so you're always
going to have a two drop or a one drop
basically. So, you're going to play a
unit on your first turn. So, this card
is just free value for you.
>> I'm time traveling. There's a sunken
temple.
>> Yeah. Coming through. I love the the
conservatory that you're talking about
as well. Uh, as you said, you're
basically always the defender if if you
set up. And of course, Victor going
first is going to allow that move uh to
the conservatory as uh turn two begins.
So, there's the unsung hero. There is a
Warmogs as well played for Fiora. So
very similar to the previous game,
although it was BF sword in game two.
>> That is very interesting to me because
>> the question that you have to ask
yourself now is that a strong start you
started with in your first turn you used
up all your energy, right? You used the
runes, you played two cards, so you have
two cards less in hand and they are not
a combination. You know, unsung hero
plus Warmox, it doesn't do anything.
>> It's just a whole pile of nothing. So
maybe you are lacking good cards that
you can use as follow up because the
start of the Victor deck inherently is
strong going first with the Raven Bloom
Conservatory.
>> Okay. So there is a BF sword in hand
that is possibly a side deck card.
>> Yes, I'm going to bring it up on
streaming spirit.
>> It it's you know a tech card that we saw
a lot in Origins um at least against um
against Kaisedex. Uh so again this
matchup is so much based on direct
damage abilities. Um here is the play on
sunken temple. Wages of pain comes out
>> and we'll deal with the
>> Oh wow, that's a really early use.
>> We're throwing it in immediately. So are
we going to even I don't even think you
get the gold token then, right? Because
you're not doing the damage that Wages
of Pain wants you to do. We would have
to read up on the Wages of Pain card as
well to see the exact wording. Let's get
it for you here
>> because gold talkers I think if we if we
check out the last we've seen
>> um one thing about riftbound is because
it's uh kind of like do as much as you
can is within the rules. I I'm assuming
that it's because it's deal three damage
to a unit play a gear gold gear token
exhausted. You're going to be able to do
that regardless um is my interpretation
and the way that the players uh have
played it. So, it's, you know, pay
three, get a gold. It's not as much as I
would like, but at least the opponent
playing unyielding spirit for now. Uh,
that's a big like on a future turn where
you're committing a lot for singularity.
That blowout would have been huge. So,
getting it away is already a good thing
I would say for Victor.
>> True. If you're trading also, you did
not trade any power cost, right? So, you
actually DM your opponent while not
having this yourself.
>> This is nice. Stup if you can use
stupify for an even trade with root
unit, I think you're happy with that
card. just getting free value out of
this. And you can see Anthony just did
not go into the Raven Bloom Conservatory
once because he knows that is going to
give my opponent a draw. I do not want
that necessarily. So you can go into the
sunken temple. You can spend one energy
to draw another card. That is good value
for you. But again, a recruit token that
is pulling the overs.
>> Gold plus one salvage is going to make
it not mighty anymore. So you won't be
able to activate Sun Temple. And now
Fiora does not have all of those
keywords, deflect, ganking, uh, and
shield. So, little bit less potent.
Still difficult to deal with without a
follow-up spell. Recruits obviously
really struggle to get past larger units
like Fiora without the assistance of an
Imperial Decree or Wes of Pain or damage
that comes through
>> and there's a BF sword to say, okay,
well, we'll just we'll get through that
after. I won't draw the card, but I'll
still make sure Fiora is is safe.
>> So, we're equipping it immediately as
well. And I'm I'm wondering if there
ever was a turn for an Imperial decree.
Is it now? Because I think you have a
very very healthy rune management.
>> If if if that if the Imperial Decree Oh,
okay. Sabotage is huge.
>> Sabotage is huge. I mean, Imperial
Decree is there. And look at this hand.
Double Bellow's Breath with an Imperial
Decree and two Hidden Blades. Three
Hidden Blades.
>> Wow. Those are plenty of blades, man. So
Fior's like, well, I'm probably drawing
a lot of cards if you're using them on
my units. But that is a lot of kill
spells to just eat through the units
that Fiora has.
>> But I mean, I think Anthony is in
desperate need of more cards. I don't
even know if he has any left in hand
because that was plenty of cards played
without any card draw in the first turn.
Unsung hero just dying without doing
anything. I think he's at one card in
hand. So he'll gladly gladly take that
hidden blade, but also needs to really
top deck off of it because if you don't
find the units,
>> well, I mean, then you don't win the
game, huh?
>> Yeah. Yeah. A lot being spent. Oh, draws
the Vanguard Armory off uh the the card
after the sabotage has been used.
>> Yeah, I dig it. That was a neat top
deck.
>> Yeah, that uh in in other games you you
say you can't do stuff to top deck. You
can't sabotage the top of the deck. Uh
so that's the way I'm going to put it
for for Riftbound. cannot sabotage the
card on top of your opponent's deck. And
sometimes it just draws exactly what
they need to keep up the pressure. Uh
Imperial Decree was a problem, but now
with Hidden Blades uh and a lot of
recruit units, you're kind of like,
well, I'm just going to be able to
contest battlefields for as long as I
can. You will not be able to keep up
with the pressure that this Vanguard
Armory is going to create through the
game.
>> By the way, I love the hidden card
there, which might be a hidden blade.
could also be
>> you think is one of the three copies of
hidden blade.
>> I think it could be a hidden blade
actually and I think this is going to
give so much value. You know, you're
holding with the Fiora, you can gank
with it. So, you're going to draw a card
off of Raven Bloom Conservatory most of
the time. Then you're going to be able
to hidden Blade, draw two more cards,
and then find
>> defender trigger first. So, it's uh
>> it's No, it's spells.
>> It's to the to the bottom. So, it's
spells doesn't count on on gear. Uh, but
it's now C1 card. Decide whether you
want to hidden blade your own unit or
your opponent's unit. Maybe draw two. I
>> I think you do want to hidden blade your
own unit. You want to find more Imperial
Decrees. That is the most important card
there. You're starving your opponent out
on cards, which is huge.
>> You do not want to hidden blade them. I
mean, look at this. Your opponent has
seven runes. Is this seven Seven runes
open? Yeah. Two cards in hand. I mean,
okay, this was the first action done
this turn actually. Never mind. But
>> but but still fewer options means your
opponent can't play their way out of a
situation so much. So, hidden blade
comes out
>> now. Choose a target.
>> And the vanguard armory means you no
longer have to think about units as a as
as something that you have to worry
about for the rest of the match. Yep.
You're going to just draw your own.
You're like, you're fine to take that.
>> Wages of pain goes into hand as well.
So, just more things that are able to uh
to take control of the game.
>> Was that a frigid touch, too?
>> It did look like it. that it's a good
combination. However, repeating deflect
cost is
>> that's painful. It's it is painful
because they are separate. Um they are
separate uh instances
of that. So if it was indeed a frigid
touch, then we may very well see that.
>> But uh I mean Victor is now at 20,000
cards in hand. I counted them myself.
We're going to get even more recruit
tokens.
>> Yeah,
>> that is the nastiest one. And I think
you will have both that if you want to
stay in the game, but that is such a
huge tempo swing. Fiora Victorious
actually granted you two points per
turn. And now
>> that's exactly the interaction we talked
about earlier in the game when Fiora
Victorious is the only unit that is on
the board and Victor has six recruits at
that point. Just kills one of the
exhausted.
>> Fiora has to be the target for call the
week. No repost on in hand. So again, if
you'd have given your opponent the draws
there, there's all the chance that they
would draw into it. So keeping their
hand low, keeping that economy extremely
low for JW Anthony, it puts him in a
really difficult position.
>> And this is also a very high display of
skill level because you are not
panicking about points.
>> Some players would go, "Oh my goodness,
the Fura player, if they get two more
points next turn, then afterwards I
lose. They're already at four. If they
get to six, oh my goodness, I'm so
cooked." But no, if you're just calm and
collected and you think, "Okay, I have
like eight more good outs to this Firo
without giving my opponent cards.
They're at four points right now. There
is a good chance that I'm just chilling
with this."
Yeah, this is a difficult situation to
be in. I don't think we've seen JW's
hand in quite some time. Um,
so we'll we'll see what they have
available. I'm trying to think of like
available lines. still do have Fior
worthy from the champion zone, but Fior
worthy alone dies to wages of pain
without any kind of equipment. There is
a BF sword there, so can equip it to be
able to then, you know, play this turn
like with the the the ready or it looks
like it might be Yeah, first mate is
going to allow that without it. But here
comes the wages of pain. Oh, but it
looks like we have missed our Raven
Bloom Conservatory Trigger, but we're
able to still use it. all hitting all
the gears here with the seal of unity
and I believe that's a card that you
would have just liked to see but then of
course when declaring who's attacker and
who is defender then you would have to
trigger the Raven Bloom Conservatory and
then you actually get to use actions
>> that is true it does resolve before uh
the action step. I think that's what the
the players were just talking about as
well. uh paying for the cost kind of
skips over but um I feel like at this
point JW Antony's is looking for okay a
call call to glory trundle makes an
appearance so we are going down to six
or going up to six might grand duelist
can use the ability as well so we can
get another rune but how much are runes
going to help us in this game I mean
we're we are ramped up because we
haven't played cards recently
>> yeah that hasn't been the ability to
play them out. So, uh, gold comes from
the wages of pain.
Oh, and now we've turned the corner to
like, okay, I have control. Hidden
blade, I'm going to let you have cards.
It's okay. You're tapped out on this
turn. I've got nothing to worry about
until on my next turn. I'm going up to
seven. You have to contest both
battlefields. And I have kill spells in
hand. This is the moment where hand size
does not matter as long as you've got
those kill spells in hand to be able to
clear the board continually. Yeah, there
is only a first mate and that might be
the last chance for JW Anthony to just
get back into this game. But Betcho is
in control. Also, if you're checking the
heart rate that we have on screen, he's
very calm.
>> Understandably, Chad Anthony is heart
rate through the roof right now.
Basically getting the equivalent of a
workout in playing this game. Oh, just
turn that dice to six. That's fine. Um
although
>> keep in mind they are not ready.
>> Yeah, I was going to say they are they
are not ready for this. Um
>> we get another one. This another
>> all the dice on all the units that is
that is 10 recruit tokens actually.
>> Now now it's correct untap like uh
awaken six. Four of them are from this
turn. So that that now it makes sense. I
was about to say we don't have 10 ready.
>> Was that just I'll make four recruits
pass. Yeah, sure. Okay. I' I've got
cards in hand. But I mean, you never
want to have more than one recruit in a
battlefield. I mean, okay, there are
some scenarios where you really want,
but I I think those are the more rare
ones.
>> Call to glory drawn off the top.
>> So, how much have we got? You You have
to clear both battlefields. Doesn't have
it in our first game of the day. Taken
down by Victor Benchovo uh taking the
win. I really hope that pronunciation is
correct. And I'm sorry if it wasn't.
We're going to ask later.
>> We I definitely will make sure to to ask
as hopefully we'll see more from Victor
throughout the day. Um quite a hard
fought match up.
>> Yeah, the the kill Victor really looks
strong here. I mean, you're getting
endless resources with those recruit
tokens. You're keeping your opponent
low. You're basically forcing them to
not really participate in the game with
you. Every single time they try to
conquer something, they're getting
nervous. You're going, "Is my unit going
to make it?" And there's just this one
recruit token looking at you like
that's got a kill spell backing up.
>> Yeah, a lot of kill spells. I mean, when
your opponent reveals their hand and
it's like imperial decree, uh, you know,
three hidden blades and then some more
spells that that are just going to take
your unit. Like, how do you even play
around that when you've got like you're
taking one away and you're like, well,
I' I've got bad options all across the
board.
>> I mean, if you want to counter that kill
spell victor deck, you would have to
play I mean, a full porro deck
basically, right? You need so many units
to even be able to score points to outv
value them. And this is where the meta
game comes in because
>> Draven, the glorious executioner, seems
to be one of the best decks in the room,
if not the best deck. And this deck
actually forces you to play, I want to
say, less units because going into
combat with Draven means that Draven is
going to draw a lot of cards. So, you
want to build your deck differently. You
want to play less units and that uh
might then backfire against some decks
like the Victor Innovator. Yeah, and
this is one thing actually that I think
best off pricing for an event like uh
this regional qualifier does affect the
meta in some ways because decks like
Fiora have some strong matchups and then
have some matchups that are very
difficult and those are the matchups
that can kill all your units and then
just go wider than you and round one
you're like yes I'm ready to play Fiora
>> and I'm opposite Victor with kill spells
with recruits that can just go wide the
rest of the day you might hit matchups
that are better but round one you
started like ah of course I drew into a
difficult one to begin the day.
>> But I think it's also actually you know
what we were saying that the unyielding
spirit versus the wages of pain that
looked very very difficult to start
with. You know you're investing so much
such a huge important side deck card
>> but were there ever really big kill
spells with damage like singularities
played in that game? I think that was
actually an excellent use of the card.
Yeah, I I would love to to know more
about perhaps if there were any
sideboard choices for game three
specifically because game two we saw the
attempted use of damage based spells to
to kill units from Fiora, but she just
kind of went over the top and was able
to to survive through. Anyway, we'll
park Fiora and Victor for now because
we're heading into our second feature
match from round one. still sticking
with the opening round of play which of
course a lot of players did bypass by
winning their summoner skirmish locally
getting a round one buy here for
Bolognia qualifier but that does not
mean that there aren't players that have
traveled that are very skillful from
elsewhere in the world and weren't
playing summoner skirmishes maybe they
picked up the game recently are here for
round one I've seen a lot of strong
players already out today uh we have a
Garen matchup and uh that is not
something I was expecting to see so much
of today other than contesting four best
off cards. It looks like it's based
around Aurora. Um, so I wonder what
we're going to end up seeing. I've been
playing Aurora Civiver, which is a very
different deck uh compared to to to this
one, but interested to see how this
Garen is going to perform. It is one of
the the the champions that fewer players
are playing because it does have a
little bit of a u perceived weak
standpoint in the meta, I think, is the
nicest way I can put that. I mean, the
Garen ability is not necessarily the one
that you have trigger the most, right?
So, getting to draw those two cards,
that sounds nice, but you actually would
have to have a lot of units for it. But
I really liked one card in the deck
list, and that was the commander lead
draws. I played that in Origins in
Victor for quite some time because uh if
you just killed your own recruit tokens,
and you have some some seals of unity
backing it up, it's actually quite cheap
to play. You play it for six energy
almost for free, then have eight might
and you're deflecting and ganking. If
you if you play this card from the good
old dazzling Aurora, good times.
>> Yeah, good times. We'll see what perhaps
we're up against. So, we had a Garen. Uh
I think it was a bit of a lie cuz we're
actually going into a team Oona matchup
which is again two more champions that
are based in the bracket that we I guess
we're looking towards as um as best of
contenders. Leona's play style based a
lot around creating big units that then
stun your opponent, removing them from
from combat. I've heard people talking
that sometimes this can be a tricky
matchup for like a combat focused deck
like a Draven that wants to win. If a
Leona can get presence on the board, you
stun units, they can't really compete
for the rest of that turn. Whereas Teemo
is a deck that had a lot of success, I
would say, at the beginning of Origins.
like the prevalence of hidden cards,
being able to control battlefields,
leave your opponent asking questions,
uh, left it quite a tricky deck to play
against, but certainly didn't receive
many tools so much for, uh, Spirit Forge
compared to other champions.
>> That's a good point, but I think just
just having chaos runes in your deck
makes you inherently stronger. Also,
>> that's so true.
>> Teemo just offers you the luxury of deck
building. You can just play very few two
drops because you have the Teemo chosen
champion unit. can just play it on your
turn two and later on bounce it back to
hand with the swift scout.
>> Yeah, and I think that's one of the
things that makes it slightly less well
placaced for this current meta is um
Origins is a lot about contesting
battlefields quickly with small units.
Uh now in Spirit Forge, Draven forces
you to pick and choose your holds a lot
more. So a deck like Teemo that plays
one might and two might units, Draven
just runs over, draws a bunch of cards
and says, "I don't care about your
hidden units and hidden cards."
>> Oh, that is Aison's hourglass plate. So,
we are already preparing for this mind
rune removals, those singularities that
might come up at some point, but now
that is a Teemo deck. The deck does
bounce a little bit, so sometimes those
could be a little tougher. We're going
to the Monastery with the Treasure
Hunter, and that's already great, right?
When you move, you get the gold gear
token. When your opponent doesn't have
an early drop to contest that, Treasure
Hunter gets infinite times better. And
I've put one of the best cards perhaps
from Spirit Forge that we're going to
see for the first time today. I've
already seen it in hand I think. Okay,
not coming out now, but very well could
have been. Uh, Ezreal Prodigy, uh,
discard one, draw two, massive draw
spell that a lot of decks are running.
Um, I say spell, it's a unit. It does
other things as well. Uh, allows you to
reduce the cost for additional optional
costs. That is the very uh, important
part of that. So you for instance allows
you to to repeat cold shot basically
just recycling that first rune. I
wouldn't be surprised to see some cold
shots used in this team.
>> I think Ezreal and cold shot they go
hand in hand. So especially also with
the treasure hunter if you're having
that gold gear token next turn. It's
free. It's actually free at that point.
>> Draw two cards by looking at the top
four for free. That is
>> it's so broken. I when I saw that card I
was like there's no way this isn't
broken. That is one of my favorite sight
deck cards from set one. Actually, the
Leona that really really is good against
those combat focused decks. When you're
moving into a battlefield, it just stuns
something. That's how you win combats
rather easily, but the unit is a little
clunky. I want to say if you play it
out, you might get some tempo if you
actually get into a combat and take out
units for free, but if you get rebuked,
you're skipping a few turns.
>> Interesting. So, the first time we're
really seeing Teemo in Spirit Forge uh
in a future match. Obviously, we're in
round one of Baloni, so there's not
really too much opportunity for us to
see it too much in Europe at least. That
is a Thousand Tales Watcher in hand. So,
this is a Teemo deck that yes, it was
played in the Teamo decks back in
Origins, but it still very much is along
that line of like you still have the big
blue units. You've now paired them with
the Chaos units that are coming through
and the Chaos spells. So, I'm interested
to see where else this deck goes. I see
an Ember Monk in hand. I'll bring that
up on stream because I don't think some
players perhaps are familiar unless you
have local uh players that are running a
lot of Teemo. Ember Monk is a card that
trips up a lot of people because it can
surprise you to get a lot of extra might
throughout the game. It's it's crazy. We
saw a sprite mother discard. The mommy
is getting discarded. This card is
really really strong as well. Just
spawns you a sprite token that is ready
immediately. Has been dropped from a lot
of lists. but also a reason why you're
playing this card. And of course, the
sprites call and maybe a thousand tailed
watcher in the Teemo deck.
>> Teemo is not the greatest at conquering.
I mean, this is not what it looks like
right now. It looks like it's the best
deck at conquering ever. Getting to
three points already, but it really
struggles sometimes.
>> Actually, I think Ember Monk versus
Leona, that's a tough time.
We'll see where Leona goes. Love the uh
the rune choice on Leona's side.
the the the fully foiled out rooms do
look beautiful on the the feature match.
>> So, um
>> interested to see where Leona goes from
here. It is a deck that that I know
there's a lot of love out there for
Leona as a deck. Unfortunately, hasn't
seen the uh the quite the results that
people were hoping for. Not necessarily
perceived as one of the uh mustplay
decks and a little awkward of a matchup
at times. it does have problems with
like recycling quite a lot later for for
bigger units. That is always one of the
the trade-offs that you have against
these decks that that do play large
units is you kind of end up going down a
hole of like dramping yourself a lot.
Yeah, I mean in those big power turns,
but that's something we've seen in
Spirit Forged a lot so far where players
just end up on two runes in their last
turn just going all out because all of
those powerful power cost cards with
this power cost manipulation that we
have in gold and in those seals, they're
just sometimes stronger than the cards
you don't pay power cost for something
like a Zonas. But Zonia's hourglass,
it's it's also a phenomenal card. It's
almost like a guardian angel, but it's
easier for your opponent to play around.
like you can't really decide which unit
you will protect with a guardian with
the zonia's hourglass whereas with a
guardian angel that's a completely
different story.
>> Yeah. Looking at what I think is the the
Leona list I think I've seen a few
different things in hand like there's a
Fiora Victorious in hand. Um there's
quite a few units in this deck that
don't see play in other decks. I'm
interested to see what drops from Leona.
I think also another card that I think
is quite key already thematically
appropriate for for Leona with the
stunning uh Thonk is a combat trick that
has come up from Spirit Forge I think is
is again another thing that people have
to play around where it's just going to
basically stun
>> one of the best pre- Rift cards ever.
>> Oh is good. That and Punch first. If you
got to play both of those, you're just
able to control so much. Yeah, this card
just stuns up to two units if you want
to pay the repeat cost. If you have an
Ezreal Prodigy, then you actually get to
only pay three energy to repeat it. So
again, are we going to see Ezreal
Prodigy soon? Not only does Azreal make
it easier for you to repair your cards
because you can decide to not pay
optional costs,
>> but oh, you don't even have to pay
optional cost. Look at those three gold.
Also, discarding and drawing two cards
is crazy. Sprite call discarded. at two
cards immediate value. Ezreal might be
one of the best cards in Spirit Forge.
There is a Rasa drawn to hand as well.
Gold. Oh, this feels great. If you're
playing Chaos, it feels terrible when
you're across the table from it. The
I'll tap a gold or a seal and then I'll
look at two, draw, take one. Oh, guess
what? I'll do it again for free. Doesn't
matter.
>> That is so much value. And it even keeps
up the tempo. How many times do you get
to draw two cards for absolutely free?
Because those gold gear tokens, yes, you
use them up, but that's what they're
there for, right? They provide no other
value
>> except for when you're playing on. But I
think that Maddie can tell you more
about that.
>> So, interesting choices. Two big endame
units or the do I want to just see four
more cards ability? Uh, and it is uh
going to be one of the units. I saw Cold
Shot going back into the deck. I guess
we'll take a look here. Um, I didn't
quite catch which one. It's the Watcher.
Okay. And, you know, matchup specific, I
think that that's good because you're
going to end up playing against Leona
having big units. Watcher can really uh,
you know, put pressure on the
battlefield with that minus three effect
that I think everybody knows from
Origins. Those of you that are playing
hits the battlefield, you kind of sigh
and if you can't alter it, you scoop. I
I just think you need to pressure with
the Thousand Tail Watcher rather early
because those big units versus the Leona
deck, they're not the greatest, right?
So, if you stun a Watcher, you feel
great about yourself, right? That's the
best thing that could happen to you. A
seven might unit and you just stun it
for free. That's so much tempo. One card
in hand we saw there for Leona. Another
signature spell coming through that I'm
going to bring up on broadcast for us,
uh, Zenith Blade. Uh we we're going to
have potentially instances of surprise
defender in this uh in this matchup,
which is a tricky mechanic that people I
think are still getting used to, but
we'll see how that Zenith Blade ends up
coming through. As you can see, it's
going to be stunning an enemy unit at
the battlefield. You move friendly unit
to that battlefield. Zenith Blade is
crazy strong. I've been caught off guard
at off guard at skirmishes a couple of
times by this card before.
>> But also pushing back the Leona is quite
nice. You have the Fiora Victorious
still defending your zones. Warren Leona
is making herself ready for a possible
attack on the monastery. And I want to
say
that's going to be iffy. So I think that
the first time we're going to see a big
attempt to conquer or that's that's what
I'm talking about. The early pressure
with this thousand tailed Watcher.
There's still four runes open
>> and Ezreal is going to help out here
because accelerate is an optional
additional cost. You don't have to
recycle the second blue rune and of
course the first one coming from the
gold. So watcher comes out and you know
you can follow it up in a a following
turn and you still have more available.
So K is really really going strong with
planning forward these turns knowing I
have a watcher. I'm just going to take
another one because I'm not going to
dramp myself. I'm not going to recycle
any runes with the first one. Oh the
push goes in.
>> Interesting. Interesting. A lot of
players will leave Ezreal in base
forever because of how important the
root cost reduction is. But this is kind
of playing in and saying I know Leona is
going to be playing lots and we know Thw
is in hand. There's a Janna coming
through. So Janna won't be able to deal
too much to the the the minus that
Thousand Tail Watcher is going to get.
But as you know Janna players in League
of Legends know you pushing things back.
You getting things out of here. It's
basically like fight or flight attached
to a unit and it's the watcher that goes
back and now Ezreal is vulnerable on the
battlefield.
>> Actually, now that you're saying it, do
you even commit a fighter flight here on
the side of Trenal K? Of course, if
you're pushing back that Jenna, you're
kind of good. I think it has deflect, so
you might have to pay some cost there,
but
then you you might conquer and deflect
is not an optional cost. Just to make
that very clear, there's been some
confusion around Ezreal. It is a
mandatory cost. Ezreal does nothing to
the cost of deflect on enemy units.
>> You're taking out the VR victorious, but
then in the next turn, I think there's a
pretty good chance that your Ezreal is
still going to die. But I mean, you you
took that risk when you pushed it in
there together with the Thousand Tala
Watcher. And we're going to discard
another Ember Monk. We are good on units
there. So, pretty nice discard drawing
another card. Only thing that's a bit
odd now is you're completely tapped out.
Do you even want to hide anything? I
think I don't think so. Right.
>> Yeah. One thing perhaps for for newer
players maybe that that didn't follow
the full game state. The Fiora of course
was affected by the Thousand Tale
Watchers entry uh ability that gives it
minus three. So it actually was one
might at the time where Ezreal uh is the
remaining attacker against it. That's
why Ezreal survived and and Janna gets
pushed back.
>> So we're actually going to hide another
card.
>> That is I This is the annoying part
about playing against Teemo. You're like
I have no idea what card that is.
There's like six. It could be.
>> It could just be a Teemo.
>> It could be.
>> It could just be a Teemo. The thing is
the Leona is so strong against that
battlefield and any single card that
could be hidden there. If you push in
the Leona, stun the Ezreal,
what what could it be? Okay, it could
be.
>> This is a card that I love from Spirit
Forge. Switcheroo. I don't know whether
there's one in in the the list. I will
go and check. Uh but if it were a
switcheroo, this blows out combat
extremely effectively. you basically
just swap mites with uh your your
opponent and you say, "Okay, well, I'm
just going to leave something small here
and then suddenly it'll be able to trade
with something as huge."
>> Yes. However, if your Ezreal has been
stunned by the Leona before, which you
know of, then just investing that
switcheroo might not be the best choice.
>> You know, that's actually really
important about this matchup
specifically. Again, this is how like
the different champion matchups play
into different things. Like normally
switcher, you're like, "Yeah, what a
good card. It's so great." and then you
get stunned or with anything like that
and you're like well suddenly it doesn't
matter anymore. The thing is if you
switch there and you only know the Jenna
of your opponent and the Leona, you
switch the Leona,
>> nothing. If the Jenna isn't pushed into
the battlefield with the Leona, nothing
can conquer your field. Your S is going
to hold then because it's just so
powerful if it's five might then.
Actually, no, four might, right? The
Leona has defender. So, it only goes up
to five might when it is already at the
battlefield and your opponent is
attacking.
>> But you're at four then still the Jenna
can't really beat it. No,
>> there's a lot else that it could be as
well. Uh, you know, as you said, it
could be Teemo, uh, could be wages. Um,
it could even just be a consult the
past. Uh, there's things like, uh, tide
turner that people play uh, in this
matchup, uh, or at least in previous
versions of the deck. So,
>> turn on Ember Monkus.
>> Yeah, exactly. Cuz you reveal get the
the plus two.
>> Oh,
>> so we might see the reveal come through
just to get the Ember Monk stronger. But
is it enough?
>> Ember Monk is stunned. But however, keep
in mind even if cards are revealed here,
>> the ember monong is going to get so huge
that it might still hold. So yes, your
units won't get killed when the ember
monk is at 20 might,
>> but you're also not going to conquer.
Your units are going to get pushed back.
Your opponent is holding already at six.
>> So holding potentially to win the game,
as you said, that is one important thing
is uh if you're strong enough, there's
the the Teemo coming through. So we'll
get plus three uh might. So it becomes a
four.
>> Captain Teemo on duty.
>> That's what we like to see. Big fan of
the Teemo deck. Playing with hidden
cards is so much fun. Just forcing your
opponent to just get a headache
basically thinking of all the possible
interactions that there could be. And I
don't know if I'm the best player
against Teemo, but at some point I'm
always like,
>> you know what, if they have it, they
have it. I don't know. I I don't know.
>> At some point you just have to say,
well, if they got it, they got it. And
that is okay.
>> You look at the discard of your
opponent. You you count the cards that
are in there. You think about how many
call shots and stack decks they have
been using to manipulate their hand.
Which card would they have gone? But you
can never tell for sure because after
all the deck is randomized.
>> Find a center. Just going to go for uh
see what more options I have coming from
this. Of course, now the reduced cost on
Find Your Center by Trage LK uh being
so close to that eight point part of the
game.
>> So loaded bag two is now going to see do
you have any more combat tricks in your
hand for runes are open. Your opponent
is not going to do anything about it,
but there is still one card that is
hidden on the Z's Warren and those this
card could push up the Ember Monk to
eight.
Yeah, there's uh I'm thinking what are
the options? If it were a tide turner,
you could swap something out, get
tieer's might in there as well.
>> If you wanted to
>> Oh, then you would get another gold
token with the treasure hunter.
>> M. Yeah.
>> And you would get one more white, one
more might.
>> It's a game of just inches at that
moment of every small addition. So, here
is Zenith Blade.
>> Zenith Blade is coming in. We have
another Leona in our base that we've
played previously. So Zenith Blade can
now stun the Teemo and then move a
friendly unit to that battlefield. So we
have another Leona. Does that now count
as a attacker? I think so. Right. So you
actually get to stun him again.
>> Do you already were attacking, right? So
your all of your units are assigned that
for this showdown. It's when a contested
is applied to a an open battlefield that
it becomes a bit tricky and then you
become an attacker even though your
opponent was the one that moved in
first. So it is a complex board state
from that situation. This one I think is
a little more simple and our team player
just says yeah okay I'll let everything
die. You've invested a lot here.
>> Yep. But then again almost completely
exhausted their runes on the side of
loaded back. There is an Ezreal that is
looking strong holding here. The
monastery is going to give you a draw.
>> And we know there's another watcher in
hand and a watcher in base ready to come
out onto a battlefield. So that's going
to be 14 might at at a minimum playing
into the monastery of harana at least.
>> That is a lot of eyes on you. That's
there's going to be some watching that
has to be done.
>> Yeah. And this is one of those
situations where watcher pays for itself
massively because three units means
you're effectively giving minus 9 over
to the opponent's battlefield. I think
we went up to seven, right? So, picking
up another fight or flight in ahead if
we are at 10 runes. If we are that
actually we only
>> we can still use the Ezreal passive
effect to just play it for seven
accelerated.
>> Uh, so it's either eight and one rune or
seven and both runes. You get to choose
whichever. So, it's going to be seven
and both runes exactly as you were were
saying.
>> And I think we just paid eight and two
runes actually, but that doesn't matter
too much. games. I think it would really
help. But of course, we can also go for
a fight. Nope. Immediate immediate fist
bump. He loaded back conceds that game.
Teemo was just running away on points.
>> Yeah, that uh was uh kind of reminiscent
of how Teemo used to be be when it would
be like get get early points and then
just protect them by being able to be
very versatile about well, you don't
know what my hidden cards are. Um Leona
unfortunately falling in that matchup.
you're a Leona fan. Some of the content
I released leading up to to the event,
my Leona videos were just like way
higher than everything else. I was like,
"Wow, Leona has some really really like
diehard fans out there."
>> I mean, I like Leonard, too. She has
almost my name, you know? I'm I'm
Leonard, so we have something in common,
but I don't stun as many players.
>> Uh I was uh seeing if there's a joke
there going from Kunik to uh to
We still have a few more hours on this
broadcast.
>> Yeah, exactly. We'll make it work. We'll
we'll make it work as we head into a
follow-up game uh for these two. So, I
wonder where we're we're going on on
sideboards for this matchup. I'm looking
at uh exactly what our Leona player has.
There's one card in here that I'm
actually quite interested to see.
There's two copies of it, and that is u
Blitzcrank in passive, which is a card I
love playing. I think that's a really
really good card going first if you can
establish. Oh, loaded back deciding to
go second here. Val use the one extra
rune so you can get your power plays
first. We're not playing the obelisk of
power. I would have said that would have
been quite nice with some of these Fiora
Victorious that you just play on your
first turn then.
>> And then interesting to see a Trafarian
War camp come out. Um,
>> okay.
>> So, Trafarian War Camp is going to
obviously make units a bit bigger. uh
that are on the battlefield. I mean,
that is one thing that Teemo does
struggle with is like having smaller
units, but it it's it's a symmetrical
battlefield, right? Is if we both
contest it, we both get the buff. So,
>> you know, we tend to see it when you can
go wide and and have lots of units like
a Victor will will play it.
>> I think the Trafarian War camp is mainly
just because you're running three copies
of Fiora Victorious.
>> Oh, sure. To activate mighty. Yeah.
Okay. if you're pushing that in there.
There's some decks that profit more from
the Tarfarian war cap. Of course,
something like a Victor in the order
version when you're playing Victor
Leader as your chosen champion unit and
a bunch of units in your main deck so
that you always have more units than
your opponent and you get more might.
>> Yeah, that makes sense if it's that uh
it's Leona has selected War Camp, right?
And which it may very well have been. We
didn't we didn't see Battlefield Choice
set up. Um, Valmore's layer I think I
would understand for Leona as well. Uh,
so we'll we'll see as as the game goes
out which player does end up utilizing
it a little bit more. Uh, but we're into
the early game and this is what Temo
does. Just puts units down really quick.
>> Just hide it immediately from the from
the champion zone.
>> Yeah. Uh, Teemo Legend passive I I
believe. Um, let's have a look.
>> It's just not much of a surprise, isn't
it?
>> That's true. felt like just hiding those
cards. The best thing you could do
there.
>> Yeah, you can pay one and tap it to uh
hide it on board. It's the the very last
part of that. You can either put it to
your hand or you can put it to the board
from the champion zone. So, kind of just
doing that shortcut utilizing the legend
ability for that.
>> But, I mean, now your opponent just
knows very well which card is it is
there.
>> Sometimes that's fine though, right?
Like I I actually don't think it's that
big of a of a deal. Um, if I'm being
totally honest, you because you're also
saying, "Well, I'll just get a a unit
basically for free for one one might."
Yeah, sorry. One one one cost on a
future turn. You just get a unit um
basically out of nowhere. And you're
saying, "Yeah, okay. I'm not hiding it."
But sure, I'm fine with that.
>> You know what? Maybe I should do that
more often. Maybe it's actually does
sound kind of good that you're just
playing this for one energy cost to the
fields. It's it's it's a lot of tempo. I
mean, Leona just can't really push in
there because then you I mean,
especially against the Leona deck,
right? Yeah. If you're pushing Leona in
there, then you're just reacting with
your Teemo and they're both at five
might. So, that would really not help.
You leave your probably Teemo on the
field and you're still going to hold
removing that Leona if there's no combat
tricks.
That is an on.
>> That medic is somewhere going crazy. Uh
cuz that is the on
very often.
>> Wait, I I think that is the the forge
god. No, that just gets better with
every gear you play. And you have so
many gold gear tokens.
>> Oh, yeah. Sorry. No, this is the the one
we do see very often.
>> It actually gets huge just from pushing
all of those gold gear tokens. If you're
hiding, you're getting a gold gear
token. If you move the treasure hunter,
you're getting a gold gear token. You're
getting so many gears while sitting on
your own. And you know, Teemo really
profits from holding on battlefields.
>> Yeah,
>> it's or is kind of goated at that.
>> Yeah, that is a very fair point.
Obviously already getting both of uh
like extra might from here from those
gold tokens as as you were saying.
>> Also, if Leona wants to push into that
field and then stun the you would have
to play deflect too because it's spell
or abilities.
M.
>> So yeah, that kind of takes out the
entire the entire strategy of the Leona
deck here. And oh wow, pushing the Leona
into the Vile Mos layer. And I believe
Wait, no, the Trafarian War camp is from
the Leona Vos layer. Now that that is
fantastic side decking as well in your V
moss layer game, you're stacking your
orange forge god into the other
battlefield and then your opponent is
forced to play good units into the volmo
layer because they can never ever
conquer that. You can also still play
with your black market broker. It this
is blowing my mind honestly.
>> That is that is an interesting uh like
adaptation coming into a a second game.
Um,
as
looking at what outs we have, there is a
Ezreal is singularity in hand. I say
outs, I mean I feel like Teemo is in a
in a pretty good spot looking at things.
>> Yeah, I would agree with that.
>> Outs to continue winning the game
potentially.
>> Wow, that is that is so strong. There's
also the Fiora in the base.
>> Did you just see what two cards came off
the top? Two switcheroos.
>> Oh, wow.
>> As well. Although you don't want that
with your right.
>> Yeah, that's true. You're hiding
already. But I mean, the thing is when
you're hiding Teemo, you can just play
Teemo and
>> you can play switcheroo out of your hand
as well, action speed. So, uh
>> Oh, we at least I'm pretty sure it was
two switcheroos.
>> Going to go with the treasure hunter
into the Valmos layer. The next question
is, do we just sacrifice it or we're
playing the switcheroo?
Wow, that is so big.
>> I don't know how far down the the the
rabbit hole I'm going here. Switcheroo
can swap two of your own units might. So
if you get stunned on or you switcheroo
or's might to the other unit that the
battlefield
>> the same battlefield though
>> but but and the the black market broker
is here. So sorry I'm actually not
talking about this battlefield
specifically. Yes, I should probably be
focusing on what is going on live.
>> Drops the second switcheroo immediately.
Okay, cool. That works too.
>> Wow. We're I mean we are recycling so
many runes for that but loaded ve is
completely exhausted with the runes and
has go. Yeah, well your treasure hunter
conquers the battlefield with my Leona
determined in it. My five might defender
and I mean there's one thing going for
him. At least he got it out of the vile
monster layer.
>> Yes. Yeah, that is uh I don't think
that's much of a
>> I don't think that's too much of a
benefit when it goes to the graveyard. I
got to be honest, this is why I I will
just not play Teemo. my brain goes too
far down like the theoretical rabbit
hole that I'm thinking about random
things when I could just be winning with
a one might unit treasure hunter on a
battlefield with two switcheroos did
ramp a lot of course but um again it's
so much about like one of Leona's
struggles doesn't necessarily have that
many ways of uh getting units onto
battlefields the same turn they're
played there are a few different things
you know with zenith blade that type of
thing that can can get you into uh
combat might get you into battlefield
quite quickly, but it's not the same as
the Fura we were watching earlier where,
you know, Fiora worthy is just there
from the champion zone, allows you to
just keep going, keep being present on
battlefields, but
>> um
yeah, yeah, that is a Fiora. I uh
realized we were on the following turn
from Switcheroo. I
>> The thing is now that was a big turn,
right? You use those those gold tokens.
>> That makes your orange kind of way
worse.
>> True. Using the gold gear tokens takes
away might from your own. And I wonder
if there is more ways to just
effectively get might on it. I mean with
the black market broker, you kind of
have an infinite combo of playing out
Teemo, getting it back to hand, and then
hiding it again.
>> So you can make one gold token every
single turn.
>> Sona is being played into the Wild Mo's
layer battlefield.
>> That is also I mean you're getting so
many runes ready at the end of the turn,
but if you're in Vmor's layer, you lose
a lot of flexibility. Well, that was a
sprite token. Where did that come from?
>> Have we moved to Teemo's turn? That
Sona's untapped four, right?
>> Yeah, we're on Teemo's turn now again.
>> Yeah, I maybe I missed it, but I think
he only tapped untapped two. Too too
used to playing Annie.
>> Maybe maybe I missed it. I I will say
that there is uh there's a lot of cards
that we don't typically see in this
game. Uh and a lot of like plays that
I'm I'm as I said too far down the
rabbit hole on on Teemo. So, it's it's
it's a very interesting game for our
second feature matchup of the day.
>> How many cards do you reckon we have in
the discard pile on the side of of Treel
K? Because
>> enough to start playing Rases. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> But do you even have to That's the the
interesting thing. I think with cards
like Singularity in your hand,
>> you can just Yeah. start removing your
opponent's your opponent's point
gainers, which is the Sona and the
Fiora. What do you have to answer this?
You don't have something like a Repost.
have used not so fast already last
>> I was going to say is there another not
so fast uh in hand
>> oh I love the aura from tragel just
looking at his opponent like
>> is it
>> what do you have here
>> okay I've seen tapping three I'm
wondering whether you're going wind well
it is Shen it's another card that I saw
in the the deck list here
>> yeah Shen is really cool it's can be a
reaction play just it's the opposite of
Renga pouncing
>> yes yeah
>> so it can go up to a five might defender
right now
>> important ly the shield only goes on
when you are defending. So this at this
point is just to hold the battlefield
>> as the units die. So it won't do
anything to save the two units being
singularity, but it is enough to say,
okay, well, I'll get a point on my turn.
And also, you can't really contest it.
Three might against five might
>> here currently on on board.
>> Not just dice to wages of pain.
>> True. Because yeah, outside of combat,
uh, wages of pain will just kill Shen.
We've also decided to play so many of
our runes yet. I think we have one
rune floating. We have one energy
floating because we played the cult. Oh,
no. We just took one that we used for
singularity. Never mind that. But I
think you would really have to start
getting those gold gear tokens up again.
I think that we could, you know, play
the Teemo.
>> Mhm.
>> Bounce it back, hide it again, get a
gold gear token from black market
broker.
Then we're chilling.
It is uh
quite a
compared to Draven matchups, I will say
little bit more complex on the like
having to think outside the box for
options. Like Draven and some of the
other meta decks are very like well I'm
just going to contest and I know what
I'm doing every single turn. This one is
just like you have a Shen in hand. Okay,
cool. Right.
>> When do I use my Shen versus team?
>> Yeah. When does Janna come out? Um we
we've seen people playing around uh
Janna and Vile Moore layer as well or
not playing around it uh in in previous
tournaments as well. So there's a lot to
think about in in this one. Um a lot of
variance compared. But this is a nice
thing. Again, both of these players
likely aiming uh for minimum a best off
card. There are also obviously
qualifications to the regional
championship later in the year on the
line here. The further you get in the
tournament, the better chance you have
of that. And I mean, everyone here is
here to win in some way uh as well. Like
everyone would love to be raising the
trophy at the end, but you know, the the
other options of trying to be the best
Leona or the best Teemo at the event
certainly allow you something else to
play for.
>> Definitely, especially Teemo. It's such
a fan favorite. I want to say people
love Teemo. Some other people don't.
>> People love to hate Teemo as well. Uh so
he's definitely uh British people would
say the Marmite of uh of League of
Legends. I I just love Teemo. He's such
a little rascal.
>> You're not a Teemo hater?
>> No. No.
>> Okay.
>> And I' I've played a lot of Shen in my
life on top lane and I still like Teemo.
>> Sergeon Shen being the uh my favorite.
Uh
>> phenomenal.
>> Really old skin. I'm sure there are
better ones these days, but
>> I don't think so. I like some of the OG
ones. We're stacking the deck again on
the side of treasure case. So, another
big turnway can possibly be push. So, do
we at this point, our opponent, how many
cards does loaded bag have in hand? This
looks like a solid four cards. Lar Shen,
would you even go for a watcher if you
had one? Because now you're straight up
chilling. Now, we're playing out the
Teemo. We get the black market broker.
Play a card from hidden. You get the
gold token.
>> It happened so so long ago. I had kind
of half forgotten that that Teemo was
played from the champion zone and we
knew what it was the entire time.
Fatigue. Fatigue is a real thing. You
can then also use the Teemo legend
ability to put it back in your hand. So
that's the other thing is you can kind
of like float it, rotate it back all the
way through and then you hide it again.
Is it the Teemo or is it is it my third
copy of Switcheroo?
>> It's infinite gold gear tokens and it
also funnily enough works like a better
combat trick now because then it's going
to get you a gold gear token when your
opponent is attacking.
>> It got hidden cuz I sort of consult the
past in hand as well. So it's like I'll
bring it back up. I'll play it. I'll
I'll play it back again. Now you don't
know what it is. Yeah, there's so many
mind games
and chaos games with Teemo.
>> This is also one of the reasons why if
you're playing Teemo locally, I would
suggest you use the same color sleeve
for your champion as well. I know a lot
of players like to try and differentiate
for their chosen champion so they don't
forget it, you can't do it. So, make
sure you're using the same sleeve cuz
you can shuffle it into hand and it
disappears.
>> You know, non-competitive Ariel, people
are a little bit more relaxed on that.
>> Not with team. you're just giving
yourself a massive disadvantage because
>> the big strength of Teemo is just that
your opponent does not know what you are
hiding. Sometimes your opponents play
around a Teemo and then you have a
consult the pass and you hold a
battlefield with a two drop for no
reason.
>> Again, we're going to reasons I don't
play Teemo.
Reasons that I'm not running this.
>> You don't have to sweat if you're
playing Teemo. It's just you're the
opponent.
>> That That's very true. Uh lot of runes
up for Leona. a lot of availability to
just like dive deep in uh whatever end
game power you have in your deck.
>> He really found his center in the last
turn, right? Twice. So, ramping up, but
what can you do? Leona is such a
reactive deck. Your units, they are not
known for big pushes and Treas
the break point, right, where you are at
60, you have it so easy to just conquer
two battlefields at the same time.
Teemo's breakpoint is at seven because
you're sitting on an orange with a
hidden Teemo and a black market broker,
gold gear tokens. This is this is
gluttony almost.
>> Yeah. And speaking of gluttony, some a
character in the game that I'm sure is a
little bit gluttonous itself, but um I
talked a little about not having fast
units for Leona. Looking at the deck
list, there are Tasty Fay folks in the
main board here. So that ability to get
out onto a battlefield quite quickly at
least allows Leona to play late game. uh
you know obviously tasty fay folk kind
of mid game into late game for that
ramping death nail effect but when that
is there it's not big enough yet that
I'm that you'd be too worried about it
there is a tasty fay folk somehow
theition coming through I'll be honest
whenever I see a green deck have this
many uh runes available I'm like it's
probably going to go towards tasty fay
folk at some point
>> but I mean loaded back can't even
accelerate it I mean technically it
could but for what reason because you're
not going to conquer in the trifarian
war camp goes up to Seven points on the
side of Tragel K. So many runes open.
And now the thing is there is only a
Shen defending on the other side. So can
you just remove that Shen? There is four
runes open. Do you just go for
singularity? Fight or flight. Everything
is an option. You have the Azreel in
your base as well. Teemo is so close to
just winning the first game with a quick
and swift two and0. We're even giving up
a gear.
>> So that is Singularity on both.
This would, as you said, clear out both
battlefields. Four runes available.
>> Oh, that looks like a not so fast.
>> Not so fast.
>> But there is other cards that Tragel K
could have. Now, the question is, do you
go into combat and then press the fight
or flight button or do you do it
preemptively to force out maybe
something like another Shen or another
card that you haven't thought about
because I think for Shen, we don't have
enough.
>> Fight or flight is tricky because it it
does lose to defy in in many situations.
It's like there's a lot of cards now
when you when you tumble down the uh the
cost of spells, there's more options to
actually deal with them.
>> But if you do it preemptively,
>> yeah,
>> before combat,
>> then at least you're okay.
>> You're you're seeing the defy. You're
like, "All right, you know what? Other
game plan." If you're waiting for combat
and you push the Ezreal into a losing
combat, fight or flight gets defied, you
actually might find yourself in a not so
optimal spot anymore. So, I really like
the play of using some of these combat
tricks, some of these actions just
somewhere on your turn.
>> And that was a pass saying, "Okay, well,
I I I can actually save the fight or
flight as a defensive use on my turn."
>> Cuz if you're only coming in with tasty
faithful potentially could accelerate
another one if there is another one in
hand, but if you're only coming in with
one unit, then suddenly it's it's not so
scary with a fight or flight. I force
you to have the Defy in hand. And we
know there's a Teemo hidden there. That
adds more to the battlefield. Do we?
>> We know. We know. This time it it got
played out of hand and we uh we I paid
attention more attention than I did to
the first time.
>> So, Treasure K just waiting for this
turn to possibly be over. It's
interesting. It's It's so cool to see
how different players approach the game
where I would have considered, hey,
there is just a Shen. You have used your
not so fast here. I'm trying to see if
you have a defy with the fight or flight
and try to see if I can win the game
immediately. Treasure K just decides to
just go for the more patient route.
>> That is true cuz when your opponent only
has two runes left available, then
there's like I I guess defy really is
the only option at that point that that
saves the game.
>> Well, if WK would also do it so many
stun
>> if you fight or flight it first that
would be a clear battlefield, right? If
you fight off flight, we're talking
about fightlighting Shen.
>> Yeah, exactly. But then if you push your
Ezreal in stunnes. Yeah. Yeah. No,
you're totally right. Um but
>> yeah, I think holding is a good shout.
Maybe you could even consider pushing
the Ezreal into the Trafarian Walk.
>> Leona, the chosen champion comes through
as
>> Nice. That's a big one.
>> This is where she enters ready. That's
another point that I uh actually omitted
earlier about ready units when your
opponent is within three points. So now
there is potency to come back in with
these big late game units. Um I feel
like that was definitely something I
underestimated was Leona from behind
actually does have quite a lot of pace
to get out onto the battlefield. But I
also like that Treasure G kept the fight
of flight for this because uh
>> the thing is if you move that Leona into
a battlefield and you use the ability to
you know shrink the units that are
stunned that you're stunning in the
process if it gets pushed out for fight
or flight. It says the units here have
minus 8 might.
>> So I think the units just chill, right?
They just recover. They their might.
>> They don't go minus 8.
>> So Zenith played as well. So he's going
to get the stun off.
>> Are we considering to double deflect? I
think at this point does not necessarily
matter too much.
>> You got enough runes to do it.
>> Yeah. I mean this is Oh no, we are we
want to keep our runes alive here. So,
we are going to buff our Leona Zealot
and the black market broker
onto a stunner ring.
Do you What are you doing now? I mean,
you're going to react with the Teemo,
that's for sure if you have played the
diff the Teemo.
>> Yeah. So, Teemo comes
>> through.
I think a fight off light here could be
so important.
if you can get it off because that then
only loses to Defy or another not so
fast.
>> Yeah,
>> that doesn't lose to another stun card
because you just need to hold you don't
need to win combats here.
>> You just need to
>> Ah, and importantly being on Vilemore um
fight or flight
>> is uh true won't actually
>> doesn't even work. Yeah,
>> really good shout.
>> Twitch must have been raging about that
>> probably. Sorry. Probably. Uh although
now we get rid of the zillot
fight has been played. So
>> So we're pushing it out of the Trafarian
War camp and now we're going to see how
this combat resolves.
>> Yeah, sorry. I uh the board state was uh
>> very intriguing. It is. It is indeed. So
the tasty fa folk is going to threaten
with six might. We have the black market
broker who should be at three again.
>> Yeah, we have the on. And if we decide
to reveal our hidden teemo, then we're
going to get another gold gear token
exhausted. That is going to make the on
a little bit bigger. So it gets one
extra might. So then we should be at a
combined 12.
Oh, there's more runes being used.
Exhaust. Another zenith plate.
>> Another zenith plate. Wow, that is a
push if I've ever seen one.
>> That is uh pretty great. I don't know
whether you could say it's top decking
cuz we haven't seen a whole lot of draw
recently, but uh Zenith Blade coming
back in does not care about your fight
or flight anymore then.
>> Yeah, that is just absolutely massive.
And I think this is one of those points
where Leona really shines because
>> you've read Zealot, right? If your
opponent is very close to winning the
game, it enters ready with such a
powerful effect if you get to stun your
opponent's units as well.
>> So this this deck, it's a little bit too
stressful for me, right? You have to get
your opponent very close to winning the
game to defeating you and then you can
start your power plays.
>> So you won't have those easy games where
you're just sweeping through your
opponent many times.
Well, but now what are we doing? I think
we're we're just counting. But there is
no way that you're beating that Leona.
>> Yeah. No, not with especially both
stunned. You just uh
>> not get the gold to. There we go.
>> There it is. Yeah.
>> But then again, completely exhausted
runes on the side of loaded bag. You
just need one more point. Unfortunately
for Trekk, you're not going to get it
from just taking out that Shen. But all
of a sudden, Leona is at six points too.
So if you're getting a double hold here,
game's immediately over. Also, Leona
Zealot is buffed now, so that means
Singularity is not an out anymore. All
of a sudden, the tides may have turned.
>> Yeah, certainly. Uh, it does feel that
way. Teemo in not the best spot here.
Has to try and recover. I mean, at this
point, are we just trying to draw into
Watcher? Does Watcher even do it? Um,
looking at that battlefield, I have to
run some math. I don't think alone it's
enough. It would have to be like
Watcher, Ezreal clears one battlefield.
Is there a way to have enough runes to
clear both?
>> I think Watcher plus Ezreal clears
clears that battlefield. Actually,
>> I'm just wondering whether you can clear
both battlefields. Like if you get Wages
of Pain and Watcher, Watcher plus Ezreal
clears one battlefield and Wages of Pain
deals with the Shen, maybe then the
following turn you can deal with it, but
then you kind of have to have another
unit, another Watcher.
>> Your opponent is so out of steam, I
don't even think you need to clear the
other battlefield.
>> You just hold with Watcher and Ezreal.
Yeah, that's true. Exactly. So stack
deck is trying to find this last push.
This thousand health watcher really
dramatically revealing the cards to
himself. I think fountain mind that
might not be the big drop that you're
looking for but rebuke is one of the
best removal spells in this game.
Bouncing a card from a battlefield to
the hand immediately.
>> Oh my goodness. And we have another
called shot there. So we're going to
recycle this. We're digging. We're
digging there. So it it doesn't cost
past that. There is a watcher.
Immediately goes to hand.
>> That's a very quick.
>> Now you're like, "Okay, if the watcher
doesn't do it, what's my second one? Can
I find another watcher just to to put
the nail in the coffin in the following
turn?" But called shot being done.
Repeated the repeat one coming for free.
There was the first one that was all he
needed.
>> Yeah.
>> Should be able to turn this at least
back into Teemo's favor.
>> Yep. And we also only need to pay.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, what are we deciding? Are we going
to recycle more cards?
>> Yes. Okay. So, we have
>> Yeah, it was seven and two recycled. So,
keeping up two
and two chaos runes.
>> And now we're counting again. We are in
Trifarian Warham. Keep that in mind.
>> So, Leona is at 8 right now. The Tasty
Fay Foc is at 82. They're going down
three. So, both are at five. So easy 10,
but of course you have 10 on your base
as well. You're in trifarian war camp as
well if you want to push them in. So
that would leave you at a decent amount
too. Then the thing is you are basically
only holding within Ezreal. Is that even
enough to win the game? Your opponent is
going to be at seven points as well. If
they manage to push something into the
Terrafarian walk, they have the shot at
winning the game. But then again also
you can't really just
let it stay here. The other option is if
you think your opponent your opponent
has used double zenith blades. So
>> yeah, you think there's probably at
least
>> if there is one more then it's unlikely
to be available yet. Leona hasn't drawn
that much through the deck.
>> We've seen two not so fast as well if
I'm not completely mistaken. So I think
just pushing for the Shen, not giving
away so many units and then stacking
into the vile moors layer sounds
fabulous.
>> Yeah. And then you you at least I'm
trying to think of like what even is
available that would
come in and be fast enough. Things we're
also getting another draw. We have two
runes open. I think that a great play
here would be to recycle one of your
runes to hide a card in there. Not use
your team champion ability.
>> Oh, we're actually playing a Raza. We
have so many cards in our stack then
just for free. Are we playing another
one of those? This is Oh my goodness.
This is such a big battlefield now.
>> Now just recycle another one. Are we
hiding cards? Yes, of course. Throw
another one in there. We're passing. We
still have two runes left open for a
possible rebuke. A fight of flight. So
many good
>> chaos. We know we know that there's a
rebuke that was drawn earlier in the
turn. So, uh that is certainly available
for Charel K.
There's uh that is a massive hold and I
don't know if there's enough
>> in the tank for Leon. Was there
>> I mean that is that just really does not
look like a lot of pushes. We're going
to reveal our hand and loaded back
conceds the match.
>> Loaded bag conceds. Our team of player
does indeed win
>> their first round here in Bolognia with
a very interesting and and and dynamic
matchup is I think the way that I would
put it. uh one with a lot of
interactions that that are less familiar
uh with a lot of the decks that we see
in the meta. So uh that was quite a
learning experience for me on seeing
exactly how that played out. Uh there's
a lot of lines that could have could
have been woven throughout it.
>> I'm such a big fan of the strategy that
he pulled off with the or that just
keeps getting boosted by those gold
tokens with the black market broker and
you have the possibility to just loop
your team chosen champion unit. Put it
back to hand. Hide it again. Play it.
Put it back to hand. Hide it again. You
can generate gold tokens for forever.
This is this is infinite gold. I feel
like this is what uh this is what it's
all about.
>> Well, I want to hear more from a player
that actually played Teemo rather than
us here trying to figure out what's
going on along the way. So, we have a
winner interview with our winner from
round one.
>> And welcome back. I'm here with the
winner of our feature match tragic with
a 20 with Teemo to start off the day.
Why Teemo?
>> I mean, Teemo is
wonderful. Uh, he has a lot of mechanics
and uh I mean, I like mushrooms, so why
not
>> planting some?
>> Absolutely. Honestly, I think that's a
vibe. Just vibe space picked it. And
honestly, it's proving to do really well
at the beginning of the day. How do you
feel now that you've got that first game
out of the way and you're on that
victorious
loop?
>> Oh, hopefully. Uh, I mean it's it feels
good. Uh, I was a bit stressed. You're
on T stream, you know. Uh,
I'm playing against Leona, so I didn't
train too much on that matchup, but it
went well. Um, and yeah, I'm happy. So,
I can start even uh it's like I had a
buy, you know,
>> right? Exactly. But it's not uh it's
like uh yeah, we have to to go through
seven of the games. So, we'll see what
happens.
>> You're right.
>> I hope it goes well.
>> It's a long day, but you've got through
almost the hardest part. You've got
through that first match on TV.
>> 200. Exactly. On stream. The hidden
mechanic is something I really love
about Teemo. Do you think people will
underestimate that today?
>> Uh I don't think people underestimate
it. I think uh they know that you can
hide like a lot of things. Uh it makes
people think a lot more than in other
matchups. So yeah, I think uh matches
takes more time and yeah, maybe a bit of
stress of what is going on on the
battlefield. So yeah, uh I like the
mechanics. Uh I hope that other sets
will bring more uh hidden cards. So
yeah, it's nice mechanics.
>> Absolutely. I think you really
appreciate that as well. The best of
that
is something that you were thinking
about when choosing Teemo.
>> Uh yeah, I think that Teemo is a
powerful deck uh in the meta right now.
It's not one of the most powerful, but
it can do a few things. So yeah, metal
was on the way uh on the look, I mean.
Uh, so I hope it goes well. Yeah, I
think you have to go to the day two if
you want uh metal teemo. So I try my
best and go for it.
>> You've got a long way to go, but I'm
confident that Teemo will continue to
bring you strength to strength and I
hope that all of your hidden mechanics
work out for you. Thank you for joining
us, Tragic, and good luck in your next
round.
Oh,
you
Hello and welcome back to the le Oh,
wait. It's not the LEC, is it? It's
Riftbound here. RQ Bologna. I'm Medic.
I'm joined by Amy. It is great to see
you all as the better Cara Duru and more
color coordinated Caru takes to the
desk.
>> I'm so excited to be here. Thank you for
joining us as well, medic. Honestly,
your insight is going to be impervious
today. We are ready to rumble, but not
with a rumble deck in this round. But
there are going to be twists and turns
>> that there are that they are. We'll get
to the decks that we are facing off with
in just a moment's time. But first,
we're going to have a look at some of
the casters favorites and some of our
meta picks for this weekend. I'm trying
to remember exactly what I picked. Ah,
what a surprise. Speller and my favorite
combo coming out from Spirit Forge. The
fact that you can give orn deflect 4,
the fact that you can equip the speller
really easily with fire below the
mountain. I'm just a huge fan of
generally. I know you are, but I've got
to take just the spotlight away for a
minute to talk about Jace and how their
fantastic combo can just align with the
supposedly expensive to cast Vanguard
Armory, but actually Jace completely
reduces that cost and then you get this
fantastic gear in play permanently
unless someone decides to do something
about that. And you just get to have
consistent recruit tokens.
>> It's so good. It's girl math at its
finest. If we can get a discount
somewhere, you know, we are planning a
discount. Yeah, 100% off. Yeah,
>> I'll take it 100%.
>> We will talk about Leo's and Jameses a
little bit. Pit crew cull. Such a good
combination. When you move in with pit
crew, you get the cull from the conquer
trigger that makes a gold that then
readies the pit crew. We see it a lot in
the Ezreal rat deck or the Ezreal mouse
deck depending on how aggressive you're
feeling with the small furry animals.
And then for James, he's gone with Vex
and Fizz Trickster. Fizz just so good in
these chaos decks where you're able to
recur and recur and recur.
>> Exactly. And chaos is so strong at the
moment. We know that having that
recursion of resources, it makes the
discard pile a secondary draw pile.
>> Yeah, it really does. These are some of
our meta MVPs as well. As you can see, I
went for treasure hunter. I think the
ability to make gold is overpowered. And
then Ferris 4runner. We're seeing a lot
of it. It works really well. There are
decks that play it just because it's the
only way to beat another Ferris 4Runner.
I know Rexside decks are doing that. So
I think treasure hunter the the ability
to get a bunch of power is so impactful
in the current meta.
>> I agree it, you know, costs are
expensive and if we can reduce those
>> it's more girl maths.
>> It's more girl math and it's just
working out better for us. The easier it
is for you to reduce your cost, the more
efficient your gameplay is going to be.
I went for Draven, of course, one of the
big bad boys of this meta, showing that
he really does have what it takes to
take this league all of the way.
Obviously, a very aggressive style deck,
drawing cards whenever combat takes
place. Draven is hungry for that combat.
And then I went for Aurelia, who kind of
then stands uh next to the decks who
want to be those spells slingers, and
she says, "Actually, I got this." And
she just gives them a run for that
money. So, I've gone for that contrast.
Yeah, I think the thing with Aelia is it
takes a little bit of brain power to
play, which is why I don't tend to play
it. But also, it's about making sure you
have protection for her. I think a lot
of Aelia players when they're starting
off with a deck will play Aurelia cuz
it's like, oh, I can play her now and
then not have the defensive tools from
Karm to actually back it up, not have
the energy to play those.
>> Exactly. And that's what you need. You
need to kind of protect the princess in
that scenario where you're actually
like, uh, maybe holding back is the way
to be and then use my resources later.
>> Yeah. It sounds foolish to me, though.
And I know in in the next couple of
matchups we have decks that don't really
want to hold back too much. We expect we
know we have a Draven and an Annie.
Annie obviously kind of mid-rangey at
the moment likes to flood the board with
those units and then kind of overpowers
her opponents. Draven you can go for the
miracle route which is a little bit less
consistent but a little bit more aggy.
Or you can go towards mid-range and look
for those mind spplitters, look for that
late game insurance. So I'm really
looking forward to seeing how this
matchup goes. It's going to be a couple
of seconds before we do have it on your
screens. Honestly, I'm really excited
for this one, especially because the two
decks with their sideboarding
opportunities have very interesting
decisions to make. Do we include more
mind spitters? Are we going for that
aggressive stance? Do I need to stop my
opponent from having the cards in hand
to take this back? Because it's two
really aggressive builds of deck. And it
it does feel like two rams butting
heads.
>> It's quite funny considering battering
ram is in the Draven deck.
>> Oh, we got there. Yeah, mostly right in
the miracle deck. A relatively new
introduction into it. I think a lot of
people when they saw Draven at the start
of Spirit Forge were looking towards
more mid-rangey variants. And then as
the miracle package, this chaos package
really came to the four, people saw, oh,
bannering ram, I can play it on turn
two. I can play it like
>> if I just play a couple of cord shots
and a a stack deck, then I'm there. You
know, uh it makes it very easy to get
out early.
>> And when is drawing cards not a good
thing? You're just giving your deck
>> 10 times the consistency, but can you
get to those combos in the right order?
And that's what it all comes down to.
>> It's a good question. It's a good
question. Let's get on into our second
round of the day here in Bologna as we
see Draven take on Annie. I will say
just so that you all know at home, I am
controlling some of the graphics. So, if
there are mistakes with the graphics,
it's entirely on me. The production
staff here are amazing. They've been
doing an amazing job, but I'm the one
pressing the buttons and often means I
make mistakes. Let's have a look at this
Annie deck list. Uh it it if you are on
the feature match area, we get to have a
look at your deck list, so it is
relatively open. Nothing too surprising
here from Annie. I like the invert
timelines. I think the ability to get
more card draw later on in the game is
really powerful.
>> Yeah, we've it's a very typical Annie
build and that's not a bad thing. Annie
is strong. We've seen it from Origins.
She's coming through and bringing all of
this early game pressure with that heavy
sneaky deck hand. Making sure that
you're scoring early and then trying to
keep in it.
>> Yeah, Annie, one of those decks that
doesn't always play around her champion
unit and there are a few of them in in
in the meta, but I think Annie
specifically, it is not uncommon to not
see Annie stubborn played at all. you
are playing around the colors that you
have and the package the domains give
you and the ability to look for as you
say the early sneaky deck hand if you're
on if you're playing second or even just
early card draw getting those noxious
hopes out as well and let's have a look
at this Draven list it does say that
Darius is the chosen champion that will
be Draven Vanquisher instead I assume
because you cannot play a Darius as your
chosen champion on a Draven deck
>> no but our glorious executioner
certainly here to make a statement.
Definitely one of the most anticipated
decks for this format. Something that
every deck is thinking, but how do I
beat Draven? That's the question on
everyone's mind. Will Annie be able to
do it with some early game pressure or
will Draven get that advantage? Both
decks are using very similar cards to
achieve this.
>> I was interesting to see the minur there
though, a couple of them in the main,
which it it can give you quite a lot of
power, but can also you don't always see
it in main. and often you see it sided
in. We also didn't see anything like a
bushwack for that readying at six where
you can pseudo accelerate a couple of
your units to go from six to eight. So,
we'll have to keep our eyes on exactly
how this Draven player is deciding to
play is kind of the miracle package with
that that chaos variant that we've been
seeing quite a lot. Start off with the
treasure hunter though. No real
surprises there on turn one. We're
playing at Dreaming Tree and Targon's
Peak.
>> Lovely. Okay, onto the Annie player. We
got the two power treasure hunter as
well there. Getting everything ready to
go. Draven going for gold here. Going
straight on in there. Getting that gold
token and a point. Taking the first
battlefield. That could be really really
strong for Draven. Taking that first
point away from Annie where Annie
prefers a lot of the time to be taking
that first point. Didn't quite get it
here. So unfortunately left with just
the traveling merchant right now. But it
looks like that might be all. It might
be that that is just a pass the turn.
But no, we're bringing in the Draven.
There he is bringing it onto the board.
Keeping it strong. Going with the heavy
unit. I can't blame him.
>> Crack out the vanquisher early. You
know, against Annie, you are going to
have a bit of a battle on the ground.
And so getting the vanquisher in your
base doesn't risk too much removal or
like too much bounce cuz it's not going
onto a battlefield anyway. you can then
buff it up later on. Draven Wangle
obviously very powerful for that. You
see the traveling merchant moving
forward for that discard. No real
surprises here. You want to be cycling
through your deck as much as possible
getting rid of a pouty porro after turn
one. You're not really using that too
effectively.
>> Looks like we're going a little bit slow
here with Annie. I can't really There's
a lot of reactive kind of spells and
gadgets in hand, but no units that are
particularly strong right now. It's just
going to be a blind titan. I might move
the traveling merchant back here for the
extra draw. Discard. Switch it around.
You can also get the dreaming tree
trigger, I believe, because you chose
the traveling merchant, unless we've
already chosen it this turn.
>> Okay, so we got the
>> Oh, no. It's with a spell. It's not a
dream. Yeah, dreaming tree is with a
spell. That's entirely on me.
>> So, we got the Nox's hopeful off the top
deck there, which is great because we do
we can play that, but we haven't gone
for that yet. We're going straight on in
with the overzealous fan.
Yeah, gives you a little bit of removal
when it or at least uh
distraction at a battlefield. The
ability to bounce something back out
when you are uh looking for those
combats makes it harder for the Draven
to uh actually impact that dreaming tree
too much. You can see in hand we've got
the stack deck, we've got a Kaiser fight
or flight, a hard bargain, and the Brin
here. Uh I believe that was everything.
Oh, Tai Turner in there as well. So,
it's a solid hand. Brin here. Obviously,
you're using a little bit later on
trying to make sure that your opponent
can't get those spells and abilities
off. More of a closer in decks like this
than an early game piece.
>> Looking like we're in a strong position
here. If you're Draven, you've got two
gold in play now thanks to Traveling
Merchant moving around doing that thing,
collecting all that gold, and then we're
going to go in with that aggressive
stance
for our
>> first kind of real tussle of a
Battlefield takeover right now. So, just
doing the math there, figuring out how
big Draven is in comparison to uh
Gordo's
units.
>> Yeah, I think the big thing here is the
Draven can buff himself on the attack.
So, we saw a gold being removed there to
give the Draven plus two might
overzealous fan is then used on its
offensive trigger. Kill me, move an
attacking base, bounces the Draven back.
>> Ooh, Kaiser coming down, hitting the
board hard. They get a really powerful
unit just building up that base ready
for next turn. Yeah, and you you could
have accelerated the Kaiser here. I
don't think it does too much in and of
itself. You get control of a single
battlefield, but you're already at two.
We're playing to eight. So, you're kind
of comfortable saying, "Okay, as long as
I'm going up in these increments of two,
it makes it a little bit easier for me
to play out the rest of the game."
>> I also think, you know, you've got the
potential of removing some units from
Annie with the Kaiser. She's strong in
her own right and also gets that lovely
conquer uh draw ability. And so you'd be
able to continue to put the heat on
because at the moment we can see that
Annie is just drawing that little bit
short. We've got reactions. We've got
some smaller units, but nothing
hard-hitting right now. And that's going
to be really troublesome coming into
Draven and Kaiser.
>> Yeah, you can see using the cleave just
for the dreaming tree here. It's all
about trying to get that extra card draw
out. Haven't seen the stack decks.
Haven't seen the cord shots. Um,
>> nothing to help us cycle to those
important cards that we need for these
big combos to actually deal with Draven
at its hardest.
>> Yeah, exactly. Like the Traveling
Merchant kind of does it, but you are
you're looting more than anything.
You're discarding then drawing a card,
which means you are still thinning out
your hand as you thin out your deck a
little bit. It's not the easiest
position for the Annie overall. No real
combat tricks later. And you can see the
retreat of the Titan saying, "Okay, I
know that you're going to win this
combat or win this battlefield. I don't
want to give you a combat so that
Glorious Executioner then allows you to
draw that card.
>> Yeah, you're trying to reduce the amount
of cards that your opponent's managing
to draw while attempting to accelerate
that yourself. Going in with an Noxus
hopeful there. Of course, we got the
Legion effect, so it costs too fewer to
be able to play, which is even better.
So, we've got the four power, which is a
little bit better. We're getting into
the range now where a a champion battle
could take place that would actually
benefits Gordo.
>> Yeah, I think it's a a bit of a struggle
for Annie in this sort of position
because you do you do like to swarm a
little bit if you can. You like to have
stronger units on the battlefield. You
like to be able to remove your
opponent's units. And at the moment,
because the Draven player is just
playing this slight bit slower, you're
even on points. We're going into round
four, round five, and the Draven's units
are just stronger right now. It's a
Kaiser and a Draven Vanquisher.
>> Very difficult to play into. Let's have
a look at what uh I'm going to mess up
this name. Besides
Shazand
go by,
we'll go with that. Yeah, we'll go with
that. See what Bazer wants to do. Uh
still holding that brin here for later.
I will say, and this is this is a
disgrace. Like, why is your gold up
here? Why are we putting our gold this
far up onto the battlefield and there's
another one joining it? It's not at the
dreaming tree.
>> But what if it is?
>> But it's not. It's not. You're right.
It's not it's not being stashed.
>> Maybe that's a future battlefield where
you can stash gold there and get double
or something if you conquer it enough
times.
>> That would be clever, wouldn't it? Love
that. But for the time being, bring it
back into the moment. We've got
ferocious units ready to go. I imagine
this is going to be quite an aggressive
push at this point to try and put us up
to those four and five points. Really
taking over. And that's what this is
about. That's what this whole matchup is
about is pacing. And Bison has Zonda has
that in the bag right now. We're going
in with the Kaiser Survivor. She's
strong. She's ready. She really can't be
particularly contested here. I don't
think
>> it looks like we're going to have a
fight or fight.
>> Again, it's about denying that card
draw, right? Even though it's not a
combat because it's an open battlefield
that the Kis is going into, when she
conquers, she gets to draw a card.
>> And now we see the Draven going in as
the second option. It's like, does
Scordo want to keep using resources to
keep down? My expectation is no. And as
you can see, we now go up to four four
by Sand.
>> And that's what it's all about. You
could deny your opponent one thing, but
then actually, was that resource worth
keeping for later when it could have
been more impactful? I don't know. This
is a really tough situation. We're
bringing the Draven back, going in with
a tieer just to swap them around to keep
Draven safe. Tie Turner, a much kind of
squishier unit, but we don't mind that
in this situation, just being in the
dreaming tree, especially considering
the amount of cards that Draven has that
can buff units and get out of those
struggle situations in combat.
>> Yeah, it's also just making sure that
you're not leaving your units in a
position where they could be vulnerable
at all. Right. Why? If a Titaner dies,
not the end of the world. If if a
treasure hunter dies, not the end of the
world. If you're losing your Kaiser or
your Draven, you're getting a little bit
more concerned. And I think this is uh
one of the big level up steps for
players of Riftbound and one that I've
only recently really been learning is
>> in a lot of other card games controlling
the area and being in the fight is
important, but because in Riftbound you
can take a step back and then readvance,
often you want to be in your base and
then looking to score six to eight
rather than trying to hold from six to
eight.
>> That top deck was really lovely from
Scordo there. We've we've finally got
one of our bigger units, the Ferris
4runner, in the hand and and we've got
plenty of runes to be able to bring it
into play. But first off, I love this
sequencing of saying, "Okay, I'm going
to have all of my runes up. I'm going to
have everything in my pocket and I'm
going to just move this Nox's hopeful
into the tie turner and see how my
opponent reacts. I'm currently winning,
but what have you got in your hand that
could potentially push me back or say
no? But then you've got so much backup
and Bison Donsen knows that.
>> Yeah. Yeah. There's so many resources
still for Bison Z to work their way
through this. Believe the fight of
flight was played.
Uh get the draw from the dreaming tree
if you were targeting Tide Runner.
Obviously, you can just knock the notes
hopeful back as well, which makes more
sense in this situation. You want to try
and play for that whole point if you can
get it. Scordo taking their time,
thinking about exactly how they want to
approach this. You you're also you're
not just thinking about this turn, but
you're thinking about if I use a
resource here when Bison Zonda then goes
in with the Draven, goes in with the
Kaiser, how much trickier is it for me
later on? It's going to be a hard
bargain repeated. So, that's four energy
needed from Bison Zondo and it's paid.
does mean now Zonda is tapped out apart
from those two chaos runes for the rest
of the turn. And you can see Scorder is
like, well, I know you have the
resources for this, but I would like to
deny you from further plays on this turn
if I can.
>> And I think that's what it's all about
is using your resources, but also making
sure you're keeping an eye on what your
opponent can do. It's not just thinking
about how many do I need to play in my
turn. How many do I need to leave alone
for potential of a comeback from my
opponent? Especially in this matchup
where you have a lot of similar cards
that can push back at your opponent.
>> Yeah, I have to score a second. Going to
go move into the treasure hunter here.
Four might into one. Pretty one-sided in
terms of battles. Has the traveling
merchant trigger first as you can see
them pointing it out. I will say our
players today have been very good at
being very deliberate on this is what
I'm doing. This is how I'm doing it.
Make sure the sequencing is right.
Discarding a Ferris 4ERunner is
surprising.
>> Yeah, I would have thought that that
would be a great way to keep lots of
units in play, which is what Annie loves
to do is just swarm the board and kind
of overwhelm. And Ferris 4runner could
be really difficult to remove if not
dealt with efficiently. Again, as you
stated earlier, using a Ferris 4Runner
into a Ferris 4runner is very common for
that exact reason. It's a pain.
>> Yeah, there is a second one in hand as
far as I can see for Scordo. So maybe
just saying I don't need two six energy,
one red, one fury power costs to go
through. So now having a quick look
through the graveyard, we treasure
hunter does get killed off. It's another
point over to Scor currently sitting at
three, but Zonda does have more control,
especially with that Kaiser and the
Draven still sitting in base. We're
going to bring the Annie back which
allows us to recur a spell. currently
looking like it is going to be the fight
or flight, which makes sense. Again,
it's one of the key portions of this
game of this deck is the ability to
force unfavorable combats on your
opposition.
>> Yeah. And kind of just force that into
your own hand, push them back, give them
a struggle, make it difficult for them
to advance their really strong units to
be able to draw cards. And then if you
deny them that card draw, that
combination just can really make Draven
suffer. at the moment. Of course, uh,
Bison Zonda has gone ahead and gone up
to five now with that hold point from
the battlefield. And so, it's looking
quite one-sided in regards to points,
but that's what Annie can do in this
matchup is they can make this comeback
just by building this really strong
base, advancing forward, and just trying
to overwhelm Draven so that they can't
kind of take over both at the same time.
Slow them down a little. We're still
both in it to win it here. There's a lot
to play for, and both of these decks are
going for gold. They're going for the
win today.
>> Yeah, we've seen some Andex have really
good performances over in China.
Obviously, we talked a little bit about
it in the pre-show. The ability to have
played your legend for so much longer
than everyone else has played their
legend allows you just a little bit more
comfort in some of these matchups.
Obviously, Draven knew in Spirit Forge,
but Annie's been around for so long and
a lot of these cards have been key to
the deck for a while. Let's see where
Zonda wants to go. Vanquisher moving
forward. Looks like he's going to take
the battle at Taran's Peak. We'll have
the ability to sacrifice those golds to
Draven's trigger and put as many of them
on as you want. For now, it's just going
to be the one doesn't get the option to
do that again after you've declared this
is how many I'm doing. That's that. So,
it'll be six might Draven with all of
your runes available.
>> And that's the nice thing about this at
the moment. And they're trying to take
away target specifically because Annie
benefits so much from it. Being able to
ready four runes using the legend
ability and the battlefield at the end
of your turn just again gives you that
flexibility. Both of these players
aren't going, I've got an aggra
aggressive deck. I'm going to go into
battlefields and mess you up. What
they're saying is, okay, no, actually
there's more strategy to that than you
think. What I'm going to do is deny your
resources. And if I can just string you
along and make it so that I have more
than you, then we're golden. And that's
exactly what both of these players are
trying to do with kind of this tussle at
targets peak.
>> Okay, so Scor deciding to retreat out of
the situation going for the flash is
going to bring the tide turner and the
traveling merchant back. Will get a
discard draw trigger from the traveling
merchant as it does return. And I mean
Bison is like yeah sure if if that's
what you want to do. I have used a gold
to get here but I will take that trade
in totality. That's fine. Another Ferris
4runner getting discarded. I wonder if
there's one more in the hand or if
Scordo just doesn't really like the
Ferris in this matchup. Appreciate
production switching to the hand cam.
Scord not quite playing ball with us
there as they put their hand down on the
side. Fight or flight and assault are
the two options.
>> So, as a cleave and fight,
no, it's a very common
>> deduction of both cards. They do a very
similar effect. Uh I like the cleave in
this matchup. It's really cheap. It's
cheerful and it does achieve a lot. But
unfortunately, it just means that Scoro
could run out of units here. There is a
very large opportunity here for Bison
Donsa to just eke forward by being
aggressive, but they don't know that.
They don't know that that's the way.
>> I think also you have to give credit to
Bison for the patience cuz it would be
easy to look at this battlefield and
say, "Yeah, you know, I I have the more
I have more might. I have more power.
Let me play aggressively." But in the
end, Scor has two cards in hand. You are
you have a great board set. You've got
your Draven. You've got your Kaiser
still back in base. You know, if all you
do is score one point a turn for the
next few turns, you are in prime
position to win this game. So, playing
it a bit more patiently, accepting that
you're not going to get as many combats
as you want, putting more might in your
base, and then if you ever need to
overwhelm, if you ever need to have that
might advantage, you can play around it.
>> Absolutely. Here we go. Darius in effect
finally. Here he is.
We saw a peak earlier and now he's
bringing to the battlefield another very
strong unit.
>> But even not even going aggressive with
the Darius being like don't need to go
to Dreaming Tree. I'm happy. Yes, I you
get the second card trigger. You get him
ready. You get the extra two might. But
>> the Trafarian is very happy to trifle
his way back home. You know, he can just
stay in base.
>> And unfortunately, it looks like Annie
might have run out of steam here.
They're going to have to go aggressive
here. They need to stop that double
Battlefield takeover next turn. So going
in with Annie into that tie turder. A
three to a two. Looking pretty good. Can
Bison Zonda bring something to the table
to stop stubborn old Annie from taking
that battlefield? No.
>> It doesn't need to though. Yeah, you
again. It's four points to six. It is
not inevitable at this point, but very
tricky for Scordo to actually take the
win from this position unless they find
another cleave and an overextension from
Bice. Again, we'll move to five.
Traveling Merchant for the discard of
the traveling merchant to draw.
Hopefully not a traveling merchant. I
don't think it can be. I think this is
our third of the game. But uh for Bison
Zonda, as long as Scordo is not getting
a massive amount of draw, they're
actually in such an easy position to win
out from this spot.
>> They really are. That's all you got to
do. You got to get to eight points and
you want both battlefields in your
control on your turn. That is very much
within the possibility
>> right here, right now.
>> As soon as you see these plays where a
cleave is being played just for the
dreaming tree trigger, yes, you can't
use it for the attack anyway cuz you're
passing the turn. So you don't get the
assault trigger off it. You know you're
in a pretty good position because again
it's searching for this mystery card. It
was a Draven in hand for Scoroke. It's
going to put the Noxious Hopeful in onto
Taran's Peak as well, increasing the
might of that battlefield to seven. But
if you're buying Zonda, you can match
that with a Darius, assuming you play a
couple of cards before you go in for the
attack.
>> And I think that's the problem here is
that Scoro is going to be trying to buff
up these bases, get them really beefy to
really make um Vice Z have to work for
it. putting multiple units on both
battlefields, hoping that actually being
able to stand some more runes at the end
of the turn with Annie might just give
them the push they need. Going in with
the porro, the pouty porro as well
there. Really trying to get as much
power as we can on the board.
>> Yeah, I'm wondering how many fury runes
Scordo has. I think it's three cuz you
need to use your fury runes if you are
going to buff up that Draven when you
defend. So three runes gives you a plus
six in this position. and top
battlefield much more easily conquerable
with only that seven. We have the
recycle coming out there as well.
>> We'll see on readying. So, dreaming tree
much better defense for Scodo. You've
got two, four, six, 10, and then plus
however many of those fury runes, which
are four, five. Actually, in terms of
>> I don't think Scordo has any cards in
hand, though. I believe that hidden card
was the final card in hand. Okay,
>> so Scorto has these runes but can only
use them if something in play can
activate them because at the moment I
believe they have no cards in hand.
>> So what's the risk? Fight or flight onto
Scordo's Draven gets it out, meaning
that you then can't actually use its uh
ability to increase its power in the
defense. You then are probably hiding a
fight or flight of your own. Could be a
tide turner, but it doesn't really make
a huge amount of sense to I mean it
depends what he had in hand. I'm pretty
sure it was a fight.
>> Well, we saw the fight or flight cuz
they received that back, right? So, so
we we knew there was a fight or flight
in hand. So, it's very likely that has
to be it.
>> Oh, my my fingers are not big enough.
Oh, not small enough. F
>> O F. This is what we think it is, Chad.
>> Yeah. Fight or flight.
>> Fight or flight down towards that.
>> And that is impactful. And you know, B
said knows that that's what was taken.
And there we are. There's the activation
of the fight or flight. We kind of knew
that was coming.
>> But why not have it on the board at that
point? if it's going to have been in
your hand anyway and they know it's in
your hand, just put it down. It's a
shame that it doesn't leave anything to
the imagination.
>> There is a lot of mind play in these
games when you think about, oh, I've got
a card in my hand. Oh, look how many
runes I have available. And you think,
oh gosh, what could that be? What could
my opponent be hiding? But when they
have no cards in hand, you know, you can
kind of go for it and not have many
repercussions.
>> Yeah. Now, I think there's a discussion
happening about fight or flight
targeting traveling merchant, dreaming
tree trigger being on the stack cuz
you're targeting your unit with a spell.
So, you can actually stack it the
however you want, it seems. So, they
stack the traveling merchant at the top
of the chain, allowing them to discard
one, draw one when they had no cards in
hand. So, they just draw one and then
they draw from the dreaming tree, which
means that they get two card draws out
of that.
>> Brin here still there on the chain.
comes out
>> bringing in the pace now a reaction unit
at this time really snazzy
>> it's actually kind of the best unit they
could draw at this point because you
can't play any other cards this turn as
soon as that grin here is fully uh down
into play right so you needed something
that had reaction Rengar is the best way
to get it play it straight to the
battlefield you get that extra might the
assault doesn't actually apply in any
way right cuz you're on defense but now
Vice Zonda needs to have a real consider
about exactly how they're going to play
this turn. Use six runes for the Brin
hit now five and we're going to see the
Darius come down. Second card for turn
buffs them up to seven. So both those
Dariuses are now at seven and we'll both
be ready.
And we have quite a few fury runes as
well to buff up our Draven. And I think
it's going to be quite the overpowering
Dreaming Tree takeover here with both of
them going in those Darius just taking
over saying okay we us two we got this
against four units but actually the
power is overwhelming and they do have
it. There's the fist bump taking over by
Senz does take that game number one here
with our aggressive duo of Draven versus
Annie. Yeah, really good play all around
by vers Zonda. I like the patience at
the start. I think it was really
important to hold back, not allow your
Dar your Draven or your Kaiser to die.
And then the use of the double Darius
later on just superbly played,
controlling when they needed to control,
but also understanding you didn't need
to entirely hold those battlefields for
the the whole game to actually be able
to take the win.
>> Yeah, exactly. It's all about holding
back and then going, "Okay, right, my
guys are ready now. Here we are.
Everyone was having a party in base and
now it's time to strike." Yeah,
>> really important. We're wanting to deny
our opponents cards. Both of them
looking at those mind splitters. And
we're just
going to prevent your opponent from
doing the thing you want to do.
>> Yeah. A couple of dead cards in the
sideboards as well. Like
>> you can play factory recall, but who
really cares about bouncing a gold to
someone's hand, right? Angle shot not
really that powerful either with very
minimal equipments being played. I do
like the move, as you say, into more
later game threats like the
Mindsplitter. You could also look for
the Dariuses if you are the uh the
Escond, the Annie player. So, we'll see
exactly where they want to go. I
wouldn't be surprised if we see a
slightly a shift away from those lower
might units into something with a little
bit more inherent power from Scond.
>> Yeah, it would not surprise me at all.
And I think that's exactly where uh
where Scond kind of didn't have quite as
much to go with is just that we ran out
of speed. We ran out of units that were
big enough to deal with the threat that
Draven poses and we didn't see
Switcheroo. We didn't see the Ferris
4unners come into play and again they
can be really frustrating to deal with
because they they just they litter units
behind them when they're gone. So even
if you do deal with them,
>> actually they're still kind of there in
spirit and that makes it really
difficult to come back from and gives
you a backup. And I think that might
have been a nice play in that game one,
but game one can often be used as a way
to sus out your opponent's deck. It
doesn't necessarily mean the be all and
end all.
>> Oh yeah, definitely. And it I think one
of the issues playing into Draven decks
at the moment is they kind of do well
into everything in game one. Like you
can start to tech into them after that
point and we see some people doing that.
This is such a similar idea behind a
deck between these two decks that I'm
slightly worried for Scordo on the Annie
side. We'll have a look as we go into
turn one. It's a start peak and an
obelisk of power which is why you have
those three runes already for Scordo
playing the tie turner turn one. Not
really what you want to do, but it if
it's your two drop, if it's your two my
unit, you you have to get something down
so you can look for those early
conquers. Control the battlefield early.
full four furies for the glorious
executioner himself. Not really what you
want to see, but early on again, you're
not looking for those power costs of
things like the rebuke. So, you don't
really care too much about the fact that
you haven't been able to pull any of
those chaos.
>> Draven down early gives a really
positive outlook to that ferociousness
of the deck. Being able to say, "Okay,
well, you have your Tai Turner. You
might be able to score first, but I'm
immediately going to come back and be
aggressive with that if I need to."
going with another TI turner.
Unfortunately, these just low kind of
power units unfortunately aren't super
helpful in this moment and also means we
can't use their hidden effect later in
the game.
>> Not going in to one of those
battlefields with that tie turner
knowing that it's going to lose to the
Draven immediately and then you're
giving Draven not only a card from the
Glorious Executioner, but also a gold
gear token cuz they've won the combat.
That is one of the issues when you're
playing into Draven decks is you have to
be so aware of when you can look for
combats, when you can actually look for
fights and when you can leave units out
on the battlefield. We start to see a
little bit of card draw here from Draven
going for that stack deck. Not something
we saw a huge amount in game one. No one
really got into that miracle package
that we've been talking about a little
bit. I'm still not a massive fan of
miracle. I'm going to say not not the
the deck archetype, although I think
there's, you know, problems there. The
naming convention here. Why are we
calling things miracle? It's not miracle
from MTG.
>> That was stolen by Hearthstone players
and they decided to call it Miracle
Rogue. It wasn't Miracle Rogue and like
it's not you are playing Draven
>> and you have a deck that you go through
very rapidly. That's not miracling.
>> No,
>> there's no miracles happening here.
>> If anything, it's just like a harsh card
draw mechanic. Like it's just card draw
Draven. Card Draven card
>> Dven card draven. The problem is card
Draven like all decks are card decks.
>> Yeah, true. I know. That's what I'm
saying. Like it's difficult.
>> Uh regardless of Navy Conventures aside,
we've got a Kaiser Survivor as well.
Very similar to that game one now going
in with a really beefy unit, not having
any pressure to go into a battlefield
too early, allowing Scordo to take that
first point knowing that you can come
back with quite the bang. So, and then
draw cards and we're winning combat.
That's what Draven wants to do, win
combat. Scoro's taking the other
battlefield as well, trying to just now
do what Annie does best and gain points
early and try and hold a lead.
>> Yeah, also looking for the ability to
flash later on, the ability to put down
a traveling merchant, use that flash,
get units back. I didn't quite catch
where the other cards were in hand, but
you don't if you flash your units out of
a combat, then uh the Draven does still
get the draw trigger, right? It's they
still win the combat even if they
haven't uh even if you haven't got units
there after the combat has been started.
It's one of the ways Draven uses like
fight or flight or rebuke to win those
combats automatically without actually
having to outmite you. Traveling
merchant down. I expect to see a flash
at some point from Scoro just to get
that back to base. And uh you don't
really want to just chuck a traveling
merchant onto the obeliska power and
sack it. Although there is an argument
if Kaiser goes in there, it's for
mightite to form might. So there's a a
harder decision to be made for Bison
Zomb.
>> Absolutely. But there's a lot of tricks
up their sleeve yet and with a lot of
open energy to use those runes are ready
to rumble. Let's see how Darius is going
to go into that tide turner. Looks like
yes, we are going to go ahead and spend
and recycle to be able to buff the unit.
Expecting a comeback from Scoro. And
here we go in with Rebuke. Lovely.
>> And that will bounce straight back to
Bison Zand's hand.
>> Yeah, I like the rebuke here. You know,
you're looking for a hold. It also means
that Bison Zonda cannot get two of those
combat wins on a turn. Can't conquer the
battlefield and get a card draw from
winning the combat. But we'll see if
this Kaiser decides to go towards start
tip peak as well.
>> I I really like this uh flipping the
room when you've used it as a power
cost. By the way,
>> you can still use that energy. It's just
shown that energy is in the pool.
Thankfully, in Riftbound, the energy in
the pool remains for a long time until
the end of turn until your end of your
draw step, I believe. Uh so for now,
they are just happy enough to sit there.
Another combat being initiated down to
star tit peak and scor must have seen
this coming. He's so aware after the
after the Draven comes in. You bounce
the Draven. Are you going to look to
bounce this as well? Nope. Just going to
flash the tie tunner. Probably going to
look Oh, both the tie tunners.
Interesting. I wondered if it was going
to be the traveling merchant for the
discard draw, but maybe Scor just happy
with their hand right now. just wanting
to move things back, knowing that kind
of there's a lot of aggression from the
other side of the board and thinking,
okay, well, I just need to be able to
hold units on the board, which was
something he struggled with in game one
was just keeping them around long
enough, right, to be able to then deal
with the fact that Draven's huge when he
wants to be.
>> And there is the legend ability trigger.
Draven and Kaiser will draw two cards
here.
>> Ooh, that is phenomenal.
drawing cards gives you so much more in
your pool, allowing just to be able to
kind of have everything that you need.
Like there's a lot of cards in the deck
that we're probably not going to see and
two right at this stage near the
beginning when we've just had a push
back with our Draven back to hand.
>> Absolutely phenomenal. Yeah, piercing
light coming out here from by Sandra,
which I didn't catch if it was repeated,
but
>> I think it was based on kind of the
targets that are being selected.
>> Yeah. So, the reason that you repeat
this is you target the traveling
merchant twice because you have to
target a unit out of battlefield. So,
you say, "Okay, I'll do two unit to this
traveling merchant and two to another
unit, the tie turner. And then I'll also
do two units to this traveling merchant
and two to the other tieer which is at
base." So, uh, I think obviously it
looks like there was a a slight question
with the judge there to make sure that's
how you can do it. I believe that is how
you can put it on the chain, but I am
not a level one judge, unlike you, Amy,
and unlike obviously our judges here
very experienced with all of this.
>> But honestly, that would be a great play
wiping the board. Annie literally just
kind of signaled to their opponent, oh,
I want to bring these back and secure
them. I want to keep them safe. But
actually if you can go ahead and target
those in base and that's one of the
risks. Base isn't a stronghold. It's not
a safe space necessarily. Can be
targeted with spells quite often
actually more so in these chaos builds.
>> Yeah, I think it often you do look at
your bases. It's safer than a
battlefield is what I'll say. Right.
Often you can a lot of spells are
targeting things at battlefields
especially direct damage spells do do
that. But then you have things like
bellow's breath. You have things like
piercing light. Um, fidget touch as well
in combination with a bell's breath is
so powerful. So, especially when decks
can interact with your base, it becomes
a lot harder to actually make sure that
you are keeping things safe. And yep,
>> there they go. Unfortunately, off to the
discard pile as we see entire board
decimated by Zen Zonda there. Wow. And
now free rain. Really, we're going to go
get a Titan in swapping with Kaiser
Survivor. We've seen it before. The
Titan is brilliant at doing that.
protecting those heavier units, allowing
them to just sit at the battlefield. And
that's exactly what they love to do, sit
there pretty and try and hold the fort.
But Scoro is going to have to really
work hard now, not only to get units
into play, but also push them into those
battlefields in time.
>> Yeah, we're sitting in a very similar
position to the position we were in in
game one, right? Like Bison Zonda is
very happy just to sit back in base,
play these defensive units, the Kaisers
and the and the Dravens that can be
aggressive. And
>> to match that, you kind of have to you
kind of have to yourself. Yeah. going to
accelerate out. Paying the extra one
energy and fury power to get that onto
this battlefield onto start peak.
There's still a couple of runes and
fight or flight.
>> There we go. Push
>> onto it. Yeah,
>> we're not having it. Not today, Kaiser.
Back you go. You might have come in
accelerated, but conquering and drawing
one. That's a step too far. We're going
to fight off light and push that back.
>> It's sort of having a think about how
they want to react to this. It's not a
huge amount that you can do in this sort
of situation to stop that fighter fight
going out. Hard bargain would be the
option and there aren't runes available
for Bison Zonda, but because again it's
another combat,
>> you get the win for Tie Turner, right?
So, it's another card draw coming out
for Bison Zonda. You don't get a point
for winning that combat cuz you you get
a point now for holding.
>> Uh you'll be happy enough there for
Bison Zonda to be at that two and to
have drawn that extra card from a combat
initiated by your opponent.
>> Exactly. And that's exactly what you
want to do is just benefit of every
little thing that your opponent gives
you, even if it's a combat on their
turn. And thankfully, we were able to
combat that perfectly. And now we just
have this
flurry of units that Bison can keep
achieving points with. Holding a
battlefield will get you a point and
then taking a battlefield during your
turn gets you a point. And at the
moment, Scotcher just has nothing to
come back with.
>> Oh my goodness.
I'm sorry. That's the hand that you
never want to see is like a ride the
wind a Kaiser hard bargain was in there
as well. I think I saw a switcheroo.
That is not a fun time at all for Scoro
sitting at just a Kaiser in base right
now.
>> It's not enough. It's just not enough.
I'm going to say it. I'm going to be
that guy. It's just not enough.
>> Oh, get out of town. Here comes the mind
spplitter, which we we were expecting
after game one. My spitter coming in is
not only a heavy unit, but also allows
you to look at your opponent's hand and
get rid of a card from it. Only having
two cards in hand now. Oh, that is
absolutely decimating when you've got
such a you've got a concertina hand
yourself and you're thinking, "Oh, what
should I do to my opponent?" Oh, they've
got two. How about one?
>> Yeah, I think Rebuke here would be the
option that I would be looking at
getting rid of. The cleave obviously
does give you a little bit more power
and you can kaiser into the Kaiser and
you can kind of win out on that cleave.
But rebuke is just so powerful generally
and when you are playing this kind of
holding game that Scordo was in game
one, the cleave doesn't give you
anything. There's no dreaming tree for
you to get an extra card draw out of.
>> It's not worthwhile.
>> Exactly. Right. So I I would probably be
looking at the rebuke. I don't think
that looking through the great the trash
is a bad idea at all, especially with
there already being one rebuke in there.
Oh, do you just get rid of the second?
>> I think you do. I think you go for the
rebuke. But I think that Oh, they're
more concerned with the cleave,
honestly. Fair enough, though. You know
what your opponent's got in their hand.
You know that rebuke is coming, and as
long as you can combat it, which we we
know that hand's pretty good. So, I
reckon
>> they're not too concerned about it.
Overall, overarchingly, this is fine.
Yeah, I'm trying to think of uh I guess
with a switcheroo as well, there's the
risk of using the switcheroo and then
getting cleaved afterwards. But you do
know the hand, so it becomes a little
bit easier to play around. And maybe
just wanting to make sure that you
continue to keep your units, whereas if
the Kaiser goes in, gets the assault
three, then it beats your Kaiser. It
beats your Kaiser plus a tie turner. It
equals your mind spplitter. I I can
understand the play and I will say I'm
not the one in the feature match area.
I'm the one sitting back here. All of my
plays have been beating Vetty on. You
know, that's kind of my experience at
this level. Yeah,
>> here's Kaiser going in for a point.
>> I don't know if it's going to be
meaningful enough at this stage. It
might just be the card draw that we
needed. Did get a fight or flight off of
that. So, that might help as well.
Comboed with the rebuke. Actually
couldn't do a lot of disruption.
>> I like the overus uh fan here as well.
Get that out onto the battlefield. give
yourself a little bit more safety when
it comes to keeping this Kaiser alive
because that's really what you're
playing for. You're playing to hope to a
degree that there is a battlefield open
that you can play your Kaiser to and you
can get a card draw from and the points
are kind of supplementary. Obviously, it
does help to get points you want to get
to eight, but the the aim of this Kaiser
is very much more to get through that
deck than it is to get you to eight
points right now. And having an
overzealous span as like a protective
unit over Kaiser right now is
>> kind of
important. Very important. We need it.
Yes. Very good.
Yeah.
>> But yeah, no, it's it's imperative right
now to be keeping our units in play. And
of course, we're going to bring that
Annie champion unit in because we have
to cuz we need some more units on board
now.
>> Yeah. But what are we going to get out
of the graveyard
>> is the question that I must ask. Looks
like I mean the trash flash out of the
trash. It does make sense using the
Annie to recur that and then have that
option later on.
>> I'm really impressed with the way that
Scordo has managed to come back from the
situation already. hand already has a
lot of kind of traps in it and it has a
lot of diversity and we're going to be
able to stand two runes at the end of
the turn thanks to Annie and actually I
think that we are finally maybe having
that comeback that we needed to have
enough to battle the oncoming onslaught
of these mind spplitters.
>> Let's have a look then. Bison going to
four. It's a fight or flight again
hidden at that battlefield. We know that
uh if you are bison, you can kind of
assume the op other option is that tide
turner, right? But do you want to hide a
tie turner there when you're switching
it only with the Annie?
>> I think it's a fair assumption.
>> Yeah, it's a fair assumption to say it's
a fa
>> which my new nickname for fight or
flight. I'm going to keep Oh, he's
fuffing.
>> Everyone just likes to fuff in these
decks. Maybe I shouldn't come up with a
nickname
to the experts.
So,
>> oh, there's so many choices here.
>> Yeah, too many of them.
>> Too many. Yeah, there's a lot of
choices. They've got aggression. They've
got switcheroo. They've got units
galore.
>> Acceleratable units as well. But first
off, again, I love this. The sequencing
is perfect.
>> Going, okay, I'm going to have every
piece of power available to me, and I'm
going to go in with combat first. The
beautiful thing about Riftbound is that
you can do that when you fancy. You can
go and do combat. As long as your unit
is ready, you can go in and do combat.
There is no combat phase. It is just I
want to fight your guys in this
battlefield. I'm going to try and
overpower you now. Let's see how many
resources you need to spend to try and
combat that. We're currently at seven on
our mind spplitter to just the six on
the other side. But again, the
overzealous fan can help Kaiser.
>> I think you've got the two options. And
I think that's what Scord is thinking
of, isn't it? It's overzealous fan. Do I
want to get rid of this parasocial Andy
or do I want to fuff?
>> Yeah,
>> those are the two main options. Could
rebuke
>> rebuke which of course Bison Zonda knew
was a threat.
>> Exactly. But because you know the
rebuke's there. I guess the question is
now if you're Bison Zonda, do you say
I'll play my mind splitter again. I have
the runes to do it. I I have the I have
the chaos, but you only have a couple of
cards in hand. I think maybe only just
the flash for Scordo. Is it worth
playing it now or is it worth waiting a
turn and then playing it afterwards?
Personally, I'm greedy and I would play
it now.
>> Same.
>> I would absolutely replay it, but I'm
not the one in the feature match seat.
And actually, I like the tie turner here
going on in really trying to kind of
poke the bear, I think, in this
situation. Go on. What are you going to
do about it then?
>> You have a trigger on the stack. His
overzealous fan dying. Scoro there deep
in the tank cuz we know there's a
switcheroo. We know there are threats if
this tie turner is allowed to sit at
this battlefield. Squo does not know. I
mean, I think Squo can assume that with
one card in hand, it's do I play it?
>> Do I do something or then are you
opening yourself up to the mind
spplitter? I think that's then the Can
you force your opponent to play the one
card in the hand?
>> Yeah.
>> Can you get them to use that resource so
you then can focus on other things?
Mindsplitter can be used later. Maybe if
they manage to reestablish more cards in
their hand, manage to make a board back,
and you're like, "Actually, I kind of
need that later on. I'm not going to
bother right now." going for the fight
of flight.
>> Yeah, rush of adrenaline trying to knock
the Kaiser back
>> and then Titan would trade with the
overzealous fan which is again a
defensive tool lost for Scoro and you
would need to you'd have to fight or
flight in response, right? Because you
don't want to just lose your fight or
flight. So then overzealous would
probably be knocking that tight turner
back. Kaiser back to base now. Scord has
the option to react with that fuff of
their own or even to flash. Yeah, we've
do flash knock the titer back. It's an
option.
>> It is, but we're going to fight or
flight. I like this better. I think
holding that picking up on my fs. I see.
You're just going to keep going with the
fight or flight. It makes sense.
>> I'm doing it
>> like a deer in the headlights. You're
locked into your one thing. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Uh pushing the turner back is
nice. I like this. It's a shame because
we're still limited with that one card
in hand, but at this stage, you know,
Bison Zonda has used too many resources
and cannot now go for the um mind
spplitter this turn.
>> Yeah,
>> it can be utilized later. And again, I
kind of like that because you know that
you've pushed your opponent down to such
a small hand size that they have limited
reactions and you've got loads. The hand
is still flush and we can still draw
more by taking more combats. And with
just one Overzealous fan over on that
battlefield, combat doesn't feel like
something that's going to be difficult
to overcome.
>> Yeah, I think we'd be pretty happy in
this position again for Bit. It's
>> uh you do want another big unit and that
is something we aren't flush with. Like
we have we have the Mind Splitter in
hand and that does work, but a Draven
Vanquisher would be really nice. You
could play that second Kaiser that you
do have in hand. Instead going for the
Tide Turner here again to try and avoid
unfavorable combats up on that obelisk
of power. actually going straight in
because the Kaiser was still readied.
>> Beautiful.
>> We've switched that with the tie turner.
>> Yeah, but they So, Scor saying, "Excuse
me, we have a moment here." Yep.
>> You are skipping a couple of steps.
>> Oh, cuz here's the flash.
>> Brings the Overzealis fan back. Meaning
that uh it's not a combat when the
Kaiser goes into start peak, right?
>> I love it. And then you don't get to
draw the card. Still looks like they're
going to take the point. Why not? It's
wide open. But it did limit your
opponent, and that's what this is all
about. But then again, was that flash
worth it? That was a last card in hand.
Zodto now has really limited rune usage
and really nothing else to play. So
Bison Zonda knows that there's no
threats.
>> Yeah, that's the big thing. The
difference between four and five points
when you're playing to eight isn't
monumental unless you're playing
something that can get those extra
points like a Lucian deck or you know,
Skyfall or Trinity Force or something.
So here it doesn't matter too much. You
are still winning. You are still
conquering. You're getting that card
draw for the Kaiser. So you're kind of
okay, but uh in terms of when Vice Z can
complete the game, it doesn't actually
change the turn cycle too much.
>> No, exactly. And that's that's the
concern is
>> at this point
>> Scott is going to have a really hard
time coming back cuz a stack deck. We
love drawing cards. Cards are great.
>> Is this the first stack deck we've seen?
Yes, it is. I'm pretty certain.
>> I can't remember seeing one so far.
>> I think this is their unfortunate first
stack deck, which is such an awfully
late time to have it, but better late
than never. It might be what we need to
bring this back. Looking at the top
three cards in your main deck, put one
into your hand and recycle the rest.
>> Hasn't played it yet though, I don't
believe. Went for the Kaiser Conquer
first
>> and now is going to see what that card
is and then look to play the stack deck
afterwards. I didn't quite see what it
was now. Going in for the combat down
towards start peak. So into the Kaiser.
No runes available for Bison Zonda. Very
importantly did play that Draven at the
end of last turn. So used up all of
their runes
>> and
>> taking out the overzealous fan taking
away that protection from Annie
>> makes sense
>> dealing that damage out. Annie still
there at the battlefield only three
power though.
>> Yeah, not the best for Bison. Does have
that Kaiser still in hand can accelerate
it. So it will still have a unit
advantage but with the Ferris being the
draw from the Kaiser that becomes a lot
harder to deal with. Things like Rebuke
so important to be able to deal with the
Ferris 4runner. and it dies, you get two
extra mechs, which can be it's 12 might
for six energy in a power. It is such a
strong card.
>> Honestly, kind of bonkers when you think
about it. And it just keeps going. And
that's the really annoying and ferocious
part about that card. And we didn't see
it in game one. And I think seeing it
game two now really puts back on the
map. Yeah, Draven coming in here for
with uh for four, but then with the
power paid into that attack trigger
allowing him to go up to six. I will say
it's crazy how strong uh Ferris 4Runner
is and mech decks still suck, you know.
>> Rumble still so bad. It's one of the
best cards in the meta and it's like,
well,
>> there's no point playing a Rumble, you
know.
>> Exactly. But honestly, like it doesn't
necessarily have to be kind of that
themed thematic deck for it to be a
great card. It's flexible and it's got
the color combination to allow for this
to happen. And honestly, I kind of love
it. I think it's a great addition in
this matchup. And maybe that game one
was a kind of go slow and see how we go
and then react during game two.
>> Mhm. We'll have the glorious execution
of trigger come off by Zonda as he was
able to get the point against that
Kaiser. Interested that we didn't have a
st the stack deck coming in during that
showdown.
>> Yeah, I was surprised.
>> There's also the argument you delay it
to make this bottom battlefield feel
more impactful cuz perhaps you have
something like like uh you're
representing fight or flight, right? So
you don't want to then go into this
bottom battlefield as Bison Zonda with
the risk of just being fight or flighted
back. Yeah, that is so true. But here
comes the mind spplitter and we knew
that that was a threat and that's kind
of why I was like oh man shows the exact
deck and
>> puts it in the discar pile again. No
cards in hand again for Scoro and that
could really spell disaster because
we're living off the top deck and top
deck city is a place I've been and it
wasn't nice.
>> Yeah, it's not the most pleasant of
local I find. No food me
>> company not much of it. It's quite empty
top city.
>> Exactly. So, it can be a really scary
place to be in, especially now we know a
stack deck isn't a like is a lower
possibility of that top deck. Actually,
>> grinding through the deck to be able to
combat this flushed hand. Can I just say
that is like the ideal hand that you
want right now. You've got pretty much
everything you could ever dream of. It's
Is it eight or nine? Sorry. 2 4 6 8 nine
cards in hand.
>> Nine cards in hand. It's absurd. A stack
deck for Python under.
>> Oh my goodness. Replacing one with the
other.
>> Oh goodness. Stack deck bringing it
home. More card draw for Draven. Were we
surprised?
>> No, not at all. Not at all. And this is
why like this is why Draven is seen as
such a a king of the meta right now. the
the ability to have consistent match ups
into most uh most decks, but also find
your consistent matchups, find the cards
that help you win certain matchups
really easily because you have your
stack decks. You have this ability to
draw cards off conquers to get the gold
to allow you to play those cards off
conquers as well. So overall, it's just
a really hard matchup. Annie, I think a
lot of of us saw as relatively
consistent in what she wants to do as
well, but she doesn't peak at the same
level that Draven peaks at.
>> And I think my concern with Annie is
that if you do run out of steam, cuz the
whole point is that you're trying to
hold those units on the board.
>> And if you do run out of steam,
>> then this happens.
>> And it's a really unfortunate situation
where we have one card. I didn't quite
peak what it was. We have one card in
hand, and not much we can do. We can
bring units back, but we can't then deal
with the
>> with with the threat on the board. And
so then eight points is going to be an
easy score for Bice and Zonda next turn.
So we kind of have to leave the units at
that battlefield, but then we can't
establish more. And we're at this real
pit.
>> Mhm. This is where you need like a
Charelia's Reququum or something. That's
why the best. Just give your give your
units ganking. Easy to deal with.
>> Oh gosh. You love your or
>> I do. I'm a big I'm a big or fan. Okay.
Takes out the Annie. That's three might
remove from that battlefield. Still six
in there, but mind splitter plays at
seven. Yeah, a lot of
>> Oh, it's a second ferris. Second. Okay,
that makes sense.
>> Really bulking out that area. Kind of
saying I'm going to make you struggle
for it because I kind of have to. I'm
going to let you have the whole point
there going up to seven. But now, can
Bison Zonda just overpower their
opponent, take out these Verrunners,
take that battlefield for the game?
Yeah, I the problem is as well, even if
Bisunder can't do that, Scordo only goes
to seven themselves. So then they need
to find a way through this Draven with
six fury runes available in terms of
power. That's an extra plus 12. So you
need 16 power worth or you need a fight
or flight or something to get it out.
Ter stepping in.
>> I love that. And then
we knew it was coming, but I love the
the weight, the pause was drama. And
there it goes as Bison goes up to eight
points and takes it away with Draven,
the big baddy of the day, showing just
how strong they are.
>> Yeah, really good performance from by
Zo. I think game one was a lesson in
patience. Game two similarly, but they
had a relatively powerful advantage for
the majority of game two, understanding
when to hold on to that switch route. I
really like the play where we thought
perhaps there'd be a switcheroo with the
Kaiser in the overzealous fan, but
instead goes for the fight or flight,
makes the Kaiser go back to base and
then has the option later on to use that
switcheroo really effectively into the
first four runners.
>> Honestly, could not have been more
perfect. It just all planned out and
that's exactly why these players are
doing so well on their current scores as
well. Really showing they've got what it
takes to go far in this tournament. I
have absolutely no doubt that that's
going to happen with Draven a lot today,
but that's because we just see that
consistency. And although these decks
were both very aggressive in their
stance, Annie never got that early game
pressure.
>> And that's exactly what you want. You
want to go, I'm quick, I'm nimble, bish
bash, takes him early game points and
then just hold on like gripping to those
battlefields and it just never happens.
>> When the first two units you play are
tie turner, you know you are struggling
as an anti deck. you just don't have the
power that you really wanted to have on
that board. And for the Draven deck, you
know, well played, but obviously when
you are in this sort of situation, you
have to punish as much as you can. You
have to capitalize
over
>> and we took that and it was a good it
was a good battle. But my goodness, it
was just such a shame to see Annie not
quite get off the mark. But I've got to
say, regardless, drawing as many cards
as they could and coming back from those
mind the initial mind spplitter I
thought was phenomenal.
>> Yeah, really well done all around. I'm
sure we'll see more Annies.
>> Of course we are.
>> Maybe we'll see some more Scordo as
well. I did get a ping in my ear that
something was ready, but I didn't
actually hear what it was. Oh, winner
interview. Let's hand it over to Leo
James,
one of them.
Hi, James here with our winner of round
two. Zander, thank you very much for
joining me for an interview following
your win. Congratulations.
>> Thank you very much. And thank you for
the invitation.
>> Yeah, of course. Of course. Happy to. Uh
we just watched you play Draven against
Annie. Obviously two very meta decks
from one from Origins, one from Spirit
Forge. They're the same domain like
colors match. How does that match up
different for you? Like how are the two
different when you play against each
other?
>> I mean um as you said they are the same
colors but the variation which you get
from legend and champion changes
everything because the draw engine for
Draven is just insane. And for any I
mean it's a mana acceleration and uh
resource management. So you get more
money but you have less resources to
play. I have a lot of stuff to play but
not man not so much cash to do it. So
that's the main difference but in the
end I choose Draven to bring. So I think
that having more options rather than
more mana to pay for it uh in this
particular case show that it's a better
solution.
>> That's very fair. And how was your
preparation and decision making for
decks coming into the event? Were you
always playing Draven or or did that
take some time to figure out?
>> Actually the in the origins I was first
playing mastery but then I switched to
any.
>> Okay.
>> So um as the the as I saw first preview
of Draven I said it will be too powerful
because as master with his uh legend was
just just plus two might was really
huge. I thought that one card it will be
better. So I knew at this point I will
be playing. And regarding preparation uh
there was only one week after the
premiere so there was not so much time
to to do so. I played some online games
and proxed some uh some matches. So I
played a few games but actually this was
my first match against Annie with
Draven.
>> So even though you played Annie in set
one you were like ah I
>> I know you know
>> I kind of know what can happen.
>> That's fair. you had the the information
coming into it from playing the other
side of the matchup. Well, thank you
very much for speaking to us. Hopefully,
we'll see more from you across the
weekend and good luck in the next games.
>> I won't uh I won't say thank you not to
jinx it. Thanks.
>> I appreciate that. Let's get back to
some more riftbound action.
>> Surprise, it's us. We're still here.
>> Sorry. Uh
>> oh, Amy. Amy, I'm the one that needs to
say sorry.
>> No, I'm kidding. Honestly, that was a
brilliant interview. Thank you so much
for being such a superstar on our set
and being able to show us all that
Draven has to bring. Even though, you
know, it was the expected deck coming
into this format, but it's still so
interesting watching it go. Like, we
didn't see a lot of what Draven has to
offer there. We didn't see a spinning
ax. We didn't see a lot of like the key
cards. We saw the switcheroo right at
the end. So, actually, we've got so much
more that Draven can bring to us.
>> Yeah. So many cool things that Draven
can do and I I expect that we'll see a
lot of it through this weekend. In fact,
we are going to see it in our next game
as well cuz we have Draven up against
Rexi who has been making a little bit of
a stir amongst a lot of communities. I
think there was a challenger TCG put out
a Rexai guide which I did use as part of
my research for this and because of that
Immortal Phoenix was immediately sold
out in a lot of different places. People
love their Phoenix's, people love those
cards. I do think personally it's
overrated as a deck and that is not just
because I'm bad at playing it, but I
just don't think it's as good as some of
the other decks that try to do similar
things.
>> I really like the style of Rexai. I just
think it lacks that oomph. There's
something missing. I don't know what it
is.
>> Maybe the players will show us. Maybe
they figured it out. Maybe they've
brought the spice. They've cooked.
They've cooked
>> hopefully. Uh cuz I couldn't quite get
there and it was always that late game
that I was struggling with when I've
played it in the past. But I love the
idea of these immortal Phoenix. I love
the fact that you can use them as a
discard cost. You can throw them away,
but then they're always there. Immortal
is in the name, and it certainly is.
>> In in essence, they're a kill spell.
That's kind of what Rexi is trying to do
with these immortal Phoenixes. As you
can see, we have the the normal package,
soaring scout, honest broker, vengeance.
We don't always see that. The drag under
there as well for a little bit of
removal later on. Cole the week is where
you're using your Phoenix uh to kill
your Phoenix, bring it back. You can't
bring back a Phoenix off an single co of
the week. Just as a note, if you kill
it, it's not in the trash by the time
that you are looking for that trigger.
But this is a relatively standard deck
all round for a Rexside player.
>> Yep. We're going to be seeing game three
just to give a little context for you
viewers at home. Obviously, these games
are happening simultaneously, so we have
a little bit to give you here. We give
you a sprinkle of Rexai, but just a
little just a little treat for you guys
at home. But honestly, looks like a
great list. It's got consistency. It's
got power. And I love being able to put
cards like Vi in this as well. And just
bringing in those really strong late
game destructive units.
>> And no Vi in the main here. No under
Titan either, which is something we do
sometimes see. I like the addition of
Brin here when you're trying to deal
with some of these uh heavy spell decks
and you're just looking for the win. I
wonder if it will have enough power as
the game goes on to deal with the
removal possibilities that a Draven
presents. But when that's my concern
because that's was what I mean like when
I'm saying like about this VI that's
that's a instru that's a card that I'd
like to put in this deck as playing
against Draven and maybe it's in the
side deck. We don't know that. Maybe
there is some power there that can be
utilized. Um oh I think we get to get a
little sneaky peek here for uses. I like
the divine judgment. I've seen a few of
this in the side just for that
resetility and it's like well I already
have my stuff out. I have the ability to
recur them. I don't really care about
being on two runes. Let's go down there
and let's battle in the mud.
>> Exactly. And I love that. It's it's a
case of okay well um I've got everything
I need. So let's just put everything
back. And you kind of go back in time.
You go back all the way to the start of
the game. You restrict what your
opponent can do and then just keep up
with the pace of the game.
>> Yeah. I wonder what uh sort of type of
Draven we'll be seeing. We've seen
already in in the first series of this
round two that you can mix and match
between miracle and mid-range depending
on what you want likely against the odds
edition is something we're seeing a
little bit more for when you really want
to try and control a battlefield with
that one unit against these recruit
heavy decks against these swarmmy decks.
It allows you just all of that extra
might on the defense. So, as we get into
the game, we'll see exactly where we're
sitting in terms of battlefields. I will
mention as well, something that I really
noticed with Rexi is sequencing is so
important. When you have your Rex EI
void borrower trigger, when you have the
uh Sundisk triggers that you need to get
off effectively, and then when you have
things like the void rush coming out as
well, so important to make sure you're
sequencing things properly.
>> Early game seal, we're not mad. Phoenix
in on a hard play there into the base.
Not a bad thing. Again, it's immortal
for a reason. It's okay for it to come
out naturally as well. And actually
having that really kind of expensive
drop at the beginning of the game
bringing the Phoenix in can be really
beneficial. Being able to use that seal
on your first turn, play a three power
unit with assault two really does set
the pace of the game.
>> But then immediate answer here from
Draven with the treasure hunting and the
Noxus hopeful. It's so much power for
such a small cost. You know, you're
paying four and you're getting five
power out of it in totality. We will
move into the sanctum, have that candle
lit Sanctum trigger alongside the void
borrower trigger. So look at the top
couple of cards here and then decide how
we want to place these. Can I assume
this is the candle uh candle lit sanctum
trigger first. So we can put one on the
top if we want. We can put them both
back on the top or we can put one down
uh both into that recycle and we will
just recycle one of them and then reveal
a piercing light and another phoenix off
the top from Rexi.
the Rex eye ability being kind of
revealing more cards and kind of
churning through your deck I think is
one of the big strengths of the deck and
I really love that that's being utilized
here. But putting the phoenix to the
bottom going for the piercing light so
we are going to have one Phoenix to work
with for a while. Importantly on the
Rexai void borrower trigger, the legend
trigger, you do have to pay costs. With
void rush, you get reduced by two
energy. But you, this is one of the
things with the sequencing where you
kind of want Legion if you're playing
your Sundisk, but you can't play a spell
that's too big before you conquer
because otherwise it causes issues. And
you see the immortal Phoenix there being
used just as FOD. And just chuck it in,
get a point, kill it off, it will come
back.
>> It's fine. He's all right. He loves
being in the discard pile. He'll come
back later for fun. Yeah, chuck him in
the trash.
>> He loves it.
>> You put the trash on fire, though. This
thing's like burning, burning through
all your other cards.
>> Exactly. Okay, Treasure Hunter doing its
thing. Moving on into the Catalit
Sanctum there. Of course, we get the
trigger fight or flight or stack deck.
Ooh, what a choice.
>> I mean, it depends what you have in
hand, right? If you already have a F in
hand, you keep it. I'm going to keep it.
You keep the F. Uh, but if you are if
you're looking to try and get through
more cards in your deck, you're looking
for some more of those like rebukes and
such, then a stack deck does help you
dig a little deeper. I didn't quite see
what was kept. Overall, we're going to
have the Draven Vanquisher come out once
again. And uh, no real surprises here
from the Draven early doors.
>> Here we go.
Mascalisboss once again
>> going on in. We've got a lot of
resources, but nothing in play
currently. I think that's the key part
here is that we are currently kind of
lacking on board presence, although that
won't stick around for long. And sealing
into a seal, you can't ask for better.
>> It's just it's an incredible play. The
seal into seal is one that we all love
doing. Then into a piercing light
>> because a unit was left at the
battlefield. It's really easy for this
piercing light to find its targets. Two
triggers or two targets on the treasure
hunter. Actually, not even going to
repeat it. I was wondering if they were
going to try and kill off the Draven
with it, but decided they don't want to.
They didn't want to use the extra power
for the runes. Did have enough for the
repeat and said, "Okay, well, Draven's
dying anyway. This way, we only have to
recycle one rune in totality." So, call
of the week.
>> And that's what it's all about.
>> It's about denying your opponents their
resources. And now, of course, Grab
Clanker doesn't have anything on the
board. Doesn't have a champion unit to
bring into play. Has to use cards from
their hand. Do they have any worthwhile
units? I couldn't see.
>> Nor could I.
>> There we go then. So, it's a surprise
for all of us. But
>> we can't see on this side and we double
seal on this side. You know,
>> all they need to be doing at this point
is reestablishing that board quickly cuz
otherwise Rexite is going to bring
things back and plunder away. Luckily,
we got the Darius here.
>> Brin here. Uh, spinning axes. A I've
missed the other two. I think it was a
Foff and a Falling Star as the remaining
cards in Grab Clanker. Yeah, it's very
solid. Darius comes down. No need to
pseudo accelerate it by playing one of
those other spells. Mascalismos
looking has a soaring scout in hand.
Just going to put that out. Nice little
death nail on that. Then chucks in an
Nox is hopeful with that Legion effect.
So,
>> and again, it's just reestablishing the
board for both players. Both players
were kind of pushing back and forth. Uh,
and now Grab Clanker really does have a
bit of pressure on their hands to kind
of start moving forward before Rexi does
exactly what it loves to do and just
flood the board with units. keep them
there and just be that kind of like
frustrating aggressive kind where you
just can't seem to keep their stuff off
the board long enough cuz they just keep
bringing it back.
>> We'll look for through with that stack
deck. Make it very clear which card we
are taking into our hand and then we
will move in. Didn't quite see what it
was. It was a fight or flight at the top
of hand there. I guess at some point you
do want to start looking at scoring
points. You could put your Darius in
here somewhere. There's not kill threat
on the other side with only that five
might and so we will
cycle here and falling start onto that
noxious hopeful
>> which I like again you're removing the
larger threat of the two for a potential
of kind of
>> making your unit bigger with spells
>> and then going in and taking out the
Darius actually you're going okay know I
need to I need to protect my back here a
little bit.
Darius
effects
both went to the top. So they must be
quite lovely.
>> Then it just looks like we're kind of
maybe setting up for for just waiting
around for next turn. And that's that's
the thing with these decks is that they
kind of need to take their time at this
stage to be able to almost one up each
other.
>> We got a void rush in hand. Going to
conquer with the soaring scout down
towards this bottom side from
Mascalismos. Use the Rex side trigger.
Remove the counters from the der. Okay.
>> Into a void rush. I kind of like that.
>> Yeah. Going to play the void rush.
>> Deciding against the hidden blade. Needs
to pay for it. Using the seal. Seal so
important in this Rex side deck. You
have a bunch of these individual power
costs that you really want to get
through. So now we reveal the top two,
play one of them, reducing it cost by
two, and then we draw any we didn't
play. Importantly, different from the uh
Rexai legend effect where you are
recycling the one you don't play or the
ones you don't play. Here you draw the
one that you don't play. I'm going to
play that falling star.
>> This is exactly how I'd have gone with
this. Play the falling star. Remove the
one threat on the board. Don't allow the
whole point and you've got the Vi in
hand for later when you want it slash
need it because at the moment there
aren't a lot of cards in the discard
pile. You want V to come in when she is
big.
>> Yeah, you really do. Looks like we're
just going to get the spinning axis
down, mitigating any effect of that
falling star. That Darius will have six
damage marked on him, but that will be
cleaned up at the end of turn.
Mascalismos is going to try and void
rush out here.
>> See if we can find that little bit extra
damage that we need to work our way
through the Darius. Currently sitting at
eight might in total. We just need two
more. If we can sneak it out,
>> we could get Hex Tech Ray, Falling Star.
There's a lot of cards that could do it,
but are we going to see them off that
void rush again? Void rushing twice in
one turn. What a rush.
>> Looks like we have a small discussion
with the judges here.
So, the previous void rush was paid for.
>> Yes.
>> And then reduces the cost of falling
star by two. That's how void rush reveal
the first two cards of your main deck.
You may play one of them reducing its
cost by two. So it's a a mandatory
reduction.
>> Yes. And it just happens. So it's not
something that kind of can be affected
while the game is ongoing and it just it
just happens. It was cheaper and then we
can go ahead and play another one and
again reduce the cost of the next card
>> by two as well.
>> So we'll see exactly what the uh concern
is here. My assumption is I think I saw
it properly was uh Mascalismos did tap
for the falling star uh to pay its two
cost. Uh, but you don't need to do that.
So, all that would have happened was the
two energy would be floated and because
energy doesn't leave a pool. Yes. In
Riftbound the same way it does in some
other card games like Magic,
>> um, you would still have that two energy
to be able to cast
>> the future spell. Yeah, absolutely.
>> But, uh, we'll see exactly if that's
what ends up happening. Get the judges
who know it all to work it through. Uh,
so at the moment, like Draven's in a
solid position. I think if this Darius
does fall, we've talked about it a
little bit, you lose control of the the
battlefield and also lose kind of
control of the game because you don't
have as many units to uh to work your
way through. But it's Draven, it's very
good at finding a lot of units, Amy.
>> Yeah, if there's if there's any deck
that's going to bring it back with that,
finding units, being able to accelerate
them as well, being able to push into
those battlefields really quickly is
going to be something that, you know,
Draven naturally excels at. So, even
without preses
in the discard pile and then the void
seeker, I love that card so much. I
think it's one of the strongest
signature spells in a vacuum like being
able to just
>> take two and then go, uh, I'll have that
one cheaper and then and then the other
one is going to go in my hand. It's like
that's a two for one. That's great. I'm
loving a good bargain on that.
>> It's, you know, it's buy one get one
free.
>> It is. And I love it.
>> We have fa and we have bog bog off.
>> Bog off, right? Yeah.
>> Everything ends it off. It's, you know,
it's really nice with the Rexai deck. I
do think they they seem to be lacking a
little bit of removal overall when
you're like falling starring Darius to
try and get rid of these. Hard bargain
coming out for the void rush. So,
>> we have two runes to pay. Uh but it
looks like it wasn't repeated which does
mean that this void rush will happen but
we don't have a huge amount of energy.
Can't play the Brin here. We'll just
play the honest broker hit and bring it
here will go to hound
>> and well sadly for Mascalismos and great
for grabbger as Darius survives thanks
to the spinning axe.
>> Yeah, spinning axe such a powerful
equipment. It does so much. The quick
draw, the plus three. It is incredible
in decks like this and it we don't talk
about it too often. It is often one of
the reasons that Draven can be in such
strong positions cuz you don't usually
see it as a a huge include but the
ability to get units out of this sort of
kill range is so strong.
>> It's so so strong. Going in with a stack
deck. Oh my goodness. We got another F.
Okay. Was a rebuke. I know I said it.
You're welcome. Uh, and but no, Spinning
Axe is a fantastic gear and honestly is
one of the reasons that Draven is so
strong cuz it can get you out of so many
sticky situations. It's got an
absolutely phenomenal effect. It brings
so much power onto the board really
quickly.
>> It's Yeah,
>> like you can't even be mad at that. It's
so good and we didn't see it in our
first feature match uh of this round.
So, being able to finally see Spinning
Axe come into play and actually rescue
Grab Clanker from otherwise a little bit
of a troublesome situation just means
they can relax in this situation. now
they can take their time a bit more and
still lead the way in points.
>> Yeah, they're just in such a strong
position at this point. It it's hard for
Rexite tot often find that big late game
threat and we talked about it a little
bit when we were looking at the deck.
It's like you don't have your VI, you
don't have something that can really
outpace a Darius when it has a spinning
axe on it and when this Draven can get
through so many cards at a time, bring
it back, ready it with a second card per
turn, then go back in. Yeah, it's
basically a two point per turn engine
now pretty easily. Just this Darius with
the with the spinning axe equipped.
>> Yeah, we brought that back nicely and
then kind of gusted away the only card
in a base so that Mascalismos can't
score that point for holding.
>> Great. Love that. And then pushing
Darius just in and being like, "Okay,
well here's your threat for next turn.
Can you do much cuz I can't see much on
the board right now." We do have Phoenix
in the discar pile. We do have a VI in
hand cuz we saw that earlier. So there
is a potential of a late game kind of
threat. can come back. The more uh cards
are in the discard pile, the stronger V
gets.
>> I want to see if that's where
Mascalismos does end up going for now.
And you do also have Rexside Breacher if
you want to bring it out giving
accelerate to any of those units you get
off the top of the library. Do still
have to pay the accelerate costs for
those. It's one of those cards where you
read it and you're not 100% sure unless
you know the exact rulings around
Accelerate, but you do definitely have
to pay for those costs. Honest going
into Candidate Sanctum. Once again, we
are looking through these top cards
trying to stack something up well for
our Rexite to connect with. I think it
was one to the top, one to the bottom.
We'll have the Rex side trigger and
we'll see exactly what Mascalismos
thought was worthy of being on the top
of Blood Money and a hidden blade. Okay,
where are we going to go with it? I can
hidden blade the Darius if we want. Does
give more card draw over to the Draven.
Could even hidden blade our own Honest
Broker, which is something you do
sometimes see. I was going to say even
for the death nail cost as well, but
actually yeah, just deciding to remove
the immediate threat on the board and
go, well, I can't I can see you have no
other units in play, so maybe I can just
start holding.
>> Yeah, it does give more card draw over
to Groud Clanker, though, and that is
where Draven thrives so much.
>> Very much so. We've discussed it a lot.
We've seen it a lot already.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> Phoenix comes back into the fray from
its favorite place, the discard pile.
Assault to when they're attacking. You
can kill a unit with a spell. You can
play to play with kind of a trash based
element. You can just pay to be able to
reanimate that Phoenix. Bring it back
from the trash at any point. It's a
really strong unit. Obviously, we won't
be using it as an attacker on this turn.
But having that plus two for assault
when it's being aggressive is great into
these aggressive style decks like
Draven.
>> Yeah. And it means that Grab Clanker now
needs to think about how am I holding
battlefields? How am I playing around
the fact that this Phoenix can come in
for five next turn? There's also a
soaring scout and an honest broker in
base. So it's not just five that you're
looking at. It's a total of eight with
those two death nail effects. Brin here
early for grabb clanker. I think
mascalism may be playing as we would say
in magic hellbent. No cards in hand. So
he's just like I'm good. Nothing I can
do there.
>> That's fine with Rexi though. You have
your phoenixes. As long as you are able
to cast a spell, you can then play that
from your discard for one energy or
power. That's phenomenal.
>> Also, I think you're really happy as
Mascalismos because the Briner is just
played out as a as a unit. There's no I
don't want you to be able to stop me
from winning. It is it's purely a five
might unit that is being played out
there. And now you're playing your own
Brin hit to avoid perhaps that fight or
flight or rebuke coming out from Grab
Clanker as you go for this next conquer.
>> Yep. Not being able to play cards is
kind of big in a card game where you
like to play cards.
>> Yeah, it is. It's very, very strong.
Okay.
>> Very impactful going in. Okay, with the
Zoring scout to another battlefield to
keep that point advantage. And I think
Rexi has a really strong point here.
We've of course got the void borrower
ability. Oh, would you like soaring
scout or soaring scout?
>> Bird's the word. Bird is the word.
>> There we go. That was an easy decision.
We'll take another Soaring Scout again
littering the base with units ready for
a really big hold on these bases where
Grab Planker just doesn't have much to
fight back with right now. Will they be
able to bring this back? If any deck
can, it's Draven.
>> Yeah. Have a He's still got three points
as well. So you hold to six. It's two
turns still before Mascalismos can win
the game.
>> Yes.
>> Uh so for grabb clanker, it's kind of
about developing your base again. You
don't have to go and try and kill off
this soaring scout. You can. It will
give the uh the rune channel to form
asalismos. When the death nail comes
off, it gets you a point. you control a
little bit of a battlefield, but because
there's a Brinhill on the other side,
you know, unless you are able to
actually bolster up your defenses there,
you are going to lose on that rebound
attack gives you the glorious execution
of trigger as well, which is nice, and
get that little card draw.
>> And hopefully that'll be enough.
Hopefully these cards in hand are
actually going to help us to reestablish
that board and have kind of a much
stronger stance because unfortunately
for grabbanker Mascalismos just has a
lot of units more on the side in our
champion zone which can come in
accelerated. So, we have a lot of power
dwindling in base kind of posing that
threat and saying you're now on a clock.
And if you don't start to react to
exactly what I'm doing and what you can
see I'm building up, then unfortunately
your time is going to run out, my
friend.
>> Yeah,
my expectation is if Grab Tanker doesn't
really bolster up this Brin here at all,
we'll see ah tie Turner comes out. So,
my expectations don't matter because
immediately that Brin here has been
swapped out for a tieer. can just go in
with an immortal Phoenix plus one of
those honest brokers if you want. It
defends you against a fight or flight
knocking back one of them. You still win
the combat, but the overzealous fan now
means you need to go in with a little
bit more if you are going to try and
take that battlefield out of Grab
Clanker's control. Mascalismos will be
an advantage when it comes to point gain
though because they go to six on their
next turn. Then grab Clanker goes to
six. So, if it is just a hold war on
battlefield to battlefield, Mascalismos
wins with the uh one turn clock extra.
>> Yep. So, we do have that clock in play
now. And
>> honestly, it's not looking great for
Grab Panker. I've seen a few of the
cards in our hand. We haven't got the
switcheroo. It doesn't look like I think
>> thermo beam for the sundisk, I assume,
>> which is lovely, but we don't have
sundisk in play right now, so that's
irrelevant. And and the rebuke.
>> And rebuke. Okay. So, it's a little bit
stronger than I was hoping, but still
not great when we're looking at power
value. Going for another overzealous
fan. Just kind of trying to now hold
this battlefield. Trying to make
Mascalismore spend a lot of units to try
and take it back from them. Just
building up that board and saying,
"Okay, well, I'm going to make you have
to commit a lot here."
>> It's an interesting one though cuz
Malcolysis again doesn't have to commit.
Doesn't have to go onto that battlefield
if they want to take the win.
>> We'll see. I expectations is, you know,
one unit into Candlelet. Get Candleit
Sanctum trigger.
>> Lovely.
>> Look at those top two go to six. One
point ahead right now. Stacks the
triggers effectively as well. Still not
even bringing out the breacher. Just
like, okay, I'm I'm happy with what I
have. I don't want to risk the
possibility of a falling star
connecting.
>> It's safe where it is. And we have loads
of runes in play to be able to cast that
in at any stage. It was a brilliant
choice to be able to just kind of hold
back, have all your runes in play, and
just say, "This is fine. This is
absolutely fine. And I know that I'm not
going to need to go and swarm these
battlefields right now because actually,
it's not advantageous for me to do so.
Let's check out those top cards."
Vengeance.
>> There's the Sundisk. I'd be tempted by
that.
>> So would I. I would be tempted by
Vengeance on Brine as well, though.
Getting rid of five might at this point
feels pretty powerful, right?
>> This is a tough decision. Sundisk
obviously does allow you to bring in
units ready and that is what's going to
get played. We do know there's a thermmo
beam in the hand of grab clanker but
that's a a lot of power and energy to be
used to try and deal with a singular
sundisk. So I don't think we'll see that
thermmo beam too readily.
>> It just might not be worthwhile. And
Mascalismos is making a very very clean
statement here with I have units. Can
you do anything about that? I'm on six
points right now. I can get to eight
next turn if I just push all of this in.
I don't think grabbank is going to be
able to do enough.
>> And there's also an argument here. You
do have legion effect on sundisk. Just
plays the rex side. That's interesting
to me cuz I feel like tapping the
sundisk, getting the legion effect, the
Rex eye coming in ready doesn't really
cost you anything. Like
>> you can't you're not going to sundisk on
your opponent's turn. So, Rexi, you
could have pseudo accelerated it anyway
because Sundice counts as the first card
you played for the Legion effect. Uh, so
yeah, I it doesn't matter at the end of
the day. Rex eye comes in anyway. But I
might be I would Would you agree with
that logic? If you play the Sun, you
might as well just have it. Yeah,
>> I would say so. Yeah, you I would I
would like to see that, but again, I
don't think there's any rush.
>> I don't think it matters too much cuz
you're not going in with a Rexite,
right? So, it it doesn't actually change
anything. It's just one of those
>> it looks cuter when it's standing
vertically rather than horizontally.
>> Whereas at the moment actually it's it's
nonconsequential to the to the outcome
of the game. It doesn't matter right
now. Both players are in a potentially
winning position. We're on seven to six
points. It's all about these next couple
of turns. It's all about how these
players react to what one another are
trying to do. A very clear stance from
Mascalismos here trying to just
overwhelm the board with as many units
as possible. And then Grab Flanker is
going to be coming back and kind of
almost doing not what Draven usually
does but almost spell slinging their way
through this.
>> Yeah, you can see Mascalism's very much
playing for that
voyer trigger with the Sundisk already
activated. Get the Legion effect and
then try and swarm your second
battlefield. approach the first one
probably candle sanctum just for the
extra look at the top the extra vision
that you can get from it and then try
and overtake the obelisk of power on
their turn. I do see the uh grab clanker
going into the candle sanctum here. I
wonder if perhaps we drew off the
conquer before we had the sanctum
trigger.
>> Looks like it from
>> Kaiser's
not goodness. Um from the Draven effect
there.
>> Yeah. So, judge was there. They they
sorted out. Made sure that everything
was sequenced exactly as we wanted it to
be. There's the thermo beam to deal with
the sundis. Does also take out the two
seals which uh does cost quite a bit for
masc mascalismos, but in the end, still
very happy in terms of runes. Has all 12
of them available for next turn
>> and no cards in hand. So, like got
nothing to cast right now anyway. So, oh
no, I think they do actually have some
cards in hand. Might be off towards the
side. Ah,
>> they're off to the side. But still
really respectable amount of resources
in play. But again, Grabbanger needs to
limit that. They have to they have to
say, "I need to put everything in that
I've got in my court and just let you go
and see if you can do this. Leaving lots
of runes ready to try and just hold on
to these battlefields at this stage."
here of our own for Mascalismos and Grab
Planker now needs to think about exactly
how they want to deal with this cuz you
do I I think I saw a spinning axe in
hand which would be you'd want to play
that early with the way Mascalism is
counting things out. It looks like it
might have just been passed on.
>> Yes. Yes. Is Mascalismos turn right now.
>> No, no, but with a Briner trigger.
>> Oh, with the Briner trigger.
>> I didn't see anything played out from
Grab Planker.
>> No, I don't think so. It might be that
Mascalismos is just counting out while
Grab Clanker decides whether or not they
want to play that spinning axe.
>> Maybe it's a really tough decision here
because this is the make or break
situation. This is the tense moment.
This is where both players have the
potential to win the game. Their
decisions in this moment makes history.
>> It really does. It really does for them.
Going 2 and 0 as well really puts you in
goodstead for the rest of the
tournament. Need to get six wins today
if you're going to make it into that day
two. And being on a two and0 run is
great. Grab clanker extending the hand.
Mascalismos going to take it. Rexi
defeating Draven. Two and one here in
round two. Huge performance by
Mascalismos. A couple of moments where
it looked dicey for him, but his ability
to to hold back to build up that swarm
and then really void rush his way into
victory was superb.
>> Absolutely beautiful. Rexai breaching
the win, taking it away from Draven, the
kind of big baddy of the of the set
right now. Rexai very understated. A lot
of people were underestimating it.
>> Yeah.
>> And
>> I think it's overrated. I think it can
still be good. I just think it's
overrated.
>> Fantastic deck. I think the amount of
vision you get, the amount of card
knowledge you get from your deck, I
think is under understated. I think it's
fantastic. We saw it there in both in
the game
>> many times to be able to really reduce
the cost of your um of your plays as
well. Uh using the seals into the seal
early on was a really great start for
that kind of kick off the boardwalk
which was great. And then yeah,
unfortunately we just didn't see much
kickback from our opponent on that
occasion. Yeah, when you're playing Brin
here for value, like for might value
rather than for not letting your
opponent play card value, you know,
you're in a little bit of a difficult
spot there for our Draven player. We're
going to hand over to our winners
interview though, Malasmos. Incredible
stuff all around.
Welcome back. I am just now joined by
our winner of the last feature match,
Masca. How are you feeling, man?
>> Good. Good. starting to. So, it's uh
that's good.
>> How did you prepare for the event?
>> Um I play with some of my friends in
Malier and we we did a lot of testing on
TCG Arena and yeah, that's pretty much
it.
>> Well, it's it's going well for you so
far. And to you have picked Rexai. Can
you explain to me why you did go with
this pick?
>> Uh I was maining Rexai when I played
League of Legends. So, it was it was a
given when I saw it. I was uh ecstatic.
So
>> So Rexi also likes combats a lot. How
did you prepare for the Draven matchup?
>> I I don't really do combat with my
Rexai. I index more in creature removal.
So I don't play under Titan. I'm more
with the Vengeance the Dragon.
>> Okay.
>> So I don't play combat and I don't play
their games.
>> That's very nice. Does that hurt any
other matchups of yours? Some that you
want to avoid now?
>> I want to avoid Azir. I say it's my uh
worst matchup. Too much uh too much
little creature and I can't do with a
little creature.
>> Well, so far it's going really well for
you. You just beat a Draven in the last
game with the Brinier Thunder Song.
>> Do you want to say a little bit more
about that card, how you're using it in
this tournament?
>> Yeah. Uh so, uh for the last game, I was
at six and my opponent was at six as
well. So, I knew that my uh my next turn
was probably my last. So I prepared a
few units and uh Brer in my hands to uh
stop all his interaction.
>> All right now one last final question of
course before I let you go. What is your
approach in deck building? What you are
playing a rogue deck. What do you think
is the most important thing when
building that deck?
>> Um I'd say check the
the the meta decks. Check what other
players play with your legends and try
to keep an open mind. Uh not just follow
the list as the players play, but you
try try different things uh and see what
goes with your game plan.
>> Phenomenal. Masca, thank you so much for
your time. We have a huge day of
Riftbound ahead of us, so we're going to
give it right back to the casters.
Thank you very much, Leonard. And thank
you very much, Leonard. Great.
>> How can I be there and here at the same
time?
>> Time travel. I mean, obviously for, you
know, event logistics and everything, it
makes sense for us to be a little bit
behind uh where the actual rounds are
going on on stream. So, that's why if
you ever see something happen on stream,
you're like, why aren't the casters
telling them? Well, it already happened,
so uh we can't get involved at that
point. It is in the past. It all has
happened. But the present is more
Riftban. We're going into round three
here from our Bolognia regionals. James
Ellery joined by Leonard Kernik. I'm
going to keep saying it because I can.
Uh we had some Draven in round two. Um I
know you're not quite as big of a
believer as me on the Draven, but there
was some fun stuff there. I mean, I'm
also a Draven believer, don't get me
wrong. I think it should be one of the
most represented decks in the
tournament. Again, it is an absolute
force to be reckoned with. You know, the
ability of that legend is just so strong
>> and that is why it is 15% of the player
pool. We have our meta share here. So I
think no surprises to see Draven right
up there at the top and I think it does
make sense that Kai'Sa is right there
behind as 11%. Couple of reasons Kai'Sa
we have seen started coming back into
the meta but I think also the ability to
play a deck that you kind of know from
Origins and you've come into now the
first premier event in Europe. You're
like okay I know these cards. I'm going
to just keep playing what I know.
>> Even though the deck has changed a
little bit, but it has become more of a
I'm just going to throw removal at you
type of deck. Even though I've also
talked to a bunch of players who are
still on this I'm going to play Darius
and cleave actions just to outtempo
Draven for a little bit. What is
surprising to me though is that Ahri is
standing strong even ahead of Victor,
ahead of Civer, ahead of Rexi. Ari as
the fifth most used deck. I think plenty
of Rift Bounders want to get that metal
card. It's really sought after. Ari is
such a fan favorite. What do I think of
the position of the deck in the meta
game though?
>> Uh so as an ARI player, I actually think
it's not a great deck at the moment.
I'll be honest. There's a lot of times
where you want to try and hold with Ari
and holding holding in the current meta
is hard especially you know with your
early game units. I think you know there
was a lot of thing times where you're
playing smaller units. You don't want to
do that anymore against Draven. Uh
excited to see Ezreal up there. Ezreal
and Annie both uh decks um again with
with pretty popular champions. I would
say Annie has changed quite a lot as
well. We now have what people are
calling big Annie which is like big
units like Ferris 4runner and then Civ
sneaking in there is an interesting one
along with Rexi. Um, I'm interested to
see which version of Civ we'll see.
There's kind of like the mid-range
version where you're you're doing what
Randy did in the in the regionals in
China where you're playing the miracle
where you draw everything and then play
at the end of the the the game all your
big units with Russes. Or there's a deck
that I brought to to this event to to
jam some games which is Aurora which
plays itself. You just get to nine, you
play the the Aurora, and then the deck
just goes cool. If we've got enough time
left on the round, I'll I'll take
control of this game.
>> It's really dominant. if you curve into
that Aurora. That is definitely true.
But we have plenty of games to be played
today. We have some cool decks for you
lined up. So, let's just go right over
to the table for the next round of Rift
Bound.
>> Oh, yeah. Ooh, it rhymes as well. Uh,
Ezreal uh is our matchup here for round
three. First game here on the feature
stage for uh I think
>> both of these both of these legends uh
if I'm not mistaken. as we did have
Ezreal played as a unit in the previous
game, but uh this is Azia. Of course, it
will be with um the chosen champion
sovereign. So, that will obviously be uh
updated as we go through. At least I'm
assuming it's going to be sovereign. So,
the aim of this this deck is basically
uh you get a lot of sand soldiers, a new
addition with uh spirit forge sand
soldiers. Uh, one of the key cards in
this deck, Eye of the Herald, right in
the middle of your screen, is going to
say, uh, basically allows you to keep
creating units. These are recruits, so
you make a lot of tokens, uh, a lot of
small units that are able to kind of
swarm the battlefield and take control.
>> The deck doesn't play a single unit
apart from the chosen champion, which is
basically free. And also, if you're
playing 39 cards in your Vic 40,
>> you can just, I guess, draw your cards.
I don't even know if it's legal to play
without a chosen champion. uh in
constructed. I think it's not in sealed
and and limited. You can I believe you
can but Ezreal on the other side. I was
excited to see which version of Ezreal
this is. I see one copy of Arcane Shift
and 1 Thousand Tailed Watchers. So, the
context being we have seen a new build
of Ezreal come uh in the past few weeks.
This is not what people call rat or
mouse Ezreal where you use Pit Crew to
move around. This is uh kind of like a
lot of spells, a lot of draw. Um and
then discarding things to to pay off for
Russa being quite cheap. And I also see
a morbid return there. That's a really
good card.
>> Another way of bringing things back. So
studying this deck list over
>> I think
>> I'm missing mindset.
>> Yeah, I was going to say there's a few
things missing from this like last
rights a lot of people have been playing
with as well as a card. So there's a few
things that are different from what I
would anticipate, but it does look like
the Ezreal you would expect. There's
card draw. There's damage, there's big
units, and hopefully you're able to draw
into them at the right time and your
graveyard is stacked to recycle things
for Rasa.
>> And I think that deck also really relies
on the pressure of Raven Bloom Student,
the possibly best two drop in set one in
Origins. This card just gives gets so
much might when you play a lot on your
opponent's turn or on your own turn if
you want to push for a conquer. But that
card can be pivotal. A two drop that can
decide games in the late game. But now
we're going into the first game. Okay,
Vmore's layer void. These battlefields
to me make somewhat sense. Vilemore is
one that you play on Azir because your
tokens are expendable. You're fine to
just play a recruit and have it die.
You're fine to have a sand soldier die.
One of the things that um Azir does is
it plays quite a lot of equipment
typically.
>> Doesn't play a unit.
>> Yeah, exactly. It's it's spells and
equipment. So, you essentially are
turning one and two might units into
four and five might units with things
like BF sword or brutalizer on
particular turns. And then on the Ezreal
side, Voidgate, you are playing a lot of
direct damage spells. You have Arcane
Shift, Wages of Pain, Singularity. This
is just going to make your spells more
potent. But I would say Aziz's units
tend to be small enough that you can
deal with them. But maybe we'll see
situations where that'll take them over
the top. But as soon as you have a BF
sword in play, it gets really, really
tough for your opponent to remove it.
Especially for Ezreal, that is one of
the target matchups. I've talked to some
Azir players for the Azir deck because
removal is just so tough to find against
it. Voidgate helps you though. So, I
think that we're going to see a lot of
play in the file moss layer eventually,
but the coolest thing is about this
deck.
>> You have the best two drop in the game,
and that is a token that has weapon
master and has two might and just drags
out a Doran shield or whatever other one
drop.
>> Yeah. And and in this case, um, now
having the brutalizer, something that on
the first turn doesn't do too too much
the first time you equip it because, as
you said, you're probably getting it
onto a unit that uh that is is is uh
exhausted, but when you get it on
multiple units on later turns and you're
equipping, you can keep things alive.
There's a discipline in order to get a
draw, keep keep something alive. Uh,
Wages of Pain doesn't do what they
needed it to. I like that play of Lucas
because he just deliberately went into
the void gate predicting a wages of pain
there knowing okay it's going to deal
four damage to me because of the void
gate but with the discipline I have in
my hand I can actually go up to five so
I can take the maximum amount of value
out of this and there we're going to see
Ludvig just getting that gold token
because wages of pain while the damage
does not matter it still generates you
some gold and now you basically say to
your opponent well if you want to remove
this you need to spend another spell and
I already redrew the card that I
So I've gone in some way ability
now. I have herald comes out.
>> What would help here is a stupify on the
side of because then you actually get to
reduce the might. The damage counter
stay the same. So you actually get to
kill that sand soldier. You actually
target a unit for the second time this
turn. So Ezreal triggers as well. You
get another draw. So we get two draws
off of one stupid fight. Doesn't happen.
>> Yeah, there wasn't one in hand
unfortunately. And I'm glad you touched
on the Ezreal legend ability. It It can
be difficult to use. There are certain
cards that do activate it quite uh well
like singularity is one that is is good.
Allows you to kind of shortcut that
breath and get Yeah, Bellow's breath as
well. But when you're just kind of
playing what I would say is like fair
riftbound of like one spell targets one
unit, you really have to push to get
that card draw. Um and something that we
didn't notice in the deck before, I
think it might actually be a slight
difference. I was expecting to see fizz
in this deck. Uh it is a relatively
important part of the deck just like
last rights is to recur things from the
graveyard. Bring a spell back from the
graveyard and be able to cast it again.
And that there we go. It takes care of
the unit at the void gate with the wages
of pain coming from the graveyard. It's
really nice tempo play from that Fizz
already developing a little bit more of
a board here.
>> We have a gold token. We have a seal.
So, while it was a very slow start with
passing and passing again, it does not
look bad for the Ezreal. But, I mean,
these hand soldiers, they haven't
started running away yet. Void gate
usually does not matter too much for you
because you're still out of bellow's
breath range. That's still fine for you
most of the time. And you can you can
just conquer battlefields that easily.
Your units are expendable.
>> You are really forcing your opponent to
throw removal at free tokens that you
got. There is a token coming from the
Eye of the Herald. Something that we saw
uh come through a little bit. This this
version of Azir is quite similar to the
one we saw in the regional finals in in
China just a couple weeks ago placed
second. Kind of coming out of nowhere.
I'll be honest. I know people were
trying to brew with Azir for a while.
But I think for many many people it sat
in that like maybe somebody will do
something with it someday and then out
of nowhere comes into a finals and we're
like oh okay somebody's kind of figured
out how to break it a little bit. What I
really like is that we're playing, as
we've seen earlier, salvage in the main
deck.
>> I don't know if that was the case in
China, but gear removal is so incredibly
important and actually saves you some
matchups. If you're playing versus
something like a civil with the Aurora
and you do not have any gear hate in
your main deck,
>> things are going to get rough in game
one.
>> Once again though, we're seeing the
importance of K the week in this
situation. Uses it, takes out a recruit,
and trades it for a Fizz. So, you're
you're trading up in that uh exchange
every single time. And I love that you
mentioned gear removal because in this
match up I would be feeling if I was on
the Azia side of like if I can deal with
last rights there's a finite amount of
them in the deck and once they're out of
that and once I've got rid of the rases
suddenly then the deck loses a lot of
the potency of being able to keep
bringing them back and keep bringing
units but we'll see whether it actually
comes through. Uh the card we've already
seen today but the first time coming out
of the champion zone and that is Ezreal
Prodigy. get the discard, get the draw,
reduce uh optional costs, and uh yeah,
just sit in base forever.
>> Yeah, it's just a good time. Unless
you're playing into another cult the
week that is one of the few cards that I
mean, not so few, but one of the fewer
cards that can actually get removal into
the base, taking out some of the units
that your opponent wants to protect.
Kovik has been absolutely massive ever
since its release, which is always in
case of Riftbound. But this card is
something to really play around,
especially decks that generate tokens.
It's great.
>> Yeah. One thing I would say is Ezreal
for now has been keeping up with the
pace of the units, but hasn't yet been
able to score, which is kind of
expected. Ezreal does score a little bit
slower in the game. There are uh, you
know, decks that are quite a lot slower
in in that this is one of them is in the
meta. I would say one of the things that
Ezreal, the Azia, we haven't really seen
too much from is we haven't seen the
cards like Arise. We haven't seen the
cards that will make more and more of
the sand soldiers which are a little
trickier to deal with. The sand soldier
plus a BF sword is a lot. And here is
one of them with the cards that will
help. Yeah, desert's call is going to be
able to create tokens here. And as you
said, weapon master is already a thing
as well. So, we'll be able to uh
>> just go, oh, look, I have two equipments
available. I'll just
>> attach one to each uh sand soldier.
>> Repeat it as well. If you had an S on
your base, you could have just played it
for three energy, but that's of course
not the case, nor is it possible at all.
>> It doesn't work like that.
>> Yeah. Now, brutalize. I love brutalizer
decks. I'm also a huge Jax fan. So great
that you can abuse this card in some of
the decks that you can just keep
switching the I want to say carrier the
item.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And then take the maximum profit out of
it.
>> Yeah. Some uh I know a lot of people
refer to that as cascading. Um, so that
is essentially when you take a very
cheap unit like a sand soldier and
instead of just moving everything in at
once, what you do is you move your units
in one at a time to really get the
payoff for those brutalizers cuz every
time you equip it, it'll give an
additional two might to the unit that it
is equipped to. So essentially, rather
than just going in with a flat one plus
two, you're going in with one plus two
and then another one plus two and then
another and another and you know,
everybody gets a sand soldier.
>> Every everybody gets a sand soldier.
thing is now this looks like a really
threatening field and you know what I
think it is because all of these units
they are already boosted except for the
one with the eye of the herald actually
that gives you zero extra might cuz
otherwise this looks like a phenomenal
bellow's breath
>> oh I am Ludvig you are a player of my
own heart I see a Vex in hand I think
which is one of my favorite cards I
don't think it's going to affect too
much in this game unfortunately but I am
a big fan of the design of Vex. We'll
get to that when it's played. But there
was a stupify on the sand soldier to set
it lower. Uh that's Ezreal moving into
vile moors though and an arcane shift
for the combo. Thematically appropriate
riftbound is exactly what we love. The
signature spell from Ezreal. So there's
a few things are going to happen here.
Opponent's just checking the sequencing
of it. Uh first of all, it's going to
get defied.
>> No, no sequencing or anything really.
>> Yeah, just checking. Wait, does that
cost two? No, it's a either or.
>> Sadly, we won't see Arcane Shift come
through. Um, I love this card. It's
very, very strong.
>> The flavor on this card is just so
amazing, right? It makes so much sense
how it's designed when you're looking at
League of Legends and Ezreal.
>> Yep. Yeah. Yeah. Certainly. Um, I just
want to pick up one thing for again
newer players that maybe this is your
first time you're watching Riffon. A
very important note is the Defy
countering the Arcane Shift will not add
another plus one might to the Raven
Bloom student because the card was
technically not played. That's a really
significant thing. Otherwise, the Raven
Bloom student would now have two
additional might and would be able to
trade with that sand soldier
effectively. But they're both at three
for now.
>> I think it does count as choosing
though, right? So in the dreaming tree,
>> you would have gotten a draw of it
because the dreaming tree triggers when
you choose a friendly unit in this
battlefield. However, that is absolutely
not the case. So we're going to frigidly
touch that sand soldier.
>> Yep. And that sand soldier um is I guess
is nighttime in the desert cuz it does
get quite quite cold out there. So uh
Raven Bloom student will go in be able
to take that down at this point. That's
you kind of accepting that the next turn
your Raven Bloom student is about to get
brutalized by multiple sand soldiers all
bearing big weapons at this point.
>> That is true. I mean that is the
strength of Azir. You're sitting there
with your few tokens but look at how
strong they are. The thing is
>> that the brutalizer
>> I mean it only gets really really strong
in the turn you are
>> playing you're equipping it to your
unit. So if your sand soldiers do not
have the good old acceleration or they
do not enter ready then it's it's just a
plus one in the end.
>> I think that's another frigid touch in
hand. Am I I I think so
>> on the BF sword that is a lot. So you
would have to actually choose twice
here. You pay three energy, of course,
because your Ezreal allows you to skip
one of the costs and then your Ezreal
Prodigal Explorer, which is currently
exhausted, could get you another draw.
>> And the difficult thing here is there's
a lot of outs here from this situation.
And another one of those outs is playing
another sand soldier.
>> Um, is that guards that comes through?
Guards
>> plays a sand soldier into this. Wait,
you can't play it in there. You can't
play it in there because you do not
control that.
>> You don't control it. Yeah, you're the
attacking player. Yes, that isn't one of
the outs. One of the other ads I was
going to say is you just let this sand
soldier die uh and then you just equip
the BF sword to another one and the
brutalizer uh plus the BF sword. You go
in again, you get the brutalizer
equipped.
>> Now you know guards is coming.
>> Yeah, that is that is true. But I mean
you're very much fine with that. It's a
hidden card so it can throw you off
guard. That's also so crazy. If you're
hiding this card, you're all of a sudden
for for one power you get a five might
unit. That's the other thing is it's
hidden, but uh I I refer to it as like
slow speed
>> where there's no action or reaction tag
on it. So unless it's hidden, you can't
use it within uh even if you did control
the battlefield, you can't use it during
a showdown unless it's hidden. Of
course,
>> at that point it would be, but uh yeah,
this is the second part of that is you
just re-equip the brutalizer again and
go, "Okay, we'll go again. It's fine."
>> Well, big kurfuffle there in the
beginning, but in the end, you can just
go at it again. And I think that while
our opponent is completely exhausted on
runes except for one, what else could
there be? I think you can just push for
the Raven Bloom here by equipping the BF
sword and then just uh try to go again.
Also, yeah, probably better to not
forget the good old Azir, your legend
ability. You want to keep making those
tokens.
>> Yeah, recruit comes in, recruit goes
out. Uh just of course you got to you
want to allocate that damage somewhere
from the Raven Bloom. So, uh, that is
one of the the drawbacks of I Herald is
that recruit is coming to the same place
that you're at, but it at this point
it's not that big of a deal.
>> Would be crazy if you could choose,
right?
>> I know. I know. But, you know,
>> Gods is coming through again.
>> That is very interesting because we are
on very low amount of cards in hand,
right? So, guards really doesn't do
anything right now. Also, with the
weapon master equipping the BF sword.
Okay, you know, it's a five might unit.
That's very nice. I think we haven't Oh,
we haven't played a gear this turn, I
think. So that's why we can't use Azia.
>> The other card in hand is I mean I think
we could have hidden the guards because
our ceiling in the deck is incredibly
low when it comes to energy cost. You
could top deck Arise, but you could
still play that on the next turn.
>> And you get more effective might if you
do that. Uh if you use weapon master to
equip the brutalizer, it counts as
equipping that turn. So you get an
additional two might compared to if you
just sit with a BF sword and two
brutalizers. So I I I think with perfect
information on the game, I quite like
that line, but it's difficult to know
because there's a singularity in hand uh
from Ezreal. Uh so that could be one of
the outs we're looking for. Yeah, it has
already been played. Uh so it's going to
be those two. At this point, you'd be
able to hold with the the sand soldier,
but again, we have the information that
that was an opportunity, whereas our
players don't. And I think Lucas should
just consider to activate a hidden blade
in response which would not work because
you can only play that on showdowns
>> because it is an action not a reaction.
Now we have morbid return. So we're
getting a unit from the trash back into
our hand. And I know that there has been
a Raza discarded in the beginning by the
Ezreal
>> and there was a Fizz. So we might be
looking for Fizz wages of pain again
>> or we just third time
>> fizz another morbid return and then
we're getting back the Raza tool. So we
have some extra. There's a lot of stuff
we can do here. I feel like at that
point we're we're looping for the Yeah,
I guess you get one extra unit out of it
if you get the the Raza
>> or you go wages of pain. You're right.
And your opponent is not going to hold.
>> Ooh, you could also take an arcane
shift.
>> Way better, actually.
>> Yeah, actually there's a way better line
than that. Uh and then you get another
fizz.
>> Yeah,
>> cuz you flicker the fizz and then you
get another reaction from it. Uh,
importantly, um, Arcane Shift,
>> the card that gets, um,
>> like Arcane Shift gets banished. So, you
can't continually replay Arcane Shift.
It's out of the game for this round. So,
there is the morbid return,
>> but the banishing is part of the effect.
So, defying it,
>> managed to get it into the graveyard.
Usually, it's like I think it's part of
the balancing that Fizz can't loop
Arcane Shift because that would be
incredibly broken. But with this, if
you're defying the archangel, if you're
accepting that your opponent is going to
get a hilariously broken fizz.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well, there is the rasa and
the the fizz. Almost played.
>> You talked about the loop of how you go.
I was thinking wages of pain. I was
thinking far too small.
>> I was thinking very very small compared
to get a fizz, get the arcane shift, get
a rasa from the mor more morbid return.
>> I mean, in your defense, how often do
you have a arcane shift in your discard
pile?
>> True.
>> That is actually very very true.
>> That never happens.
Salvage comes through. Salvage does take
out one of uh one of the the seals. They
have been doing work. We didn't really
comment on this too much. One of the
problems with Ezreal can be that you do
have to even with the reduction in in
optional cost, you do eat through runes
quite quickly uh when you play high
power spells.
>> Oh, we finally get another sand soldier
token. Missed out on using that ability
in the last turn. Of course, we didn't
forget it. We just didn't play any gear.
And now the thing is you're out of out
of steam, out of sand in the Azer deck
because well you can make a token each
turn now. That's great. You can boost
that token up if you want to in the next
>> make one really big sand soldier.
>> Yeah, you can make one heck of a sand
soldier there, but that card can also
very easily be removed.
>> And one thing that Azia does struggle a
little bit with depending on the
battlefield choice and a few other
things, uh, card draw is a premium in
this deck. like you have to kill your
own units very frequently with hidden
blade to get the card draw. You do
stagnate in just the ability to see more
things. Whereas Ezreal, the other side
of the table is like, "Cool, I'll stack
deck. Yeah, I'll repeat a cold shot.
I'll do it again. I'll do it again. Oh,
I'll I'll get another card, draw a card
off the top."
>> Yeah, I'll I'll just take whatever I
want. I'm just going to plus off. And
this is sometimes the thing with those
token decks. I mean, we've seen that
before. I think we're casting all of the
token decks today. I know
>> with the Victor sometimes you're just
running out of steam. You're just It's
great that you can make a token every
round. It's great value. It truly is.
>> But sometimes it's just not enough, is
it? Must be nice to draw cards. Uh oh,
look, more card draw. Uh Ezreal comes
in. You get to discard more. That's
going to
>> reduce the cost of the Rasa in hand. Uh
opponent is now Look at what Cardop
does. So Cardop is a uh a unit from
Spirit Forge. Uh essentially when you
play it, you create a gold. you off your
opponent if they create a gold and if
they say yes, you get another gold. Uh
it's a nice card that a lot of people
were saying for multiplayer is is
perhaps where they were expecting it,
but actually in single player it's good.
Like it's already good to just get that
um the gold is played a lot in in the
pick crew uh version of Ezreal because
just allows you to untap a lot. But uh
it still helps as well getting through
that early game. It feels so strong in
the Ezreal deck as well just because as
you said in the early game you are
dramping yourself quite often. You can
just you can just next turn play a seal
of discord already for free which just
>> forever ramps you up.
>> That feels so good when you get to do
that. It I I I'm a big fan of the uh the
blue purple uh domain. I know a lot of
people feel like there's some very
strong cards in purple, which is fair to
say, but uh in this situation, you can
see the power of just drawing and
rebuking the big sand soldier is uh is
going to be painful.
>> Yeah, I think it's really good. Some it
doesn't sound great to just rebuke sand
soldiers, but that is all we're hidden
blading. It makes a lot of sense, but
it's also
>> uh hidden blades an action when it's not
hidden. So again, it has to be hidden in
order to play at reaction speed. So um
it it is the first time we're playing a
regional here um on the ground in
Bolognia. So there are a few things with
timing issues like that where you you
kind of have a read on a card in one way
and then it actually doesn't quite play
out like that. So that is something to
keep an eye of if you are uh playing
those spells that have different speeds.
And speaking of speeds, that is a Fiora
worthy coming through.
>> Great card. We've seen it plenty in
Fiora, but this is actually super useful
in Azir as well. Didn't see it in the
deck list in the beginning.
>> So, this is a this is a really cool one
because every time you make a sand
soldier token and you use the weapon
master ability to put a brutalizer on
it, you can actually dramp yourself, pay
a power cost, which you in the end game,
you have plenty and you have very few
cards, so it doesn't really matter if
you pay power cost. You can just make
them ready immediately and that changes
the entire play style of the deck, let
me tell you. Yeah, it kind of um
facilitates the role that the Ranata
unit facilitates in Victor that we saw
earlier where it's like, "Hey, my my
tokens are kind of ready." They're not
really ready. They're like, you still
have to pay a little bit for it, but
it's a whole lot better than coming in
and then just sitting there for a turn
exhausted.
>> The thing is now it looks like, okay,
Lucas has to get a little bit lucky to
just find equipss and keep on playing
those tokens. If he rips and rise from
the top, all hell breaks loose.
>> Is that the way back in
>> that? That is you get a extra sand
soldier for each equipment you have,
right? So that would be five plus the
two you get anyways if I'm not mistaken.
So that would be seven and you get two
that are ready anyways. So the other So
other three you take two brutalizers and
BF swords. You have five ready units.
But you need to draw the card first.
Now, danger danger moment because we've
talked about how important index running
Fiora worthy it is to keep the Fiora
alive. Uh, and that is an untapped
Fiora, which tells me Fiora is going to
a battlefield. So, probably to actually
vile moors. I was going to say able
maybe to to to go to void gate, but Fizz
is going to trade here. the it's it's
the crackback now on Ezreal's turn of
like what does Ezreal have in order to
deal with this Fiora and then suddenly
that that accelerated uh unit function
is gone and look at how much Lucash's
dramp down to four whereas Ezreal is
basically going to draw his last runes
in the rune deck as we go into the next
turn. I mean, I love that play,
especially that he left four runes open
so that next turn gets two more, gets to
six, and can still play Arise.
>> Mhm.
>> So, a rise still gets you two ready
sense soldiers even if you're a worthy
dice this turn. So, therefore, you would
have two brutalizers that would give you
two five might units that are ready.
That would be a pretty neat topic. I
guess the the key point to look at the
the the game state fully um going to six
knowing arise is a possibility is
actually significant because from five
you can't challenge to win the game
right at this point Ludvik has to now
play around okay what is the out that
Lucash has
>> in order to hold these battlefields or
conquer both on his next turn. So having
a rasa on the void gate is okay, but six
is not above that that uh threshold for
for being fine.
>> It's quite funny to see actually because
it looks like Lucas hasn't had a lot
going on in the last five turns
basically. But if he rips an arise from
the top, that is great. Oh, now we're
going in with the thousand tailed
Watcher. Of course, your opponent
>> is at four runes. you know that they
have the hidden blade in hand because
you know it was revealed earlier by
Lucas trying to activate that but there
is going to be a possible push here. Are
you going to get out that oh if it gets
hidden bladed the next turn can't be an
Arise turn. I want to I want to make
that very clear that you're going down
to three. So if you draw a rise from the
top it's not helping you. There is the
hidden blade though on thousands of eld
watcher in order to just maintain the
the the board state with the Fiora.
>> I like that.
>> Um because also your opponent has tapped
a lot out. So there's now no
singularity. Can't cast that this turn.
And most of the spells that are left I
mean you're looking at wages of pain and
an arcane shift. Those are three damage.
>> Yeah.
>> There's not really too much aside from
your opponent like saying okay well I
guess I just have to trade my Ezreal at
this point.
>> And I mean the Fiora is at four might
right now right because of the thousand
tails watcher. So plus removal would
definitely get rid of the Fiora. I think
that while you still have the Raza,
you're in a decent shape here just
because
>> another Fizz, so that helps.
>> Oh yeah, that really really helps.
>> Do you even
blink out? Do you maybe blink out the
Raza?
>> There was a frigid touch. Oh, there's a
super firey as well. That'll get you
around the corner of trading
>> three might into three might.
>> Yeah, I like that. I like that.
>> And draws a card. So, uh,
>> so it's an even trade,
>> right? Okay, that's great. You got to
draw a card. You have an even trade. You
still control the void gate. Your fizz
is in the backline. So, you're going to
That's the other thing that I don't love
in this situation for Ludwick is he's
going to go up to six with holding with
the Raza and then he can only score in
the VOS layer to go up to seven. And
then on the next turn after that, Lucas,
who is on six, is going to be able to
draw an Arise. Rice is going to really
do a lot of damage there because
actually is is weapon master mandatory?
>> Wait a second.
>> Uh I believe there's a may on it. I
would have to reread the actual uh text
again, but I I think there's
anyway that it doesn't matter cuz we're
going to see uh two sand soldiers come
out at this point. So uh this it's not
going to happen this turn. And Ezreal
does indeed get to untap.
as uh we
now look at a six-6 game. Fizz brings
the game to seven, taking over on Vile
Moore's lay. And I'm looking at the
hand. It's a cold shot, which by the
way, called shot in your opponent's turn
is always great. And here's one of my
favorite cards, Vex. So, Vex has
asymmetrical effects. It essentially
reads, uh, in a combat that involves
Vex, opponent spells cost more and my
spells cost less. And it's one power and
one energy, which really, when you're
only on five runes, untapping, awakening
up to seven, every single rune and
energy and and power matters in this
situation. But it's really important to
note, it's only when Vex is involved in
that combat. No other time is that
active.
>> I will allow myself to correct you
there.
>> Oh, thank you. Please do.
>> At this point in the game, power cost is
irrelevant.
>> Okay, fair.
>> After this game, the game uh this turn
the game will be over.
>> Well, that's true.
>> So, you can just throw away all of the
runes that you're having.
>> But my the reason I say it is relevant
is is about this turn of like if you
math out fully the Vex one extra power
can be an effect, right? Like if you
don't have enough power to be able to to
play it, but this deck I don't think is
going to suffer from that. But I I do
appreciate that point.
>> You can you can float though. So you you
can float some runes. But I mean, if
you're just clearing and your opponent
is then going to just absolutely
>> chill, then actually it still does
matter. So you were right.
>> Well, we're both right. It's fine. We
can both be right.
>> We're going to go call shot here as an
answer. So I think Ludwig might be
struggling to find an answer here.
>> Always feels terrible when you're
playing against purple and they're like,
"Okay, we're going to start a showdown.
Um I'm going to see four cards."
>> Yeah, but that's an expensive cold shot
at least. Yeah, but as you said, d
ramping here doesn't matter if you find
the answer and win the game, right? Like
>> good point. Very, very good point.
>> All right, so the fist doesn't find it
dies. I think Lick with this one, he is
fine. Thing is, Lucas never really took
the time to develop the Azir chosen
champion unit because that one would
really help. Here is Yazir.
>> Uh Ludvig is going to just show the
rebuke being like uh I can just move all
of your stuff.
>> That's interesting to say the least.
>> The fighter flight was hidden, right? So
it would only target this battlefield.
So yeah, Ludic just showing, hey, I
actually have two ways to push you off
the battlefield so you can't contest. I
guess they I I would still suggest
playing it out or at least to to
understand to that point. Uh but I think
it is valid at that point to say hey I
actually do have the answers here for
this move
>> and we might need some time because this
was a pretty long game one actually. So
let's not try to make a really huge turn
there because as you know that as soon
as the Azi was played
>> I think that's the moment you know okay
Arise is not going to happen. This is
the win condition. I can just stop that
immediately. So I think fair game by
Ludwick here and that is something that
I find really really cool. The one side
deck Dr. Mundo expert. This card is
phenomenal. If you are milling yourself,
you are playing call shots, you're
playing stack decks, you get bunch of
cards into your discard pile. Dr. Mundo
hits hard.
>> Yeah, Dr. Mundo does indeed hit hard. Um
there are some changes to this deck list
that I think are important to know. We
did see the Fizz. We did see um uh a few
other cards that came out um within that
matchup.
>> Vex.
>> Vex. Yeah. Thank you. Thank you for
reminding me. One of my own favorite
cards.
>> Gotcha. I uh I'm too in the hole here
for for for focusing on things. Here's
the sideboard uh for Lucu. Windw wall, a
card that has somewhat fallen off
because um a lot of the targets that
you're looking to windw wall, you can
not so fast. However, wind wall is a
little bit more of a catch all spell.
Very expensive, but it will catch things
like time warp. It will catch
singularities and you know a lot of
other things obviously that would get
caught by uh not so fast. I think wind
wall is a target side decking cards
against those decks that also
>> every single fury deck right now in
competition has the option to side deck
thermmo beam.
>> Oh yeah,
>> if you get thermmo beamed on Azir, you
can do basically nothing else except for
giving your opponent your hand and
saying
>> good job.
>> Yeah, that that's very true actually
that uh because of course thermo beam is
uh destroy all gear, right? There's no
targeting about it. So you can't Yeah,
exactly. You uh
>> will be able to take that out. We'll see
what battlefields we're playing for game
two as well
between Lucashu and Ludrox.
>> I'm quite curious to see what Lucu is
also running. Balmor's layer is of
course also almost a given in those
tokenheavy decks because you don't want
your opponent if they conquer over your
tokens, you don't want them to retreat
their units. So
>> prefer war camp also helps as well if
you play many token units that you want
to push somewhere.
>> War camp for a wide board game. I think
one that I've seen a lot of people
playing is Orn's Forge, which is
reducing the cost of gear. Um, so it's
kind of asymmetrical in that you're
playing a lot of gear. Your opponent
probably isn't playing a lot of gear, so
it it can kind of even that out.
>> But uh it's going to be Sigil of the
Storm on the side of Ezreal. So trying
to damp uh decks that want to conquer
early. So essentially, it's saying,
"Hey, if you want to go both
battlefields early on, I'm going to make
you pay for it." For now, the payment is
going to come through the wages of pain
and take out. Even with the war camp
buff that does apply to the sand
soldier. Still enough three damage. Take
it down. Get a gold uh and continue on.
And that kind of means Lucas is like,
"Okay, rebuilding time. Let's play play
a brutalizer, use the ability, get a
sand soldier, go to the next turn. You
get some value. You get a nice little
three drop there for basically a free."
You keep the brutalizer on the field, of
course. Now Ludwig has a gold token from
the wages of pain. Ludwick going second
feels really, really strong in Ezreal
because the deck barely does play any
two drops. And after play testing a
little bit versus Ezreal, I felt like
letting this deck go first actually not
the worst idea. We saw that I think in
the last game. I think Ezreal actually
started there and just passed twice.
>> Yeah. Are you advocating for going
second? Is that what I'm hearing?
>> I don't hate it. Okay.
>> I don't hate it to let the Ezreal player
start because usually they know don't do
anything.
>> It's ingrained in me that going first is
like just unequivocally even if there
was a reason to do it, I'm like I don't
want to let my opponent go first. I want
to be playing first. Seal into seal. Oh,
we are never going to pay power cost
this game.
>> Yeah, with a cold shot in hand as well
and an untapped seal. Oh, it's not
untapped. Sorry. The the seal was tapped
for Ezreal. I was I was getting ahead of
myself. But
>> starting with discarding Arazza. Next
card stacked deck.
>> Wow. Looking down well was brought in.
That is again another card that is is
coming in matchup dependent and and a
little bit of a tech card from Spirit
Forge. Uh he it looked like Ludvik went
to take down well and is actually
reconsidering and I think ends up taking
down well again.
>> I mean this is also one of those cars
that you want to actually wind wall.
This is I think eight energy double
power cost return all units and gear to
the hand of the player and you're
massively slowing down Azir if you get
this card through.
>> Maybe actually took a second Ezreal. I
actually like as Lud was flicking the
cards. I I think that that decision
actually changed. So we we'll take a
look. Um, having a second Ezreal
one feels a little bit overkill, but at
the same time, that is recognizing that,
okay, my first Ezreal may be under
threat over the next couple turns. I
might have to contest a battlefield with
it to to slow the Azir down.
>> It's just I mean, you're not paying
power cost anyways for the rest of this
game. Just drawing more cards does not
really hurt. Also, discarding with your
already having a Raza in play, at least
in your discard pile.
>> Nazir just keeps doing Azir things going
in with the sand soldier and the BF
sword there. So, it's more value
generated. We're hiding a card as well.
That's actually a really camouflaged
card there. This is This is magic.
>> So that I actually couldn't see it for a
moment. I was like, we've hidden a card.
It was only cuz it broke the line that
I'm like, oh yeah, there it is.
>> You can barely find it.
>> Yeah, Visual
is going through those cards. He really
knows that there is some issues with
time with the Ezreal deck because you
have quite the big turns. You need to
set up a lot. You have to basically see
into the future to know what you're
doing with those miraclelesque decks
that play a lot of seals.
>> Luckily, 26 minutes left on the clock on
this round. So, for now, we're not in
the danger territory.
>> Is that another called shot for one
repeated?
>> You've seen eight cards and paid
>> almost nothing cuz you've tapped two
seals.
>> That must be a lot of fun for Loig.
Actually, this is exactly exactly what
you want to do. While Lucash on the
other side is sitting thinking, I want
to you know what? I want to make another
token. Can I make another token, please?
>> Are we uh I was about to use a different
term. Are we recurring it from a
graveyard as well? Uh no, it's wages of
pain taken out. I was going to say
looking at another four cards is not
necessary. So, wages of pain comes
through from the Fizz. Uh it really does
feel like you can find so many options
with this Ezreal deck.
>> I love that for him that he's also
getting a gold token.
>> So, that's pretty nice. Oh, actually
there was the trifarian war camp. So the
sand soldier was at four might and now
stupify is being used there to just
later on reduce the might. The damage
counters are still on. It would
absolutely kill the sand soldier to
>> you got to do it. You got to draw those
cards. Uh otherwise you lose the the
hidden blade again for for players that
perhaps don't play with hidden cards so
often. If you lose control of the
battlefield, you do lose the spell or or
unit that is is being hidden there. So
kind of a mandatory thing you have to do
at that point. forced to hidden blade
your own unit. Get the card draw. You
actually don't end up too unhappy with
that.
>> And you deny your opponent the card draw
of the stupify. I think even though I
need to check if this is reduce the
might and then draw.
>> No, I think again it's one of those ones
of like I I'm pretty sure you do get the
card draw. Uh good good one to double
check, but um yeah, but the the do as
much as you can thing. Spells in in
Refan tend not to fizzle like in other
games where like if the target
disappears. That's not a hard and fast
rule, but it's a general trend for the
game. So, uh I'm sure chat will let us
know.
>> Oh, yeah. It's completely separate
effect, by the way. It's just draw one.
>> All right. My bad.
>> No, no. It's uh again, first event here
in paper, first event where we're seeing
>> uh at least in Europe. Uh of course, we
did have uh Houston for the uh regionals
in America, but first time we're in
Europe seeing a lot of these against
each other. So, uh there's always room
for clarification on things. I've never
seen an Azir with this many cards in
hand, by the way. That is absolutely
mind-blowing to me. Now, two of those
Sen soldiers coming in for the repeated
cost for desert's call. Getting a little
bit more pressure onto that ball, hiding
another card in on the Trifarian War
Camp. So, points wise, we're starting to
try and race away. We are This is so
good.
The Sigil Battlefield from Ezreal, Sigil
of the Storm. If you conquer it, you
need to recycle one of your runes, and
that is going to hurt you. So,
>> Lucas is not taking free points there,
and that is significantly slowing them
down.
>> Yeah, exactly. It's a way of when you're
playing a late game deck like Ezreal,
there are a few different ways that you
can can slow your opponent down, and
this is one of them is you just make it
painful for them to try and contest both
battlefields in one turn. It leaves you
a point where you're like, "Okay, well,
I'll give you one point a turn because
when we get to the late game, I don't
care about recycling anything because
suddenly I've got gear. I've got gold
tokens. I really don't care. I'm able to
just jump up the points and go 0 2 4 6 8
I win. Cool."
>> But against those aggressive decks, it
it's really starting to slow them down.
It really hurts them. They need to go to
their mid game. And decks like Ezreal,
they do not care.
>> It's it's really really strong as well.
And also power cost. People
underestimate how important power cost
is. People saw a call shot and said, "Oh
my goodness, that is the most broken
card in the game." For zero energy, you
can actually do this effect twice.
That's crazy.
>> But I think it's only crazy because
Ezreal Prodigy and of course everyone is
playing these seal of discords and
getting tokens generated, the gold
token, because otherwise if you're
recycling two of your runes for cold
shot,
>> o that is that is such a big cost.
>> Here comes Russa. tap some gear for it,
count the cards in the graveyard,
and uh not going to be as cheap as it
does get, but uh nevertheless, it's not
painful to play it at this point. I'm
trying to realize whether I included six
in counting to eight or whether I have
lost the ability to count in general.
>> It happens
this.
>> Hey, sometimes it's the easiest things
in life that are hard.
>> So, how many cards do we have in hand?
Five on the side of Lucash. There is one
arise.
Azia is getting significantly stronger
when you draw a rise. I think people
even mulligan for this card.
>> That that's fair. I I I kind of want to
we we're somewhat getting to the point
where Kull the weak
is harder to make effective against
Ezreal cuz we're now at four units. So,
Ezreal does get a choice. And with two
Ezreals on on the board, it's not quite
as uh as easy as throwing away units,
especially when these sand soldiers uh
Azir is kind of playing low economy
right now with the number of equipment,
the number of sand soldiers. You
definitely kind of like struggling a
little bit from behind. So, you don't
really want to call the week until you
have to. If you can get some cheaper
units, that'd be great. Like, if you can
play equipment, get a a fresh sand
soldier, call the week, that then you're
trading up. But if you're trading off a
battlefield, that's not ideal.
>> I don't think you want to activate this
card at all in this game state because
paying a power cost in your Azer deck,
>> first of all, hurts you significantly
more than it does Ezreal. Also, you pay
a power cost, one of your sand soldier
tokens plus two energy just to get rid
of what? A fizz that has used its
effect.
>> Yeah, there are two sand soldiers come
through.
>> Look at the triple seal of discord by
the way.
>> Yeah, I know. That's flexing. flexing to
get him out. Flexing to have the the
fancy one as well from his rare forge.
>> Yep. The overnumbered incredibly cool.
Now Ezreal is already at 10 runes. I
mean, at this point, you don't even
really care about not paying power costs
anymore.
>> You're going to get to a point where
you're paying mind power cost for
something like a thousand tailed
watcher. there. It's good also to have
some gold tokens still, but also if you
keep not paying your chaos power cost,
then the watcher is just absolutely free
later on. If you're at 12 runes and you
pay two power cost, you're basically
just being efficient.
>> Brasa goes in, takes the Sigil of the
Storm, and you're like, "Yep, fine. I'll
just uh tuck that and float one for
now." And this is the other thing is
Watcher is is an odd card because where
where you can go wide with uh uh sand
soldiers watcher coming in just kind of
like nullifies all of that additional
bonus cuz every unit is going to get
minus three. So a wide board state is
not particularly scary for Ezreal in
this game state specifically.
>> What watcher doesn't help with is big
pushes from the Azia deck. So if you're
keeping your units in your base,
>> watch really
bellow to really work wonders versus the
deck because
>> you can put him to to might if they're
equipped with a BF sword. They do not
care unless you bellow breath and then
they care very much.
>> That's some tech that people I think
need to be aware of as we go and see
more Ezreals. There is a world where you
can watcher arcane shift the watcher to
replay the watcher and get a second
enter ability to give everything minus
six and then bellow's breath will
basically annihilate anything that is in
base.
>> That's true. But you're also getting
very very low on energy at
>> you are you are at that point if you
have three seals and then Ezreal and as
much as you can like
>> rich getting richer at that point but
you can also oh no you can play two
iterations of battle sprint. It's
actually true because it's only one plus
one power cost and you can repeat it. So
that's really really strong. I think we
just played watcher for the vibes just
to develop the body on the board.
>> Yeah, it it feels that way. There's a
>> he's really hard.
>> This is like I got hard bargain. What do
you want to do now?
>> It's such a good cut. I also love that
there's counter spells for almost every
different color now.
>> Yeah. And importantly,
>> because there are two Ezreals on board,
but each will reduce the repeat cost by
one power. And that's why hard bargain
for two is going to be a double hard
bargain.
>> Oh, really? Does it stack?
>> Yes. Yeah, they stack like that. So,
each individual one is going to allow.
That's what they were clarifying with
Lucash was like,
>> "Yeah, it does work that way."
>> The Ezreal is pushing. There is going to
be a hidden blade used on the sand
soldier token, of course. So the
thousand tail watchers was not only
played for the vibes. That is that is
good to know. We're also hiding a card
in there. That could be plenty of cards.
I find it really funny that a deck like
Draven basically plays more different
height cards than Teemo does almost. But
there's also plenty that Ludwick could
have there. There could be Wages of
Pains which could be played. I don't
think it's necessarily the case. And you
know your opponent, you know, Ludvik has
>> seen the entire deck at this point. Like
literally every single card is basically
has been cycled through. Uh so really
you you are left guessing with that. And
again after all of that playing a
watcher, playing a repeated hard bargain
and now a hidden card and you're like,
"Oh, I'm going to untap and go up to
like what back up to 10 or 11 runes on
the next turn basically costing you
nothing." There is fury. Saw it in the
last game. Uh, so will make those sand
soldiers a little bit quicker onto the
battlefield. Not too many um of the
yellow runes available though,
>> but that is also a little bit slow I
want to say playing that fear worthy.
However, now you can bring in another
token that is going to get weapon
master, get a brutalizer onto it or a
doran shield. Are we taking the doran
shield?
Airbf sword and
>> just trying to stack everything as much
as we can. Fur is in base so that is
important even though it is overlaid
over the uh the the the legend.
>> Yeah, at this point there's there's just
too many cards, right? So you you can't
really keep everything tidy if it's uh
if it's everywhere. Sensor is pushing in
with the BF sword. Are we going to see
something like a fight or flight?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Not okay. So saves the Ezreal again. and
you're saying, "Okay, I've still slowed
you down. You're still not going to be
able to really to conquer uh Sigil of
the Storm at this point. At least not
without expending a lot for it. You can
get it, but it's going to cost you."
>> That would be a lot lot. So, I I'm
thinking about putting brutalizer onto
one of these sand soldiers, and then you
have the option to go in with both. So,
that means you
>> pay one power cost for the brutalizer,
you pay one power cost for sigil of the
storm, and you would sacrifice one of
your sand soldiers.
>> The Oh, yeah. you know, both of them
together. You're correct. Yeah, I was I
miscounted, but yeah, it would have been
costly to to do that. You damp heavily
into the next round.
>> I think it's a good choice of Lucas to
just say, "Hey, that is maybe way too
much that I'm paying for just one
point." But then again, Lutick, the
Azreal deck is already at three points.
That is very unusual that there's this
little discrepancy. And oh my days, is
it going to go down well for Ezreal or
is it going to be the downfall of Ezreal
with his new top deck? Oh, wait.
Actually, that is so many cards in hand.
For one second, I thought he was at two
cards in hand. I was like, where are the
cards?
>> Ezreal at two cards in hand. One has
gone horribly wrong.
>> He's It feels like Ezreal is so
comfortable in this position because now
at this point, you're outvaluing your
opponent like absolutely crazy. You have
so many
>> two copies of Rebuke. Do you ever need
to play out more units?
>> Two copies of Rebuke are down. Well, uh
>> that's ridiculous.
>> There's a card shop in hand, which is
not so significant, but yeah, you're
just constantly going to be able to
control these battlefields.
>> That is just so incredibly powerful,
especially cards like Downwell with two
power cost. Yes, they are costly, but
you have two seals, so that doesn't even
really matter. There's only three equips
so far. So I think Lucash has been
missing a little bit of steam there.
Still has those two soldiers from I
think it was from the Arise turn. And
now we're going to continue with three
energy. Considering to play the card
sharp in hand perhaps, but it's going to
stupify.
>> Draw a card.
>> The fear of
>> in doubt you're playing Ezreal. Get
another card.
>> Of all the cards is already like cool
that gives me an out next turn. Uh there
are so few cards in this deck that you
don't want to see on top when you when
you're just like drawing into them.
You're like, "Cool, another watcher.
Great. Another another late game uh
possibility. Kop going to shore up a
little bit of this battlefield. Uh make
10 is quite a lot harder than seven to
beat. It's going to cost a lot for Fiora
to start equipping things in the next
turn. And what's better than 10? 13.
>> In fact, it's Trafarian War Camp as
well. So it's 13 14 15 16. I'm in awe of
how how well Ludvig is playing this
because he does not care about power
cost. Sigil of the storm thinks he might
not be able to hold it. Wants to go for
more pushes next turn. Puts the Raza
back. So offers the free battlefield to
his opponent which is at this point
already. That's that's actually not
happening too many times when your
opponent is at five points already.
Pushes so much into the Trifarian War
camp to look good. Eye of the Herald is
being played by Lucash. So perhaps
another bigger push. We're going to see
a power cost being paid there soon. But
he has Bellow's breath plus the Watcher
in hand. Possibly if he has an Arcane
Shift, it could be Arcane Shift.
>> Uh
>> watcher Bellow's breath.
>> It could be no Arcane Shift in hand
right now. I think importantly I think
we've had to the the points were were
slightly misaligned for for one moment
there where it looked like Ezreal was on
five, but I think importantly going to
four there. Ludvik's clock is a little
bit
there is a world where Lucash kind of
like sneaks to the side and is able to
jump from six to eight on a following
turn. So, it's not like it is a done
deal, especially with that Azia from the
champion zone potentially as a as a
finish
>> for Lucash. So, I think stacking this
battlefield is is helpful, but it is not
enough to make sure that you've turned
the game for sure at this point cuz now
look how big these sand soldiers can end
up being with all of that equipment and
then potentially, you know, followed up
with an Azir as well.
>> Yeah, that are huge. These are huge. But
we know that there's also downwell still
in hand for Ludwick. It's
>> looking really strong, especially if you
consider that he can just go up to seven
here. So almost being able to win that
game and actually if you play down well
I think you much rather lose right
because with Fiora worthy your opponent
is going to be very easily able to push
up to a battlefield with an accelerated
or a ready sand soldier. So I think that
would be not the best play of all times.
>> Yeah. And the thing is downwell is um
it's slow speed as well right. So, it's
not something you can do on your
opponent's turn or anything. So, you
kind of it's
>> if you're going to do it,
>> it would have to be now. But, do you
really want to get rid of all of the the
investment you have on the battlefield
if you're
>> I think you're in such a good spot with
your battlefield. Well, Death Grip
resolves and we're going to rebuke this
absolutely massive token here. So, that
is the first of the defensive cards
being used. We get rid of two sand
soldiers.
>> And something important to note, we
mentioned earlier the cull weeks in hand
for Lucash. the more um I guess it's
actually less of a deal if you have no
sand soldiers, but if you if you have
the Fiora on board, you don't want to
color the week your own unit here. Like
on an empty board, it would be fine, but
it it still again isn't the out that you
need as Azir. Like the ability to reduce
the battlefield for Ezreal is getting
lower and lower and Ezreal if if if
Ludvik untaps goes to awaken phase with
the battlefields as they are will win
this series two and zero. I think
actually I I was mistaken earlier. I
thought that Ezreal would go up to
seven, but we already got that point for
>> that was um that was what uh I I was
mentioning like it looked like for a
moment that Ezreal was on five and I
thought this turn was going to be going
to seven. But yeah, it is slightly
different uh in that Ludic does have to
hold both battlefields or at least
contest both
>> saying okay I'm just going to hold
>> on this battlefield. I don't care about
the Rasa. We are very confident on that
we're holding with the Rasa too because
actually if Lucas is going to take over
the Sigil of the Storm then he's in the
the gameshot position right. However, I
think you have loads of outs for
possible cards that could come into the
Sigil of the Storm.
I guess the thought process is
>> you can go and put everything in for
sigil, but then I'm going I guess to
hold and then have watcher and
everything on your turn has been done
and hopefully you don't have any more.
But that is a bit risky.
>> All right, we're getting a sense soldier
token into that battlefield.
Didn't even see that there was another
one.
So that one is going to be at 368.
It's quite big. Are we just going to Oh,
factory recall. Such a nice side deck
card versus these equipment heavy decks.
It's just an action that bounces one of
those back to hand. And that can make
such a huge difference. Defy is
immediately played to it. So, we are
going to let that resolve. But can you
see a possible fight of flight or reply?
>> Still rebukes in hand and have been for
a while, but going to choose not to use
them um at this point.
>> Is that just to defend the hold now? I
think I mean you can use them
proactively, right? And the next turn
that your opponent doesn't hold and go
to eight.
>> So that is also interesting if your
opponent just passes on that otherwise
your opponent has another play with if
you're worthy.
>> Is is the fear I I can't see how many
cards that Lucash has in hand. is the
fear that you have like two not so fasts
in hand and if you rebuke rebuke then
it's a problem because you're going to
untap with um Lucash
on the battlefield already and if you
can't clear it then they're going to
hold to eight. I don't necessarily think
that it's that it's dead. I think that
if you just rebuke that sand soldier
token the Fiora just goes into that
battlefield
>> and then you have the same problem and
now your opponent is probably tempted to
not put the Fiora into that battlefield.
Actually, I can also see them doing
that. I would have also considered to
play the sand soldier token into that
other battlefield into the sigil, but
we're now passing with so many units in
our base.
>> And now you go up, you go up to seven.
Uh Ludvik does have a thousand tail
watcher in hand. So, it's with three
runes available, three power available.
What answer does Lucas have? If you're
lit, what is available in order to save
this game when I drop a watcher and go
in holding two rebukes? You it'll cost
you a lot to do everything, but you do
have the the runes and the seals and and
the power and energy available to do
everything in that list.
>> Yeah, that's crazy. Double Rebuke plus
watcher is a huge turn. We're starting
with the accelerated watcher. Watcher is
going to bring this down to
>> a minus three.
>> Actually, just a three drop. This is
three might. So you you just need to get
rid of that first and then afterwards I
think even if you just rebuke the sand
soldier, you're in a decent spot because
your opponent still needs to get rid of
this absolute binder on the
>> war. That is it. Two and zero for Lutfik
going through on Ezreal in round three.
That point in the game it's it's
essentially yeah, I'm going to force you
to use some kind of pump spell in
combat. Something that will keep the
sand soldier available. I still have the
rebuke in hand and didn't didn't even
have the the option in order to keep the
sand soldier. And that was a a very very
um I I want to say clean, but also clean
from a sense of like you barely had to
recycle anything on Ezreal the entire
time. Litic just constantly having runes
and seals available
>> never struggled in this point. And I've
talked to Azer players. Ezreal is kind
of a target matchup for them. They want
to really play versus Ezreal saying it
is free. Well, we have seen how free
that can really be. Ludvig was absolut
absolutely phenomenal, wasn't it?
>> It was and we'll hear from him now in
winners interview.
>> Hi everyone, I'm Medic. I'm joined by
Ludvik who just came off an incredible
win on his Ezreal deck. I want to talk a
little bit about Ezreal in this current
meta and why you decided to bring it
here to Bologna. What made you make that
choice? Well, uh, I was testing a lot
with my with my team and my friends and
it just turned out to be like really
good pick because it fits well into the
meta. Uh, it's kind of really
complicated deck. So, you have to be
really prepared for the meta because you
can get like distracted easily and you
might misplay and that mean uh small
misplays might cost you a game. So you
have to be really careful and yeah this
deck is like really strong into the meta
so that's that's why I picked it.
>> So when you talk about making small
misplays making small mistakes are you
worried at all when you have eight
rounds today are possible like six
rounds tomorrow like and then top eight
and like all of these all of these games
are you worried about endurance for that
sort of length of time?
>> Well I am playing TCGs for like 10
years. Okay. Uh so
uh it's I'm kind of used to this. Uh I
like playing the card games that TCGs a
lot. So uh I don't really get tired that
that much and I can think properly even
after like six, seven rounds and things
like that.
>> That's really good, right? Cuz for me my
old brain is like I I have to play like
or something. It just has to be really
easy for me. Um you played into Azir.
How how do you find that matchup goes?
It seemed like he just didn't really
have the ability to get anything to
stick on on the battlefield at all.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Uh well, the matchup goes uh
for me uh kind of onto my favorite uh he
goes like to five or six points early uh
because he's having some pressure. I try
to like slow him down and then I just
slam some like fist rases thousand tail
watchers and I just control the board
with like rebukes and wages on Yeah. FS
and Yeah, it's like I I get the old
tempo back that I lost.
>> Yeah, that makes sense. Is there any
deck that you are fearful of in the
meta? Anything you think you would
struggle into?
Uh yeah, I from our testing it turns out
that the miracle Draven is uh like the
hardest matchup. Uh so I'm kind of
scared of this particular matchup. Uh I
managed to won it yesterday uh on the PR
regional uh event. Uh but it was really
really tough and I'm also kind of scared
of Aurora. Okay. Because yeah that if
you just hy roll you win. But on the
rest, I think I'm pretty well prepared.
>> And yeah.
>> Well, thank you so much for joining us.
Is there anything you want to say to
your friends, your fans out there before
we conclude the interview?
>> Well, I I would like to thanks to all of
my friends that were testing with me.
And yeah, that's mostly it. Thank you
very much.
>> Thanks so much for joining us. Good luck
on the rest of the tournament.
Thank you very much, Medic, for that
great interview with our feature match
player on Ezreal in round three. I I'm
excited to see some variance in decks.
That was a fun matchup.
>> Yeah, honestly, Ludwick crushed it. The
pacing of his plays were fantastic. He
was really fast with it in a complicated
deck. He made all the right choices,
great sequencing, and he was, you know,
I love this heart rate thing we have
going on because he was incredibly calm
the entire time, playing a tough match
up out to perfection, completely
stomping his opponent there. That was
that was top player mentality, top
player contention actually. So, I think
that this was not the last time we see
from him.
>> I'm glad we don't have heart rate
monitors on us. I'm going to be honest
as we go in with the the fear of of
seeing what we're going to be playing or
at least casting. And our second feature
match for round three is going to be an
interesting match up. Two champions that
we haven't seen uh today, you and I. Uh
and that is Misfortune playing up
against Lucian, I believe it is, which
is an interesting battle of the 80
carries from League of Legends
traditionally as uh we will get into
game shortly.
>> Who has more lane pressure?
>> Uh
>> depends on the patch. Most of the time
that I was casting it was Lucian. There
were some times where MF was was good
and especially there was some like
clunky AP builds that made MF really
good, but I I think this is Aurora MF,
which
>> I love, but I think in this meta, some
people think it can be quite slow.
Aurora decks are always like if you get
to the Aurora point, you're going to
turn that corner, play big play big
units, and run away with it. Lucian,
however, is like, "Yeah, I'm going to
try and combo out." A lot of the decks,
as hopefully we'll we'll see as we go
through this. A lot of the decks are
trying to play that kind of one turn
kill Lucian where you jump from four
points to eight points to to to win the
game. So, we'll see as we go through uh
in this matchup um and see how things
are going. We're seeing sideboards here
between the two. We'll see what matchup
we are jumping into. Of course, this is
our backup feature match, meaning that
this was playing at the same time as our
first series. Quite curious to see as we
have seen these sideboards if we are
going to see first
>> game three or something if or if we are
going to find out what we're jumping
into. So this is uh what looks like the
Lucian uh deck list. Uh Bone Shiver the
promo card here for Bologna for those
that are in attendance.
>> That's really cool. this version running
the ruin runner, the the camel deck that
people were talking a lot coming into
this set and seeing how it's one of the
only units, you know, it has a very
unique effect where it's like I can't be
the target of abilities. I can't be
chosen by abilities and spells, which is
uh quite difficult to deal with.
>> It gives Kaiser a run for for her money.
I want to say that this is really really
strong. Also, versus Draven, it's really
good. You can't get rebuked. you are,
I'm almost, I want to say, in control of
the game when you have the Ruiner
Runner. So, you can sit on the Ruer
Runner in one of the battlefields. But
also, if you have the Triforce and the
Skyfall, you're in a good spot because,
you know, Triforce when you're holding,
you get an extra point in Skyfall makes
your hold effects your conquer effects
and your conquer effects your hold
effects and vice versa. You know,
everything everything becomes everything
basically. So if you go into
battlefield, you conquer, you get two
points and then you can go over to
another one with cards like relentous
pursuit and then you get two more. So
that is the the OTK as you say. And I
think versus Aurora decks, this is quite
nice if you get to set up your combo, if
you draw into it, you know, body is not
really known for all the card draw, then
you uh might be able to win the game.
Now, one area that this misfortune might
be able to get to, I'm seeing there's
mind spplitters in a deck, which when
you're playing a combo deck or or a deck
that can rely on a combo, having hand
destruction against it is very
frustrating to play against like cards
like Sabotage, cards like Mindsplitter
that say, "Okay, if I can catch you
before that Skyfall is on the
battlefield, if I can use a card that'll
let me take that out of your hand, well,
suddenly your one turn kill is no longer
available until you draw into And as you
said, sometimes you struggle with that
draw. So it looks like we are going into
game number two of this series and
Misfortune did take the first game. So
we are post sideboard. We are into a
game in which Lucian is going to come
out first and we on Obelisk. Yes. So
that will give Lucian that three. Allows
you to play Lucian straight away.
>> Not the not the end of the world for
that. That is quite nice to go into a a
turn two untapping with Lucian.
>> Also, I want to mention I love the High
Noon skins. This is really, really cool.
But also, of course, starting with the
obelisk of power and immobilize as well,
just immediately ramping up. Misfortune
is going to get to a turn three Aurora.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, hang on. Was
that both Skyfall and Trinity Force in
hand?
>> Oh, yeah,
>> it is. The combo pieces are here. So,
now we're just hoping like if you're the
Lucian fan, you're hoping there is no
sabotage in hand. You got turn one
mobilized was fine. Gust is going to
take Lucian back to hand. Um if it ends
up resolving
do you invest a punch first or you just
replay the Lion
>> just a lot at this point. You also you
still already know that you're playing
versus Aurora. So you are aware that you
have to close out the game rather sooner
than later
>> quickly. Is it going to be sabotage
looking for a sabotage? This is one of
my favorite interactions of when you
have hand attack in a card game and you
have to take the hand attack for Aurora.
>> I mean, yeah, you take the Aurora
because a mindsplitter. One, two, three,
four, five. Oh, do you take the mind
spplitter? Actually, wait. You can't.
Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. I'm I'm so far.
>> You're so mind splittered. I know. I'm
just everything.
>> The problem is I coming from from games
uh where you do have early turns where
you can play a card that will let you
take anything. And uh in this case,
there are restrictions. So yeah, Aurora
goes,
>> but now I think that card value-wise,
Lucian is in quite the nice spot. Also a
gust early on the Lucian. Yes. Okay, it
stops you from gaining tempo, but there
is not really a lot happening on the
other side, but this is a nice challenge
of the chosen champion units there.
Misfortune immediately taking out the
Lucian. Is that
>> I'm losing track of what I wanted to
say. Is that a sign? I mean, I I think
it's something I I also overlooked
rushing to jump to first mind spplitter
and then Aurora. I I looked at it and
thought, okay, well, the mind spplitter
can't be played until next turn. So, if
that comes out, the challenge isn't
really available. But then forgetting
that Misfortune from the champion zone
was available.
Oh, do you see what I see on the right
side of the hand of Drink Maker? That is
an Axan. So, if there's going to be a
Tazzling Aurora, that could be nasty
stuff. That is brutal if that happens.
>> Imagine hitting a ruin runner of the
dazzling aurora that your opponent just
so neatly gave you.
>> Oh, okay. The action gets played out
because you I I guess you're just going
to try and end the game. I you know that
you took the aurora anyway. So holding
it in hand, you're like the the value.
We got ahead of ourselves for a moment.
>> Yeah, but I think that also keeping the
axan wouldn't be a nice bait for a
mindspplitter target, right? Because
mindsplitter now can take away one of
your combo pieces for later on the
trinity force or the skyfall. If there
was an Axan still I mean I I agree with
you. You have to play some units.
>> We're seeing the challenge being taken
which is interesting. Now is there a
clarification here on the language? So
um important to know
the legality of cards does include
Chinese cards now um or or or uh other
language printings I think is a way I'll
put it because there are French cards as
well now. Um so you can mix languages in
a legal deck. Um, so the the Skyfall is
in uh Chinese, I believe, in drink
maker's hand. So I think there was a
moment of clarification there upon
seeing it just like, "Hey, can you can
you remind me exactly the wording on
that card?"
>> So it's always great that we also have
some judges and some helpers at the
table that can just
>> get you where you want to be with all
the card knowledge that you might have
not acquired before the tournament
because some of these strategies are
pretty niche. Now you're going to see
one of the most iconic items from the
history of League of Legends.
>> Yeah, here comes the Trinity Force. And
the other thing about that is sometimes
even like the best players are like, can
you just remind me the exact wording
like there's always like a may or up to
that you're like, "Yeah, I've got I I
need to make sure I know exactly that
and just double check." So I I do find
it interesting. It was a challenge. I I
think as a gut reaction, I'd be like,
"Oh, break the combo. Break the combo."
But I guess the the combo requires units
to be able to actually like guide them
around the each battlefield. So I can
definitely appreciate like if you can
>> get board control in a different way,
maybe there is a way to to to stay in
this game.
>> That's what I find really cool. Pushing
the Axan with the Triforce and then
going into the Orans Forge
actually also equipping the Skyfall.
Really re should we have done that
before?
Did we do that before? I don't know. But
we know that we have punch first in hand
as well. So if you're being challenged
with misfortune and the might spplitter,
then that is also going to be a lot of
might that you're going to have to
overcome. We know you have punch first
in hand. So a would go to 13, which is
still a little more than misfortune and
the mind spplitter. Or is misfortune six
mine?
>> We're going to find out soon.
>> We'll find out. And I think it might be
That reflection is in the the so at
least
>> we just took one turn so we did not
>> in fact get the
>> we didn't get the double point so chose
to equip afterwards. Um
>> I'd be interested to hear the uh the way
that that played out. And now a last
rights coming through. So that will
allow uh units to come back from the
graveyard. is actually not doing
anything specifically now or with the uh
the the way that it goes on conquer or
hold, but eventually will be important
to recur units. So, just giving the
extra might for now.
>> It's plus two might and that is really
important because we figured out Axan is
now at eight might. There's one punch
first in hand is going to get you up to
13. But then with the last rights
equipped, you could probably take away
everything that Drink Maker has right
now. There is nothing he can do against
that. Just trades it off. doesn't decide
to just use the punch firstly because
for what would do anything and now you
have a misfortune that has ganking the
last rights and you have a mind
spplitter in the discuss so I think that
misfortune is looking phenomenal right
now even if there is no dazzling aurora
just because his opponent the Lucian
deck basically doesn't have any real
grind game right now
>> yeah there hasn't been the pressure in
the early game in order to kind of put
the clock like start the clock early and
say okay I'm just going to keep getting
points I'm going to keep getting points
and then I'll be able to close the game
before you actually get Aurora down.
Aurora has not been necessary as uh we
get further into this game as uh our
Lucian player untaps for their turn as
Fortune is just chilling in that
battlefield. Keep in mind it gets
ganking easily. Kaiser is being
accelerated here. So we are going to go
probably into this actually. Okay, I
think we're just trying to beat over the
misfortune.
Sounds great if we equip the last
strides and the trinity force so we
could get some Oh, something is
happening here. But we I think we can
use this turn
>> to actually just really neatly go into
that battlefield. We have the punt first
in hand as well. We get a draw. So,
conquer. So, I think that Kai'Sa
survivor might have been the best top
deck ever possible for the drink maker.
Yeah, I was trying to follow along with
the number of tapped runes there for
equipping and uh
accelerate. There was a lot done at the
same time. So shortcutting to a point
where where Kaiser had both equipped,
I believe, if I'm not mistaken, Skyfall
costs one and a recycle to equip. Or is
that Trinity Forces? One of the two I
think does uh cost an additional one,
which is where that extra power comes
from.
Now we'll get the card draw of course uh
off
the Kaiser Conqueror
and we go back over to Misfortune who
has a lot now thanks to the the the
mobilize getting the extra rune channel.
Needs something to do with it though.
>> It's like having runes is great. Uh cold
shot will get you there or potentially.
>> So we're going to find some cards but we
do not have anything to stop the DM. So,
Callot, while it is a great card, and I
think if you're playing Aurora, it's
even better if you have it in play.
Like, while you already have this card
that generates you big units from your
deck for free, you can just you can just
recycle all of your runes. It doesn't
really matter. You keep the pressure up
so you can find the removal, the outs
certain situations.
>> Okay, double catalyst off the top. Our
misfortune player, Sebie, just says,
"Yeah, okay. No, that's not good. This
is going to be the one time when I see
uh
am I reading that correct? It was a a
concession.
>> It was for sure something.
>> Yeah. Okay. Cuz Misfortune won the first
game. So we came into game two and then
uh even though it didn't look like it,
maybe this is playing for time. I would
love actually now that it's not on
screen. I realized I should have looked
at it before, but to know how much time
we had left in the game cuz Misfortune
Aurora even when winning does take a
while.
>> So saying, "Okay, I didn't get anything
good off my call shots." So yeah, we're
done. Like get out of this game, get
into game three. Um,
>> and it's it's so interesting because it
looked really good for Misfortune
setting up with the rights and the mind
splitter in the discard pile, but then
this top deck of Kaiser Survivor
immediately equipping it with the best
combination of equipments you can have,
which is really expensive, but when it's
on the field, it's on the field. So
getting the Triforce and the Skyfall on
it just immediately made this card so
good. So you're going to just hold for
two points. Then you're putting your
opponent on a real clock. There's a
really interesting card in the
sideboard. The uh Fading Memories, which
is not a card we see very often, um was
one of like the
uh cards from Origins that allowed you
to basically have uh single target
removal cuz it gives a a unit temporary.
So, it dies essentially on your
opponent's upkeep. U
dies in the beginning phase uh before
scoring um is the important part of
that. So, not something we see too too
much in decks, but um it is one thing
that purple and and and chaos that that
domain does struggle with is the ability
to permanently remove units. There's a
lot of bouncing, a lot of pushing, a lot
of uh you know, rebuking, but actually
getting units into the graveyard is is a
lot trickier.
>> I mean, if you're playing versus
something that has the last rights in
the deck, permanently getting ready of
them is always a pretty difficult thing
to do. just recent
Kaiser top
out for the misfortune. Misfortune gets
you back a mice even when holding. So I
think if you do not find anything to
just out it immediately which the deck
has very few options to do so.
>> Yeah,
>> it's just over finding that Kaiser
survivor that even gives you a draw then
was absolutely massive.
>> There's an Aurora in hand uh to begin
the game. I mean, it's going to be a a
stack deck to start things off. I didn't
quite see which card was taken, but
we'll find out in in just a moment when
we uh get it revealed. Immobilize comes
through.
>> So good with the obelisk of power that
you can stack deck into mobilize in the
first turn with Civer or of course with
the bounty hunter misfortune.
>> There's a really really really strong
play especially if so many people are on
obisk of power right now. I think this
is really where those decks profit from
it. That's why Aurora is making a bit of
a comeback.
>> Yeah,
>> because almost everyone is playing Obis
of Power.
>> It's great. Do like that combination.
There's the sabotage and we take a we
sigh and we say I guess I'm losing the
Aurora again.
>> Aurora is gone. We also have an Axan
>> in the hand, right? Oh no, that is the
Volibear Furious. That makes way more
sense in an Aurora deck actually.
>> Mhm. And I mean there is an argument to
be made to take the catalyst of Aon just
so your opponent doesn't ramp up that
fast. But actually I think
>> you're going to get there anyway. Like
you're going to get there anyway. So put
the Aurora to the bottom and uh and be
done. And yeah, here's a catalyst is
going to ramp up. Um Volibear
>> having having had the ramp of the
mobilizing into the catalyst, I feel
like it's not the end of the world to
have it in hand, but you definitely
would prefer to rip it from an Aurora,
right? Like if you got nothing else to
do, you'll you'll like sigh and say,
"Fine, I guess I'll play it." But uh you
really would prefer that for free.
>> But the good thing is with the catalyst
of you, you get to play it next turn.
>> Exactly. If you don't have anything else
to play, you can play a volair furious,
which is a furiously big unit already.
And here we can see the bone shiver
event promo being played as well.
So just buffing up that. I mean, buffing
is the wrong word here, but boosting up
that Lucian Merciless. Yeah, that's
something that I've had to drop from my
uh my vocabulary of buff all the time.
I'm always like, "Yeah, it's going to
buff it up." And I'm like, "Nope, that's
actually a mechanic." Uh it will not be
a buff. It will just make it stronger
>> as uh Lucian get a conquer conquer
effect from Lucian comes through will
first time each turn that you conquer
ready me. So is able to get back to the
base very very safely.
>> And that's also a cool way of ramping
up, right? Because if you have the bone
shiver, you get to channel rune
exhausted if you're conquering. So you
get a bunch of stuff every single time.
I think this deck is just trying to run
away from your opponent as fast as
possible.
>> Yeah.
>> Now a call shot is actually pretty nice.
>> Like how many have you got? Okay, we got
to eight. Okay, you can't Aurora this
turn. Fine. Um that is one thing that
Aurora decks uh does have a problem
with. You can get the cards out in the
wrong order.
>> You can because we floated
>> floated one. Yes. Yeah. Sorry.
>> If there is an Aurora, I think that card
could just as well be player. But now we
have stack deck. So, I think we got rid
of that one. Actually, no, we should
still be at
10. Yeah, but didn't find it. Double
called shot and a stack deck. Did not
find another copy of Aurora. That is uh
Now, do you just say, "Okay, I'm going
to Damp fully." You're going to see
another four cards and you're just like,
I'll float two more. Still got the power
to play it. And if I just play it, yes,
I'm going down to uh three runes on my
next turn, but I have got to find it.
There is a mine spplitter two off the
top. Doesn't find the aurora. Does not
get the dazzling aurora which means this
power will be used likely for a mine
spplitter.
>> But again, constant dramping.
>> Yeah. And mine spplitter costs you two
power two, right? So if you don't find
the Aurora,
>> wait, actually only one purple. Only one
purple.
>> Yeah, you had to use cold shot the
entire time. So you took away four chaos
ruins
>> and you can't even catalyst because the
math doesn't add up. You you would need
11 power to do that. You can't catalyst
into your other purple rune. Oh, that's
backbreaking with all of this draw. Not
able to find the Aurora after the
sabotage takes one out of hand early on
means that's a lot spent. Oh my
goodness, that was a huge turn that
ended up nowhere. Now, Misfortune is
being played as well. I mean, you got
some of your runes back, but this is
definitely not where you wanted to be.
This was the high investment into I'm
going to find my win condition. But
that's the issue with those Aurora
decks, right? If you do not have Aurora,
if you do not find it, let alone if you
if you never drew one. I mean, this one
got sabotaged, but there's plenty of
gear removal when it's on the field as
well.
>> It's it's not the end of the world in
the sense of like you still have eight
runes now. You'll awaken and then
channel up to 10. So, if you do find an
Aurora off the top,
>> yeah,
>> maybe. Or if it's like a stack deck off
the top, maybe. But really now you're
like, "Wow, deck. Can you just give me
my cards in any acceptable order,
please?" I mean, you have plenty of time
in the aspirin climb game. So that's
very good. We're going up to nine here
as you can see nicely on the overlay.
>> And of course, the Lucian is going in
here. Get a rune exhausted and it's
ready immediately. So you can actually
just push it back to the base if you do
not want to risk it for the biscuit. I'm
going to play a Skyfall here. It's
funny. I did actually ask uh if we have
an overlay for if it's a double aspirin
climb game, and the answer is yes.
>> Oh, that's cool.
>> I know. I I had the same thought. I saw
the overlay. So, I go to A. I was like,
"What happens if it's aspirin climb?"
And they're like, "We have that." I was
like, "What happens if it's double
aspirin climb?" We've got that, too.
>> We've got the 10 covered. That's nice.
>> Skyfall, I think I feel like could have
been attached before as well, just to
get another rune exhausted and just have
it already on the Lucian. That would
have been a free attach, but maybe you
don't even want that. It's also good the
skyfall has been played out now that
it's mine spplitter turns. You know,
again, no Aurora from the top,
>> but uh the Skyfall can't be discarded.
So, if you are by any chance top decking
a Trinity Force, oh, we want the long
sword on the Lionus. All right. Okay, I
see it. We want more might. An important
thing here for for players to know um
that because there is a trigger that
goes on the uh on the chain for
mindsplitter when it enters it puts
something on the chain you can react to
that before it resolves. Uh so I I think
a lot of players, you know, are familiar
now that units can't be reacted to, but
the the trigger that comes from mind
spplitter can be reacted to. And that's
long sword. Uh obviously seemingly the
the most important thing by drink maker
to to retain control of and not get
discarded at that point.
>> And uh Sebie just decided to take out
the Axan, which makes sense. If you want
to eventually find your Aurora, then you
want to keep it for a moment.
>> Yeah. You don't want it gone immediately
because that would be such a momentum
swing.
>> Uh here is a punch first coming through.
Uh I believe that was targeting mind
splits. I'm assuming the challenge is
coming after. Yeah, there we go. Already
uh following up. Um and the two
Relentless Pursuits we saw in hand.
There has been a lot of discussion over
the last couple of days about the the
wording on Relentless Pursuit. Um, I
believe at this point it is in a state
where you do require an equipment, which
is not a problem for drink maker having
three equipments on the board. Don't
need to worry about that thankfully. But
it's the unit that is actually more of
an issue at this situation. And there
you go. That's exactly the choice for
the Achan cuz you knew the challenge was
coming out from the mine spplitter.
Clear the board. Your equipment does
nothing if you have no units to equip it
to.
>> Oh, and he's just passing again. No
Kaiser from the top. So, at this point,
you really don't want to give your
Aurora opponent more time to possibly
find that card or find something else.
>> Now, we're going to go ganking.
>> Ganking kicks in. We're going to be able
to score both battlefields this turn.
And just with the one unit, keeping a
mind splitter in base, not
overcommitting to both battlefields.
>> Misfortune is just having the time of
her life here.
>> Yeah. And I I saw a can barrage be uh
taken from the top uh in this situation.
a misfortune deck that is running Aurora
that has not found Auroras is managing
to stabilize which is impressive. I
believe earlier we we said that Volibar
was playable but it's actually it's a 12
power. It's 12 power 10 might.
>> Yeah,
>> those the getting him backwards
sometimes uh not the easiest. So uh I
don't think Volbear is ever going to be
seen in this game at the state that
we're in with runes. It's uh too costly
at this point. Very good point because
we're going to very likely see a Mind
Splitter soon again just to develop at
this point.
>> Do you even play Dazzling Aurora
anymore? Because this card is just
there's so few units in your deck that
you want to play Mind Splitter. Another
pass. It was cuz it was just punch first
off the top.
>> Yeah.
>> Just takes the punch first. I I know
you're probably not taking the the
relentless pursuit. This is
>> really painful for drink maker. Just not
able to draw more cards. That is a
really rough spot to be in. Accept a
turn pass. Accept the turn pass. Draw
one. Doesn't get what they needed. And
uh every time that something is in hand,
it either gets mind spplittered or then
played and challenged. Really difficult.
I I got to kind of commend the uh our
misfortune player Sebi for accurately
attacking the hand of Drink Maker and
just making sure that there are no
options here.
>> Yeah, I I love how drink maker is
playing with the cards. He was praying
for it. He was really really hoping that
there was going to be something to play
with. Gets the Ruin Runner. So there
might be a chance.
>> And Ruin Runner turns off a lot of the
interaction that Misfortune has. You
can't fight or flight it. You can't
challenge it. The only real way around
it is through it with like a punch first
or you know committing multiple units to
it. Still got 5 minutes on the round.
So, uh, there is still enough time for
both players to kind of get back into
this, but that is a consideration at
this point.
>> I think you can also take it out with
the bullet time, right? Bullet time
shouldn't target. It's all the units at
the battlefield that take the damage
>> as long Yeah, as long as it doesn't
target the the room runner, that is
fine. If it's targeting the battlefield,
that would be okay. Uh, costly costly
bullet time
>> to uh make it work.
>> Now, Drink Maker is setting up for a
rather huge turn
and is now discussing with his opponent.
It's four more minutes on the clock
>> and then overtime rules as uh they were
recently changed just as a as a
clarification for everybody. It is an
additional three turns starting uh after
the 60 minutes has elapsed and it is you
have to be ahead by two points in order
to win otherwise the game does end in a
tie. So for instance if it ended now
Sebie would take the win but we still
have four minutes of regular time plus
overtime. Um, here's a Relentless
Pursuit.
>> And now we have looked at this card
plenty of times on the side of Zabby,
but definitely decides to read it again
one more time. Still has the option to
fight or flight his own misfortune to
just save up that unit and then perhaps
conquer the other battlefield.
But because you can't fight or flight
the ruin runner, right?
>> No, you can't. It specifically reads, "I
can't be the target of enemy spells and
abilities." An enemy is the active word
here, which is why Relentless Pursuit is
able to uh to do it. So, fight or flight
your own unit. That's perfectly fine.
>> You can definitely do that. Preserve the
might that you have on this misfortune.
You have two of those mine spplitters.
So, even if this is a huge rune runner,
there's a good chance that you can
overpower it with all of your units that
have been hard played. All right, pulls
back the rune runner. Okay, doesn't want
to go into combat and is really hoping
for another top deck on the next turn.
Sebie might just have a really really
good turn here.
>> This is always when you draw Aurora on
the Aurora player when you don't want
it. You're like
>> kind of
>> again count the runes. Double check what
we're at. 2 4 6 eight. Okay. No Aurora
if even if it was possible. But
importantly, there is the opportunity to
go uh one of the units onto the
battlefield onto Obelisk or or you know
onto Aspirin's prime. I guess we we got
got to keep remembering we're going to
nine. So it is important to try and
score both of these battlefields if you
are Sebby this turn to try and get
yourself up to nine.
>> I guess the question is are you looking
at the clock at this point and saying
okay well regardless of what I'm doing
with getting to nine I have to stay two
points ahead at all times which getting
to nine is the fastest way to do that.
>> That's true. I mean semi is just at this
point oh relentless pursuit on the
misfortune move but
>> the fighter flight is going to come
through here again. Same thing if
needed. Yeah, he drew it off the top of
this uh either this turn or last turn. I
think it might have been the last rights
this turn actually. But uh
>> I think you could have even just let it
go and then equip a mind spplitter with
the rights and then take over the
aspirins clamp and get the misfortune
back that way.
>> But I think using Fighter is also fine.
I I don't think we have any units in the
discard pile, right?
>> Uh that is a really good question. I'm
trying to remember what was played this
game. might I think you might be right.
>> I think rightites is just there for the
fights. Right now
>> the question is do we just now go to
seven by pushing into aspirin climb and
the scope of how we do it at the same
time?
>> You know the opponent is uh has all the
runes exhausted. So no real response
from this. So saying well let's just go
to seven. I'll uh see how you can deal
with that on your turn. 90 seconds left
on the clock of uh regulation time on
this round. Being at seven is a good
spot for Sebie, but we'll see what Drink
Maker can actually make work here with
this giant camel.
>> Drink maker is just also taking his
sweet time just in this turn, just one
minute before the timeout and being so
far behind in those points is tough.
>> Is leaning back in the chat at this
point. He's like, "Well, let's see what
you can do. See what you got."
>> He knows he's not going to lose this
game because he's so far ahead in
points, but this become a tie. What are
we going to see next? Which is the next
card? A Trinity Force. Does that change
anything?
>> Here's where you have to get in the tank
and do the math of like, okay, what can
you actually do with a Trinity Force
with this many uh with this many turns
left on the Ruin Runner. So, if you go
and conquer, that is going to give you
an additional point. It'll jump.
>> I believe you got a six here, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And then we've seen both Relentless
Pursuits if I'm not mistaken. You can't
get to the other battlefield yet without
it. But if you were able to, you would
jump up to eight.
>> Yeah.
>> And be in a great position. But I think
that's going to be it.
>> But now Seir just really needs to get it
going there in in timeout before I mean
there's the Aurora. You've been wanting
it all game and as you go into turns,
you draw the Aurora.
>> Not this time. Not this time. But now
also you won't be able to get another
draw this turn. The rights is going on
to this mine spplitter. This is also
something you could have done in the
last turn, but then again, this would
have been battlefield that would be
targeted
>> just for the extra might
counting.
>> We know that Drink Master should have no
card in hand. So, we're we're checking
five plus two plus two. There's a lot
open and it looks like the math does
math for Sebie. Able to take out the
giant camel and without Aurora up until
the last moment where it was far too
late.
>> Twins game three on the misfortune able
to take that one down. Um that was uh
like right down to the wire like
nailbiting
level of uh of late game play at that
point.
>> Was really close to the timeout as well.
So both players really taking their time
in game three as well just trying to
figure out the right solution on how to
play through those big turns especially
versus Aurora. sometimes really
difficult to navigate because you're
facing so much might and you think okay
my deck is you know you trust your deck
right you you know okay there are some
possibilities I know I can play through
this somehow but how because there is 21
might then sometimes you don't even get
there but you spend a solid 2 or 3
minutes of thinking on how to play
through something so sometimes it's
really really tough to play against
those decks
>> sometimes it is let's find out how tough
it was to play against as we head to an
interview with our winner
>> hey I'm medic. I'm joined by Sebic or
Sebastian. Thank you so much for joining
me. Congratulations on the win. I want
to talk a little bit about Aurora. We
saw it a huge amount in Origins, but it
kind of has fallen down the pecking
order when it comes to Spirit Forge.
What made you pick Aurora for this
tournament?
>> Uh I used to play Misfortune on set one.
That that was the that I fell in love. I
was basically kind of almost almost
dropped the game entirely and my friend
showed me oh there's super nice deck
Aurora Misfortune should try it and I
was like super super obsessed with her.
H that's why I'm following it. Mid-range
version looks a little bit better but I
feel like if I want to go to the
tournament and win something for at
least like best of metal card or qualify
day two, you still need to hire a little
bit. It's card card game, not chess. So,
I have high hopes that I'm I'm going to
ramp ramp Aurora every game and we'll
see how it goes.
>> Have you played many card games before
playing with bounds?
>> Uh, I played one. I'm not going to say
the name, don't worry.
>> Okay.
>> Uh, for like two years and this decks
works similar to the what I played. It's
like playing one card per turn, waiting
a little bit. Yeah, it's it's super
super close. That that's why I like it.
>> I get that. I think sometimes,
especially when it's an endurance
competition, when there's so many
rounds, having something that is
relatively simple to do and you know
exactly how it's going to interact
really helps you in that sort of stuff.
Is there any deck in the format that
you're really looking forward to playing
against or any deck that you really
think just I I don't want to match into
a single one of those guys? Uh there's
one deck uh Victor without units and how
it's possible that I'm playing unit with
for like 12 cost and he can kill it with
two cost spell. I'm just like looking
into his eye and he's like scoring
points records and then okay you can win
you can take the game and you can finish
in 15 minutes if you want. Uh but I I
would love love to play against Ireelia.
I feel like the matchup is really good
for Aurora and Misfortune. But other
than that everything is kind of okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. But uh as you said like the deck
is simple but for example like Draven
Miracle or like Ezreal are super
complicated decks and I don't feel like
I will sustain playing 8 hours or 10
hours
>> with that deck. It's my my brain is like
will be super tired after that.
>> Yeah, understandable. I think my brain
will be the same way. Before we let you
go firstly, good luck in the rest of the
tournament. Hopefully you managed to to
make it to the top eight or even the
best of if that's what you're looking
for.
>> Yeah, maybe. Uh, is there anything you
want to say to your team, to your
friends, anyone who might be watching?
>> Thank you, friends, for showing me that
deck and thank you for the testing.
Thank you for the list. Thank you, team
Poland.
>> Thank you so much for joining us.
>> Wow, Medic, thank you so much for that
fantastic interview. You jazzed over
here so quick.
>> I have teleportation capabilities. Yes,
I I wish I was stuck in Frankfurt for a
whole day. If I had teleportation
capabilities, I I definitely would be
gallant gallivanting all over the world.
But it is great to be back. We are here
for round four of the RQ here in
Bologno. And we've had some really good
games so far. Some really interesting
matchups as well. And I believe that
continues as we get into our first
matchup of round four in a few moments
time. Ireelia into Lee Sin, which is not
something we too commonly see these
days.
>> No. But actually, I'm really curious of
the tussle between those two because
they work. They kind of have the same
goal Midame, right? And and so and they
have similar tactics that they employ to
try and buff their units to make
something so big that their opponent
can't deal with it to hold the
battlefields and then kind of take the
lead and stay in the lead.
>> What happens when those two forces come
together? But they are different in
their own right and they do have tactics
against one another, but it's not a
matchup that I have seen a lot of. I'm
going to be honest with you guys. But
that's why I'm honestly really excited
to see how these guys play it out and
whether that whether it's clear that
they know what to do with this match up
because it's tough.
>> I think the le player probably has a lot
of experience playing into Aurelia. I
don't know if the Aurelia has a lot of
experience playing into Leins and
something I don't have a lot of
experience with is flavor text.
>> Like I don't listen to champion quotes
in League. I don't I have them used a
lot of the time when I play. I don't
read the bottom of the card cuz why
would I when there's the top of the card
that has the important stuff? And I
believe we're going to play a little bit
of guess that flavor text here on the
Riftbound stream because we like
embarrassing ourselves.
>> Well, the thing is I've read Oh.
>> Oh, okay. I mean, this one is relatively
simple.
>> Join the glorious evolution.
>> Glorious evolution. Any ideas?
>> Um, it's going to be a Victor, isn't it?
>> It is. I'm not sure. I mean, the
question is, is it Victor Victor
>> or
>> or is it a different Victor?
>> Oh, it's on the screen.
>> Oh, it is Victor. It's innovator. Okay.
We knew it was Victor. We'll take that
blue Victor. Close enough, you know.
>> Yeah, that's a point.
>> I feel like production is kind of giving
us a little bit of benefit. Okay, so new
flavor text. Here we go. Here we go.
>> Here we go. Can you guys get it quicker
than we can?
>> It's nothing. Okay, I know there's
nothing on
>> buff token. No,
>> Kaiser evolution rem.
>> It probably is on Kaiser. We'll find out
what the next one is for a minute. Does
Aurelia Fervent have flavor sex? Yes,
>> I think like a lot of cards have flavor
sex. It's actually something I had been
looking at. I want a turd.
That feels very Annie to me, but I'm Oh,
it might be time. Do you think it's time
warp?
>> No, I I don't think it is time warp
because that implies that like the turn
hasn't happened. It's kind of like this
is a it's my turn now kind of.
>> I want to turn. No, I want to turn. It
feels feels It feels Annie. You're being
Annie. It feels more Annie to me than
anything else. Yeah,
>> it does. It does.
>> I want to turn, but Annie probably is
more like fire.
I think I I I think Annie, if I remember
Annie properly, there's like there quite
ferocious like maybe capital letters in
that box. I don't think it's Annie.
>> Okay,
>> I want to turn. I think that's really
I'm struggling on this one.
>> I I think we might be trying too hard to
equate it to a mechanic.
>> Yes,
>> I want to turn. I want a turn. My turn.
Hello. Please let me have a turn. A
porro. No, don't speak. A mech of some
sort. I want a turn. Maybe uh definitely
not Rex eye. Rexi is like
that is the flavor text.
>> Exactly. It's mur guest.
>> Uh okay. I'm thinking
>> Oh my goodness. I'm really struggling.
>> N
cuz N's like N.
>> Oh no.
>> So I'm going to Should we just throw one
out there? Throw it out. Chuck it into
the void.
>> Um
>> I'm gonna I'm gonna go Kaiser. I'm gonna
say sure. We're locking in Kaiser. Final
answer.
>> You didn't have to.
>> No, I I agree with you always.
>> I was
>> I was like I was thinking maybe it was
someone a bit more like regal, you know,
like I want to turn now.
>> My my voice acting isn't good enough cuz
if it was perfect, we would have got it.
So I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'll let you
down. Oh, we have one more.
>> We have another
>> one more. Here we go. I'm ready. I'm
ready to go.
>> Ignore me fervently typing.
>> Remember this moment.
>> Remember this moment. Uh
>> okay. So my instinctelia
karma those are the two that jump into
my it feels Ionian
>> I think Aurelia I think I think that's
pretty
>> remember this moment remember this
moment here
>> yeah it's got that vibe it's got that
energy we're going to go Aelia
>> we're going to go with it
>> we're locking it in
>> it's probably not a highinger it's not
going to be a victor
>> Ari
we had it you know it was calm we had
the vibe
>> we knew the vibe
Does Ari say remember this moment?
>> Yes, it's there. It's
>> like just cuz it's a flavor text doesn't
is that automatically a quote from the
champion?
>> No.
>> So it could be someone else saying
remember this moment. This is the moment
you got.
>> Yeah. But I feel like sometimes with a
character like Yeah. We do have to think
about the embodiment of them. Like we
were right with the Annie and we doubted
ourselves and we should never doubt
ourselves.
>> Okay. But then we got immediately
punished for that.
>> But realiz you got to you got to think
about it. Riftbound does a really great
job of having characters which do what
they do in League.
>> Yes.
>> In Riftbound, like it's very
intrinsically linked. Annie is very
indicative of the way that she plays in
the video game. Bringing that to the
card game, I think, is genius. I love
it. And I love learning about the
characters more as we go through the
sets. Um, I'm getting to learn new
characters, and I adore that. Yeah, I
love learning the links between them.
Like,
>> yeah, you're a warbuff, aren't you?
>> Yeah, it was it was it was a and they're
brothers moment for me, you know?
>> Yeah, I get that.
>> No wonder they're so similar. Like, it's
when all the dots connect and I think
that's wonderful because they bring that
into the mechanics and I feel like the
flavor text fits there, too.
>> Yeah, I agree with that. I do think that
as a League of Legends player, I never
want to remember the moment an AR pops
off cuz I feel AR players are like Yasu
players and Yona players where they're
all like, "Oh, look at me. I'm so cool.
I'm spirit rushing all over the place."
Don't know why this accent is kind of
semi- German. I'm spirit rushing all
over the place. Look at me. I'm Ari. Oh,
a charm. Game's ready. Shall we uh talk
about Riftbound instead of me? I'm stuck
now. I'm not stuck in the voice. Sammy,
please. I need
>> I need to break out of it. Or we go down
into the
>> Anyway, game's ready. Here we are. Lee.
So,
>> power of Aurelia. It's very individual
unit focused. It's
>> pseudo voltron is what I what I'll call
it where you are relying Oh, we're going
to talk about le first.
>> Let's chat le first. Let's let's pivot.
Okay. Speaking of charm
>> and all of those wonderful spells that
we were just talking about in our
luscious voice for Ahri, we're actually
using Lein instead. And Le's whole thing
is again making units buff and we love
that. I love playing set in set one and
this can have a little bit of that kind
of in the mix as well. This one not so
much. Going with a much more purely sim
build. Not a lot of units but a lot of
buffing, a lot of thoning, not so fast.
Bringing your own kind of stance into
play and saying whatever you do, I've
got something bigger. I've got something
better. I don't need lots of units to
achieve that. I just need to make the
ones I've got meaningful.
>> Yeah. And achieving the card draw as
well through Celicorn Herder and Show of
Strength, which allows you just a little
bit extra card draw, which sometimes you
can struggle for on these uh sort of low
unit builds like the Lein. It already a
deck that we have seen many times uh or
will see many times throughout this
tournament already. the addition of
Siren relatively new I'd say in the last
couple of months into this deck in terms
of uh being able to choose the unit
moving them around from a battlefield to
your base. It also gives you a trigger
on your blade dancer and on your fervent
for the uh when you choose ready me and
then you can pay power as well to get
the readies from the blade dancer.
>> But as I alluded to earlier, we've got a
really similar build here in both decks.
We've got we've got very similar green
utilization with our Stellicorn, Herders
for the Card, Draw, Defy, Charm, and
those are the cards that played at the
right times against one another are
going to be what brings our champion
into the limelight.
>> Yeah, I think the the major differences
are we're kind of looking at, you know,
the purple package really does help
Aurelia in these sorts of moments. The
ability to get the tide turners out, you
can play audaciouses as well. Defiant
Dance just probably the best signature
spell in the game. I mean, Repost is up
there as well, but really powerful.
Alongside that, you can look at things
like stack deck for that extra card
draw. On the side of Lein, orange does
give you a little bit of strength like
show of strength does allow you that
card draw as well, but it is very buff
reliant. So, you can see both these
players want to be choosing units at
battlefields. Double Dreaming Tree is
where we are going to kick things off.
And it's a really important utilization
in this matchup. It kind of makes game
one important now because you know
you're not going to have access to
Dreaming Tree either of the other two
games. So picking your battlefield and
choosing the right one for the right
game is imperative. And I think this
actually puts much more pressure on game
one than either of these players
particularly want. Starting out with a
lonely Porro, of course, he's going to
get buff. So that's our first buff in
play for Le who absolutely wants to make
sure that we're getting those buff
tokens all across the board. I mean
buffs like this are actually really
helpful when you think of trading
patterns right if the Aurelia can be
playing a Stellon Herder that comes out
at three might and you're paying four
energy to equal the three energy cost of
a lonely poro that now matches you in
terms of might. So lonely obviously
wants to be dying alone but if you can
manage to get a trade in on something
like the Stellon herder actually allows
you just that little bit of advantage
and le in these sorts of spaces. It does
look like we had maybe a slight judge
call uh as
after the Lonely Po came down and got
buffed. Seems like our radio player
maybe has a slight concern on exactly
what is happening there. So, we'll find
out exactly what happened there, but I I
think
>> it's a little bit like the Draven mirror
where you really need to think about
where you're utilizing your resources.
You have to be so cognizant of if I do
this, these are the compounding domino
effects from this point. It's the
consequences of my actions. Yeah. If I
start something,
>> is it gonna come back at me or am I
gonna get away with it?
>> Yeah. Well, I don't like thinking about
the consequences of my action most of
the time, Amy. I try to avoid them
whenever I can. But for now, the
consequences of that first turn is that
uh Le has that lonely power. Sneaky deck
hand out. Something you do see often on
turn two for these Aurelia players or
turn one if you're playing second.
Sneaky deck hand onto the dreaming tree
will get you a draw. Still all chaos on
the side of the Aurelia, but thankfully
actually not too much power usage in
terms of her buffs. You're looking at
discipline does cost two, but on guard
is only one. So if you want to on guard
just for the dreaming tree trigger, you
can get that draw with that chaos ring.
>> Very worthwhile kind of first point
there, just kind of getting in there
because again, both of these decks rely
on trying to use those combat tricks
against one another to be able to take
the battlefield. We still have the other
dreaming tree, so Porro, not being quite
so lonely, could hop over into there to
maybe find some friends. But at the
moment, it just kind of is a clear game.
Or we can go and try and start dealing
with um Mugari's
sneaky Dehan. But again, there's one
standing over on their side, so it can
be a bit risky. We're just going for the
porro into the open Dreaming Tree for
that first one as well. And then ooh a
spicy pick going in with a Sona straight
in there with the lonely parro. Not so
lonely no more.
>> That is a bit of a surprise. Don't
usually see Sona in these lease index.
But what it does allow you to do is have
those spell battles when it's not your
turn. Right. Aellia are very reliant on
I put my Aia in, I'm choosing her, I'm
readying her. I'm, you know, discip
discipline. Yeah, discipline and um
>> on guard and things like this to get all
of those spells out. But if you can be
fighting against that with your sona
readying for runes, it puts you in a
really solid spot. I like this tech.
>> I really enjoy that it was played at
this stage of the game as well
specifically when we're really low on
runes. It's really towards the beginning
of the game and you're having to rely on
those for spending and spell casting uh
during your opponent's turn, which is
absolutely fantastic. We've moved on,
gone ahead and of course scored the
extra point for Yogurichi there. And
we're back onto Power Spike's turd.
We're ramping really fast at this stage.
We've got a lonely parro and Sona at the
Dreaming Tree, both with buffs. So,
we're in a great position here. Really
strong already units on the board. And
not much yet from Yogi to kind of show
that there's anything that's going to to
kind of weaken that stronghold right
now.
>> And because you have the Sona, you can
do things like this. Tapping out to play
the Le to get that centered on the
battlefield knowing you immediately get
four runes back. Like Le is now out. All
the other buff friendly units at that
battlefield are getting plus two.
>> That's huge.
>> It's massive. So you had eight power
previously. Plus four is 12 plus the le
itself is six. That is 18 power at that
one battlefield with the le coming out.
Really good stuff here from power spike
early on.
Don't think he activated his legend to
get the lein buff out but deciding
against leaving that uh lease in with a
buff. Maybe wanted Oh no. because he
tapped out for it so he couldn't then
use the legend. I was confused because
he had four runes on tap.
>> No, but those were the end of the turn
effect from Sona saying the symphony
never ends. She's bringing the runes
back into play and it looks like
>> the flavor text on Sona. Nice.
>> I am. I know, right? We're learning them
that then if we get quizzed later, we
might remember some.
>> True.
>> Uh so what we got in hand? We got
>> Okay, we got a Thonk.
>> A Thonk is I like a good sunlight
guardian is nice as well. Leona,
>> I think it was a Lucian rel.
>> They're going to chuck that sunlet
guardian out does have tank and shield.
We'll buff it as well with the legend.
So, it does feel like power spike is
very much investing into the I will
control this one battlefield. I'll try
and get ahead on that and then see where
we go from there. At some point, we'll
need to deal with the fact there's
another another dreaming tree that is
being controlled by that Stellacicorn
Herder. And here comes the Lucian.
Interestingly, deciding to buff at the
Sunlight Guardian instead of the Lucian
did have the option to go for either.
>> Yeah, Lucian's nice, but it also does
like he has that first conquer each
turn. He can ready, so he's a bit
flexibility later anyway. And we can
buff things later on. So, I think they
were just trying to get that stronghold
on the Dreaming Tree with many, many
units. Lonely Porro, not so anymore. uh
with many friends who are quite strong
and I think you know when we maybe get
something like aas in later as well it's
just going to even further amplify the
strength of that board power and just
taking a kind of slow approach to saying
I'm just going to leave these guys here
I'm going to get a point every turn
minimum and Yogi now has the
>> struggle of coming up back against that
but there are a lot of units flooding
the base now we've got more Stellicorn
herders which are going to be great for
card draw. So that really does influence
the pace of play.
>> Yeah, puts the sneaky deck and back onto
the dream and creep already held there
this turn. So won't get another point
for that. But Stellorn Herder is so good
when it's uncontested when you don't
have things like a hidden blade, co the
weak, anything to kill those off because
you are drawing so many cards. They can
move into the dreaming tree, draw two
cards. Next turn they move out of the
dreaming tree, draw two cards, and
you're just cycling through your deck
incredibly quickly. We already see the
stack deck coming out. This is what
purple does so well. This is what chaos
does so well and Yogurichi is really
using it effectively obviously with the
calm Stellon herd is uh doing an
incredible job so far. Now the Lucian is
sitting at three might. We have a sneaky
deck hand there as well. And this is
where I feel like we'll get into a
little bit of a war uh as we have the
pass of focus. Sugarish is going to
discipline to get the plus two dreamy
tree trigger and the discipline for the
draw with a discipline of our own
allowing power spike to get a double
draw as well puts the illusion up to
five.
>> This is honestly kind of what I was
expecting from this is that they would
just do exactly this where they both got
enough runes to be able to play these.
Oh, but something a bit more unique
there.
>> Yeah, going in with the defiant dance.
Incredible card overall here. just going
to buff up the sneaky deck hand and
reduce down that Lucian a little bit. So
it will be five into less than five two
and then the discipline will resolve and
we have the draws coming out from the
dreaming tree. It was a reaction war
overall. So now the minus two from the
defined dance is taken off by the plus
two from the discipline leaving Lucian
still at three and I believe sneaker
deck hand goes all the way up to plus
four. So it's six in total
>> together. Yep. So we've still got the
upper hand there. But are they going to
react even further? Because that's the
beautiful thing about this. And we are
going in again with another discipline.
Another plus two and a draw one.
>> And there we are. So but you need
something else here for power spike.
You're still sitting at five into six.
You want another buff. Okay. Quick draw
out that Sterex gauge that we saw
earlier on.
>> Because of the quick draw, you can play
it as a reaction. It immediately binds.
Well, binds can be equipped to this
Lucian that will put him over the top
with that plus three might.
>> Beautiful weapons master coming into
play. I think the first time we've seen
it personally.
>> What is this? This is true control magic
from these two players. Fight or flight
at the end to knock the Lucian back
after so much was invested. Not so fast,
my friend. Not so fast. Counters a spell
that targets a gear or a unit you
control. Huge investment by Power Spike,
but remember he has this Sona. He's
going to untap four runes at the end of
the turn. Can move that Lucian back out
of the com out of the dreaming tree if
he wants. And so now he has the option
of do I stick to just controlling one.
I've overtaken Yogi on points.
>> Oh, we're hiding a card. We're adding
insult to injury going, you know what,
this dreaming tree, it could be bigger.
I'm going to put a hidden card there as
well that can be activated later just
for fun. But you're right. I love this.
sona choice of card in this deck. But I
also love that pacing that it was played
at right at the beginning of the game
just to give him that advantage. Always
being able to react back to Yogurichi's
kind of really heavy combat tricks.
>> Yeah. And this is how you have to play
into Aurelia. If you're going to try and
match them like this, you need to have
that extra card. You need to be that one
step ahead. Stay staying on that
southern dreaming tree. I'll call it the
bottom dreaming tree is an interesting
choice cuz you are ahead in terms of
points. You're at 5 to four. You could
just look for the hold here. Looking for
a double hold knowing that you have
those four extra runes available from
the Sona harmonious trigger
>> in a really really advantageous position
here
>> for power spike. really impressed by how
they've used the
not only effect of Lein but also
managing to sequence this really
beautifully to make sure that they have
everything in their core. But twoorn
hoarders all of this.
>> Yeah. So I I have realized now the
reason you leave on is if the Celicorn
hoarders move in herders herders move in
then you don't want to give them a free
conquer, right? So you have to play the
flash to bring them back as Yagarichi
drew double charm off the top off the
move. I didn't see what the second two
cards were, but now with the flash being
used, you get another two cards from
those Delicorn Herders, but Power Spike
still holds onto the battlefield and you
only have one unit that is ready this
turn. You only have your Aurelia
Fervent.
>> It's just not enough. And that's the
thing, when these kind of decks that
want to hold their point on the
battlefield manage to do that with such
strength like power spike is, it could
be really hard for Yogarici to come back
even through drawing loads of cards.
They have drawn so many cards this turn.
I'm sure the mathematicians in chat will
be able to tell me exactly how many
cards they've drawn this. Is it five
extra? That's
>> four extra in the one for the turn. Two
and two and five so far. Yeah, five.
>> That's huge. That's a lot of cards in
this game. Remember, we've got smaller
deck sizes than a lot of other games.
And actually, it's can be really hard to
cycle through those sometimes. Of
course, really taking a moment to think
here because you're right, one unit's
just not enough. And we can't move the
Celicorn. Oh, fight or flight. Okay.
Trying to push back to try and not allow
the
>> the extra point. The extra point and
it's successful. I don't think you mind
too much though cuz you go to six and
then it's 78.
Y
>> pays for the fight or flight. Uh we do
have to remember with blade dancer if
you play an exhausted unit and then you
choose it you can ready it with the
blade dancer pay a power for that. So
you could have a pseudo accelerated
extra unit out here. But you look at the
size of that hand and you look at the
energy costs on the top left corner of
the cards whenever we see them from
Yoguchi. They all look relatively cheap
to me. I'm not seeing another Aelia
Fervent sitting there. I'm not seeing an
an easy way to get a lot of might out
onto the battlefield.
>> And using up your resources, the cheaper
ones that are great for pushing things
back and having those those combat
tricks, using them now to not a great
effect is only weakening your play for
later. We need those bigger units at
this point in the game to be able to
stand up.
>> But riding the wind. Okay,
>> so wants the extra move from the
Stellicorn Herder can choose it
>> and he's going to Yeah, use the ready
from the ride the wind as well. So
there's the move. There's the draw.
There's a point
>> taking us up to five. Bring it back for
another draw. That was a Defiant Dance.
So we have
>> we have two charms and a Defiant Dance
at least in hand.
Can't quite see what the rest of the
cards are. Ireelia is going to go in on
her lonesome
>> and a guardian angel to be equipped.
Okay, so guardian angel is a za's
equipment in essence. Ifia would die
instead, we recall her after healing and
exhausting her and she just goes back to
base,
>> which is great. We're trying to say,
okay, power spike, I know that you
you're going to ultimately need both
battlefields. Now, I'm playing protect
the princess. We're going to make sure
that Ireelia has as much as they can in
their kind of armory to make sure that
we can keep this base under wraps. They
just can't give it over to Power Spike
now. Now they've got it. They got to
hold it.
>> I love protect the princess by the way.
That's great cuz I automatically goes to
president. But yeah, protect the
princess for really nice overall. Three
runes still available for Yogarici. The
problem is Power Spike is going to ready
up with eight in total. Four more for
Mahmonious. Has a hidden card at that
top battlefield as well. That top
dreaming tree. Yogichi taking their time
right now. Just you know got a
pontificate sometimes. We'll pass the
turn. See all the readies coming out
from Power Spike. It's going to move to
six with the hold on that top dreaming
tree and then we will see what they
decide to do with this Lucian. Yeah,
we're we're in a
>> telecon of their own, I believe, off the
top.
>> Not bad. We can get some card draw.
>> It was a charm. It was a charm.
>> Oh, it was actually huge.
>> Yeah, that is actually quite large. You
can kind of force your opponent's uh
Aurelia into a sticky situation. But
first off, I can't quite see what that
card is.
>> Is that a Lee?
>> Ah, the art is confusing.
>> It's a bit out of my view.
>> I'll I'll have a quick mossy on the
internet and you can uh
>> No problem at all. We'll have a little
lookie. But that is what shiny cardboard
does sometimes. We are taking the lein
in now from our champion area. So we're
going in. Oh, was that the Lucian?
Actually, that was the Lucian that went
in. So
>> yeah, there's the Lucian, but there's
also the really shiny.
>> Yes,
>> I think it might be Leet Aesic.
>> Yes.
>> Oh, no. That's No, it's not.
>> It could be set brawler. Actually, set
brawler makes a lot of sense. Set
brawler makes a lot of No, but it's six
and six.
>> Oh, it is six. Yeah. Is it the altar
Lee? Um, is the Altar Lee then?
>> Yes, must be. And that's buffed as well.
So that's fantastic.
>> Lee centered. So that's Yeah.
>> The whole battlefield is terrifying.
>> Yeah. So that all the buffed units at
this battlefield get plus four. Yep.
>> Alongside the buff.
>> That is I mean you're just looking for
the hold. Double hold is what you're
playing for now. Power
>> spike 100%. You want a double hold and
then you just want to take that other
Dreaming Tree and that's it. That's
game. And that's why Yogi needs to start
>> pummeling units.
Dreaming to make sure that they do
everything in their power to not allow
power spike to get over there because
this is going to be the troublesome
thing. Now, how is power spike going to
take that dreaming tree if all of their
units currently are over at the upper
tree? Yes. Dreaming A, DreamC, south and
north, however you want to call them.
Um, it's even then, even if all their
units aren't there, how do you take this
battlefield?
>> Yeah, you don't. It's It's 4 10 15
uh plus another ah it's it's like 30
power. I'm sorry I can't do
>> math. It's a lot more power. Yes. Much
more than one.
>> Much more than one. And honestly,
respect to it cuz that is a horrifying
>> overload of buffs and units that are
working together. Again, the Sona early
was absolutely beautiful.
Oh, there we go. Is that the Darius?
>> Yeah, it's it's the Draven. Uh,
>> it's the Draven art.
>> Draven.
>> I meant Draven.
>> Oh, audacious. Isn't this audacious?
Yeah. When you win a combat and uh Yeah.
>> Yes. You get to score a point.
>> Yeah.
I believe at least the alternate arts
are definitely confusing to me. We're
going to have the uh the charm come
across
and uh yeah, it is it's draven audacious
ultimate art. Yeah, I'm going to have
the charm come across. It will target
the lonely porro which uh
>> Oh no,
>> I mean but like
>> a lonely poo dies. He can trade as well
with his three might in the silicon
herded something we talked about six
points ago. That ability to trade. We'll
get a draw out. It's a fivey four power
spike. It's just trying to like chip
away at some of the strengths that Power
Spike has at this top battlefield, but
the power there is still absolutely
ginormous.
>> It really is. We're going up to seven
there.
Just moments away from winning. We need
eight to win, but we mo must control
that other battlefield as well. And it's
it's looking a bit tough at this point.
We've got what 6 10 13 and then plus the
gear as well. So 15 on the southern
dreaming tree, but we got a defy
straight off the bat there.
>> As far as I can work out, there is 38
power at the top dreaming tree.
>> That's a lot.
>> Yeah. Oh, so we had an emperor's divide
to move a couple of friendly units back
to a battlefield uh to to base from a
battlefield. And then we had a defy on
the defy.
>> So it was Emperor's Divide, Defy, Defy,
Defy,
>> Defy, Defy, Defy, Fifi, Fam, I smell the
blood of an Aelia player.
>> Literally, no. No, no,
>> I would prefer if you did not.
>> Uh, and then another Emperor's Divide
being shown.
>> I don't know if this is just being
played after the fact, after that Defy
War.
>> Not often you you see a full three Defy
>> Not at all. Not all in hand at the same
time, but both players have had quite
frivolous card draw, which has been
great to see because you get to see how
these decks interact in a very true way.
Neither of them have what we call
bricked where they don't really get what
they need. Actually, both decks have
kind of got the card draw they were
expecting. It's just Yugurichi has
definitely been on the back foot, but
that definitely does not mean they're
not still in this. Six points still
great place to be. Yes, that battlefield
is looking quite scary, but they've got
power tricks of their own. They're all
quite cheap. There are definitely ways
where this comes out in his favor.
>> Yeah, there's probably a few lines. It
is a struggle when you look at just how
overwhelming the presence is on that top
dreaming tree, though. It's uh for Yogi,
they've drawn a ton of cards with the
Steelorn Herders, which have been
basically untouched, which is usually
not a position you want to be in at all
playing into Aelia. You want to get rid
of those teleorns as soon as you can
because they do just get like
infantessimal, not infantessimal,
infinite card advantage, exponential is
the word I was looking for. As uh it's
back to us as there's a little bit of a
judge ruling at the table. looked like
something to do with the the sequence of
defies and the uh the emperor's divides,
but obviously
>> there was a lot that went on very
quickly as we know, but that's kind of
the point of these decks. They're spell
slinging. They're going no no and that's
kind of exactly what it is that tussle
between the two and so it can it can
very easily happen. Two emperors divide
there going to the discar pass so I
assume both have concluded now and
looking like all of that is coming.
>> It's a scoop from Yuruchi. Okay, with
the Empress survive, they go into the
trash, but believe it is just a victory
for our Lein player. Uh the Draven
Odacious at the end, a final hail Mary
for Yogi. Wasn't quite able to bring it
around. Three Axons and three unyielding
spirits in the sideboard here for power
spike. Uh unyielding spirit really good
into Kaiser decks. Really allows you to
avoid a bunch of the the spell damage.
Axan really good into like illusion
decks. anyone that really is trying to
voltron with those equipments or decks
as well. It works well. But don't say
that I told you that and don't play a
when I'm playing or thank you very much.
>> Please. Yes, please. And thank you. Uh
but we saw both of these decks come
through. Of course, in yoga sideboard,
we might be trying to utilize a bit more
of those um a few more of those comeback
mechanics, the the no, I told you so.
Maybe another rebuke, maybe another not
so fast, maybe a gust to really try and
prevent that overwhelming position in
the one dreaming tree that we saw and
you can kind of try and push back on
your opponent a little bit more. So, I
like that idea as well. It's going to be
a tough sideboard to figure out.
>> I I agree. I think that the concern I
have with Gust is even a lonely pro gets
to three and everything apart from the
Lonely Po is bigger than Gustable,
right? I think Reuke definitely comes
in. Uh, Adaptatron obviously you don't
really care about, right? It's although
maybe for a Sterax, but Sterax is being
used much more as a reaction buff rather
than something that you're going to be
able to
>> allow the reaction then go in and
conquer. I I wonder if we'll see a
similar style from both the players sort
of accepting one battlefield isn't mine
to start with. I'll just go to this one.
You go to this one. We'll be moving away
from those dreaming trees. Uh maybe a
monastery of her Herado or something for
our Le player if you're looking for that
extra draw. Uh, and we'll see where they
both decide to go.
>> It's tough and I think a very
understated
>> skill set that you need to have in
Riftbound is selecting the correct
battlefield at the correct time. And
double dreaming tree at the beginning
there meant that they were both going to
be able to utilize those really heavily
and they both want that battlefield. But
now actually it can get a little sticky.
But it looks like they've gone with
sunken temple and of course the
Monastery of Hana. And that is
interesting. I I believe and I know on
our overlay it says Sunken Tempo was
played by Power Spike. It doesn't make
much sense for Yogichi to have played a
Monastery of Herana. So I'm going to say
Power Spike probably played the
Monastery of Herana.
>> It would make sense
>> because they are the ones that want to
spend the buffs to draw the cards. We
see an early siren out from Yogici.
Really good with the Aurelia. The
ability to choose it for one, move it
back to your base, then ready it as well
uh with your Blade Dancer gives you a
bunch of power. Selicon Herder coming
out on turn two for them. That was the
Lucian early for Power Spike on their
turn one.
>> And we saw how great that Lucian played
out in game one. So I have no doubts
that it's going to pull its weight in
game two as well here. But of course
that Stellacicorn her earlier as well is
really nice having that early card draw
could just push Yuri into the power spot
there. Going to go for the buff on
Lucian and then moving in spending the
buff to draw a card. Here we go.
>> Yep. This is what you want to do on
these lease index is just get as much
card draw as you can. It's one of the
reasons that double dreaming tree was
actually really nice for power spike in
turn one because in game one because you
could kind of leave yogici to their own
devices knowing that you'd still be
drawing a bunch of cards. You see the
ston herder for a similar thing not
trying to give theelia any combat just
bring it back to base with the Lucian
and then we expect you know yogic is
going to get the Celicorn herder out get
themselves a card immediately. It's just
getting as much information about your
deck as possible is so valuable and
about what you have at the top.
>> They're playing completely different
decks but doing the same thing. They're
doing the same thing which brought the
brought the Stellicorn back to base
keeping it safe being like no I don't
want to dispatch this yet and I want
more movement out of it so that I can
draw more cards. And both players are
utilizing that fact incredibly well
right now. Both drawing as many comps
they can to give themselves that
advantage. Yeah, it's uh it's a really
fun mind game overall. At at the moment,
Power Spike has a small advantage
because of Lucian's ability. When they
conquer, you then get to ready them
immediately and then bring them back. I
wonder if they're going to try and put
the Stellicorn into one of these
battlefields cuz the move is really
nice. Yes,
>> but then you need to be able to get back
out otherwise you are going to lose your
card advantage tool and Yogichi will
keep theirs in response. So, we'll see
if this Stellon Herder goes out. It is
also the question of whether you want to
buff it with the lease in first.
>> Kind of what I was thinking. I was
thinking, do we want to buff first to
get the card draw? I think it's really
imperative at the beginning of this
matchup that we do draw as many cards as
possible. So, we go for the buff, then
go in for the conquer, draw a card here,
then spend the buff to draw another
card. And just ramping off that alone, I
think is really powerful. You're
basically doubling up the Stellicorn
Herders ability by using Lein's natural
prowess.
>> Mhm. And there is the argument that you
leave the Celicon Herder with the buff
to be at four might. So it outmatches
the opposing Stellon Herder. But because
of the Aurelia when you ready me you get
plus one. The Aurelia can just go in at
five might anyway. Uh and it would be
out to Selicon Herder. Sona once again
though coming out from Power Spike. A
huge bit of tech that has worked so well
for them so far this series.
>> Honestly, early Sona is an absolute
godsend.
and it showed how it
gone in with that to make sure that it
kind of has backup.
>> Mhm.
>> It gives you that little bit of extra
might. Also just allows you to have all
of those runes ready. Again, the uh the
counter wars, the buff wars, I guess, so
vital in this matchup. So, if you're
Yogarichi, you're going to put your GA
down. You probably choose your Aurelia
with this. and give it plus well one a
plus one for being chosen and then plus
one for the guardian angel which sits
underneath it. It's technically part of
the card text now. Depends how they want
to represent it in terms of the uh
>> counters
>> the counters on it. I like representing
the each thing individually. So it's
been buffed twice therefore it has two
counters on it. It's Miders four and it
has the guardian angel which shows
separately.
>> You can add it all up. It's not it's
little maths. It's fine. But it's a, you
know, it's a big enough unit to be
taking both of these out. So, of course,
we then see the Emperor's Divide.
>> Yeah, we're going to move both of those
back to the battlefield and get a card
draw from the Celicorn Herder.
>> Oh, we love that as a little Brucey
bonus. That is
>> And then Stellon Herder going into the
other side. I feel like Celicorn Herder
has lost all meaning, Amy.
>> I don't know the word. You know, when
words start to sound funny cuz you've
said it too much. I've said Stellorn
Herder too much and then I said it wrong
earlier and that's just
>> heard her. I didn't even listen. So,
>> it's so good. It's such a good card, but
it's utilized in these decks
>> like so very much because of its power.
Look at their hands. It doesn't look
like a riftbound game. You can't tell me
it does because there's so many cards in
their hand, but they have such low costs
that this becomes this
>> battle of wits.
>> Yeah, totally agree with you. I think
this is going to be a charm onto the
Sona met with a Defy. No real surprises
there. Another Defy. Power Spike said,
"Ah, I just don't have another Defy.
What am I going to do in this moment?"
The Sona is going to be pulled up into
that battle with Aelia. Seven might
four,
>> but we have three runes available. So,
we could
>> Is there more? Can we save
incremental last game? I think that
she's important to have around.
>> How is it that we have played a whole
game with body runes and we haven't
talked about punch first?
>> We haven't exists and it's in hand.
>> We could punch. We could pack a big one.
>> We have double discipline punch. Yeah,
it's uh there we go. First punch of the
series
>> onto that Sona. Bumps her up to nine.
Playing into seven right now.
>> Met with a discipline.
>> Oh my goodness gracious. This is just
going back and forth forever. Another
discipline. We're really low on runes
for Power Spike now. We do have two
standing.
>> So discipline pumps us up to 10 in total
into the nine. We do have a counter
discipline for Power Spike. Low on runes
for Yogurichi as well.
>> Y
>> there we have our counter discipline.
>> The foiling on those disciplines looks
so good under these lights, by the way.
>> It really does. They're really snazzy.
>> It makes me think they're in a um a
nightclub. The neon lights behind them.
>> It does. They look a little less
fearsome. A little like they're going
down the club.
>> Yeah.
>> What? What?
>> Defy.
>> Oh no. Do I have to take it back now?
>> You got to go backwards. Sorry, but
we're making some there are there are
big decisions to be made here. Who's
going to take this? Oh my goodness. So,
we've used of course the ability of our
equipment there just to bring Aurelia
back to the base instead.
>> Yeah, Guardian Angel doing a huge amount
of work in that moment, but it's a big
win for Power Spike. Holds onto the
Monastery of Horana. Can now look to
buff the Stellacicorn, move it in, get a
double card draw. Is down to only five
runes. Punch first. incredibly costly
having to pay those two body powers. But
from this moment, Power Spike now in
really strong position. The buffs on the
Sona have expired and yes, Power Spike
will very kindly take those off for us.
But sitting at five, can move to six
this turn and then is just a double hold
or a double conqueror away getting to
eight.
>> This is the turning point of the game.
That Sona surviving.
>> Oh, huge. Yeah,
>> huge. She alone on that battlefield is
making this for power spike. the low
rune kind of leftovers from that turn
matter not when she can bring them back.
And I think that's what you've got to
take into consideration when you're
using these. It's like but then if I
don't have Sona I won't have access to
these at the end of my turn. So actually
I think it's a net profit if you think
about it that way with the amount of
runes that you get to spend each turn
and then have them back at the end of
the turn ready for those spell slinging
combats.
>> Yeah, agreed. Agreed. Interesting choice
here by Power Spike. Is going to retreat
everything to base. buffed up the
sunlight guardian is then going to look
for a double conquer.
>> I love that
>> on the next turn. Yeah, I it's one of
those things where
>> often you'll see newer players be like,
"Oh, I can just hold. I'll just go for
the hold. I have enough combat tricks. I
can try and work my way through it."
Just just get out. You are so far away
from losing. Yogichi needs three turns
to get there.
>> Just wait.
>> There's no special rush. Get five extra
points for Yogurichi. So he's going to
go in with the Stellicorn Herder and
with the Urelia draws a card, gets two
points. Where are we going from here?
Has the siren if he wants to move that
Stellorn back to base.
>> I don't know if it's worth it. I think
you've got to put at least something in
there. We got a charm. Okay,
>> where where would you go with the charm?
Is it Sona again? Feels like Sona is
less important.
>> I don't think so. Sona's there now and
you're not going to have enough time to
deal with it, but admittedly it is one
of the better units to take out. It's
got the higher natural strength without
buffs, right? So, it is the Sona moving
in and yeah, just allowing that to go
now. We don't need it as much right now,
right? We just need to take both of
these battlefields and win. Yogi is
going to try and squeeze Power Spike's
resources this turn to try and make that
much more difficult.
>> Yeah, I think if you're trying to defend
the Sona there, you're really only
looking at an ong guard, which you I
can't remember Power Spike playing, or a
punch first. And if you're playing a
punch first, that's two more runes that
you're recycling. that gives you less
resources for the next turn. You're
aiming to win next turn. You don't want
to be using, as you say, all of your
resources now protecting a unit that
really has done her duty, has done her
job.
>> It's uh I Sona has been speaking only to
Power Spike. It seems first time I've
seen this addition into a lease in deck
and it's kind of she's she's mute in
League of Legends and one of her lines
is only you can hear me summoner. So
perhaps Power Spike had a harmonious
voice before the before the tournament
be like, "Oh, I'll just put a Sona in
here.
>> This is the play." And I think this is
the
>> this is what we expect from these high
level players, right? We're expect we're
we're 3 going in on this. And
>> you've got to expect this round four to
be showing the best of the best. And an
imperative part of Lein is being able to
constantly put the pressure on your
opponent during their turn. And Sona
feels so good for that. It surprises me
that I didn't think of it. Now I feel
like I've been stupified.
>> I don't think we can blame ourselves
here. We were prepping 50 decks. You
know, we had to prep all of the decks
and I know there aren't 50. Well, there
probably are.
>> There probably are.
>> Ready was telling me that we should add
Caitlyn into Aelia lists, and I'm
counting that as a whole separate deck.
So, let's do it.
>> It's not It doesn't make us feel better.
At least
>> it does not work. Ready? If you're
watching at home, probably still are. It
doesn't work, mate. It's not it's not as
good as these decks.
>> It's not worth it. But this is this is
spice that I like to see. I love to see
the innovation that everyone's bringing.
Leon is definitely an underdog of the
competition. And I think, you know, uh
Power Spike really could be going for
that best of or even further with such
an interesting build.
>> I widely regarded as for fun tier like a
best of at best, right? The way of
seeing the meta and understanding that
you can get to this position. Obviously
incredible stuff from Power Spike. Don't
know what what their matchups have been
before this. So it could be that they've
only played into advantageous matchups,
but into Aurelia is having a great time
overall. Saw them counting out some of
their mana uh some of their energy.
Thinking about it is a four three team
move into the sunken temple.
>> Okay,
>> he's going to get the Celicon her
trigger. Might just look for the hold is
still far enough ahead to do so. The
Lucian were ready after the conquer.
They have a switch of focus right now as
I believe it's Yogarici who is taking
their time thinking about if they want
to re react to this advance to the
showdown at all.
>> This is the pinnacle moment. If Yogari
doesn't make the right decisions here,
the game could be over. But we're going
to allow that.
>> The card draw is not defined in this
instance. Uh to use a term that doesn't
work in game but does work in real life.
up to the seven and now we just need to
take that other battlefield. Lucian of
course readies but
>> still I'm not quite seeing a way to take
that battlefield from Ireelia unless
they're missing something.
>> I think the the concept now is stick
here. Don't use your runes. Uh we have I
saw perhaps an Emperor's Divide in hand,
a lonely po which obviously doesn't do
too much. A thonk a discipline. Is there
a punch first? Cuz we have enough bodies
for two punch first which would be huge.
I don't I didn't personally see one, but
it doesn't mean it's not there. No.
>> Sterax.
>> Okay. So, we have in terms of reactions,
we have discipline. Thonk or in terms of
interactions on the opposing turn, not
all of these are reactions. So, we have
thwon, we have discipline, and we have a
sterox.
>> Going to have a look at the discar pile.
Really important as well.
>> Checking what your opponent has gone
through could be really imperative to
your decision-m going in for of course.
Yes, we can go ahead and just make that
just make that battlefield even stronger
with our lease in champion.
>> Gives us that plus two on the Sunlick
Guardian who does have shield as well.
Remember
>> hiding a card as well
holding knowing that they can't take
that Aurelia down yet. Doing what we saw
in game one, right? We're going okay
well I can't take the win right now. I
know I can't take the win right now. So
instead, I'm going to make it so you
can't take the win, my friend.
But out of energy, out of runes, no sona
to riverfight.
That's a word that is very easy to trip
to trip over.
>> That was that was actually really
impressive that you went for that. I
would I would skirt around the word
personally.
>> Oh, I can do that as well. No sona to
revitalize our runes.
>> There we go. with her song of
perseverance, her arro of joy
>> has unfortunately left us with nothing
more this turn. And again, taking a look
at where your opponent has played, we
know from game one kind of what to
expect with those kind of defy battles.
U but actually we've used a lot of
resources on both sides already. We're
really coming towards the end of the
game. Going for a rebuke there
by the looks of things. Yeah.
>> What are we knocking out?
>> Honestly, I'm not sure.
>> I think it's the Leen.
>> Yeah. Oh, okay. Yep.
>> So,
>> we have the reaction. We have
>> the Emperor's Divide.
>> Emperor's Divide there. So, we can move
some friendly units back to base.
>> So,
the way that I would have the line I
think I would have gone for as Yogurichi
is you you bump the lease in cuz that
takes four power.
>> Yeah. uh a four might sorry away plus
the le's might the six and then you if
you're looking to go in for the combat
showdown that gives you the greatest
might gain right
>> emperor's divide I guess the question is
are you just looking for the highest
might there's an argument that Lucian at
this moment isn't actually
the one that you want to bring back
rebuke bring the le out take Stellinorn
her out and the sunlit guardian back and
then go for the showdown on your next
turn. Yogichi can only get to seven.
Can't win on this turn.
>> No. And that's the that's the struggle
right now for both players.
>> They are both trying to sit in this top
spot, but go actually no, I'm I'm not
going to let you take this battlefield.
It's mine. So,
>> having to take
>> Oh, it's any number on Emperor. In my
head, it was two. So, he just bounces.
>> Being able to bounce all of them back
>> actually kind of nice. You then have
flexibility when you're going into your
next combat next turn to potentially
actually get to that eight. So actually
I I don't dislike this being able to
bring everything back and then split it
between the two battlefields and take
hold.
>> A huge pivotal moment in the game,
right? Really well played by Power
Spike. Do you want to know why I think
Emperor's Divide is only two units?
>> Why?
>> Cuz I play it in my own deck.
>> Oh my goodness. Again,
>> I only ever have to use it on or and
Tiana. So there's only ever two units of
the battlefield.
>> Okay. So
>> any number of units. So, we were able to
bring it all back, which actually I
think has really worked in Power Spike's
favor. Yogarici fell into the trap.
>> Mhm. Yeah. Use used the runes for the
rebuke. Use the Rebuke as well, which
could have been so impactful on this
next turn.
>> Did need to try and find a way to
mitigate some of the power, some of the
might that was on that battlefield. But
it is going to be really tricky. You saw
moving the Celicorn Herder in trying to
get that extra card draw. as the siren
as well. If they want to move it out,
but it you're using an energy, you only
have five left. How many of those
resources do you need on what is likely
to be the final turn of the game where
power spike on this lein could be going
4 and 0? Turn is passed.
>> Here we go. The runes are being set. We
ready our units and here comes the
showdown of showdowns to see whether Lee
Sin can take a clean 40 sweep here in
Bologna. Round four of the regional
qualifier.
>> So we still have that Sterax.
I think we drew a Lucian.
>> Okay, nice one. We're going for the buff
on the Lucian.
>> Buff the Lucian.
>> In they go.
>> Go in. Look for the first
conquer which would give us a card draw
here. need to obviously conquer both
battlefields to take the win.
>> The runes kept up
>> by a lot of potential here.
>> So, Thonk, Lucian, Lein, Lonely Parro,
Sterax Gage.
>> There's not a lot of reactive. It's
>> the discipline and the sterox really
literally it, isn't it? And with such a
with such a big hand, you're kind of
like, oh, that's not as many as I would
like to have against Yogi knowing that
they can do the same. Yes,
yes, yes, yes. Okay,
>> okay, so we've
>> Defiant Dance, we didn't see the Defiant
Dance being played. Minus two on the
Sunlit Guardian, plus two on the
Stelicon her
>> discipline to buff that up again by
another couple.
>> Well, the Defiant Dance actually
targeted the Sunlick Guardian, it seems,
>> um for the next attack. Planning for the
next move here. Discipline onto the
Lucian will get us a draw. We'll buff
him up by two.
puts him to six in total. One more than
the Stellicorn. This conquer vital to
this turn for power spike. Likely to go
all in.
>> They got to go all in. They got to go
all the way. They've got to take this
from Yogarici. Yogichi is actually
limited on their units right now, which
is very pressing. So if Power Spike can
take this, they've got to go all in.
>> Yogurichi sitting on
>> not great options here. Double not so
fast in hand. a rebuke
uh a guardian angel which just can't be
played
and a stellarorn and a couple of others.
Maybe ride the winds can't quite tell
what we're looking at, but it's a lot of
don't target my stuff,
>> but not a lot of
>> not a lot of hey, I'll buff my stuff in
a combat.
>> And that's the problem here is that Le
definitely has the advantage in that
respect because buffing units is exactly
what Leon loves to do.
>> We get the sunken temple trigger here as
well.
Okay, I didn't quite catch what they
were in that draw, but again, just
flourishing the hand with so many
options.
>> Can we get to the other battlefield? Can
we take that just final step? We've got
the eight points, but we must have both
battlefields under control in order to
win.
>> Are we bringing the Lucian back? Are we
bringing the Lucian back? Currently
sitting at Yeah, it's seven points
because of the card draw from the
Conquer.
>> Yes.
>> Oh, beautiful. So, the Lucian gets ready
from the Conquer. Emperor's Divide to
bring just the Lucian back and then go
for the Conquer on the top. Power spike
on Lee Sin. Superlative play.
>> Lein centered and ready and set for the
win. Taking round four by storm. An
underdog, but no longer. I imagine
everyone will be respecting Le a little
bit more after that showing.
>> Yeah, truly truly
incredible stuff from Power Spike. I I
It's an F tier deck, guys. The Sona by
itself does not make it a tier, but it's
just
>> F stands for fantastic.
>> It's true. It's true. Fantastic stuff
all around from Power Strike. Obviously,
commiseration to Yavichi, but going down
to three and one, no shame in it at all.
Still has many ways to make it today,
too. Honestly, I'm so impressed with how
that went down. It was a matchup that
I'm not very well verssed in, but now I
feel like I know it very well thanks to
these two. I think I understand the two
and froze. And unfortunately, Leid does
just have that combat prowess, that
natural combat prowess on board that
just allows them to stabilize faster.
And that is really what kind of kept
Powerhouse in this game.
>> Yeah, Power Spike did an incredible job
all around. I know we have a second
series as well from the feature match
area 2 to watch. It'll be ready for us
in just a moment. But overall, I mean, I
I'm sure there's a lot of people at home
who are just happy to see an AIA player
win. Like, it's the same way when you
see a Draven player win, it's kind of
like, come on, guys. But I I really
think that
>> the addition of the Sona is inspired. I
really think that was
>> Yeah. superlative stuff all around.
>> We've seen so many innovations already
today, and I think that's my favorite so
far. I think that's got to be my top
spot. Like things I didn't have on my
Bologna bingo card. Um,
>> what what else is on the bingo card?
>> You don't have a bingo card?
>> I don't know.
>> I'll get you sorted out with one after
this round. Cool. Thank you.
>> But I think that's one of the things I
just wasn't expecting and I'm really
pleased to see it because those are the
deck building innovations. We think we
chatted a little bit yesterday actually
about how
>> is deck building your own deck really
important or is there a lot to be said
for ones that you copy from others?
There's no shade. Absolutely no shade at
all because I absolutely use a lot of
other creators lists as a base for mine.
But then sometimes there'll be cards and
I'm like, I'm not jamming with that. I
don't really get it. And that's probably
just me being silly. But like sometimes
I'll be like, that's not working for me.
I like this other card and I think
that's going to work better and I'll
just swap them out. And that tweak can
be enough to make Lein go 40.
>> Oh, 100% 100%. And pretty good play from
power play as well.
>> Oh yeah, very much so. I believe our
second round is ready. Our second
feature match. So, let's jump on into
it. I can't remember exactly who it was.
It was told to me a long time ago. Oh,
can we squint and see?
>> It's Volbear versus Civer.
>> Volibear versus Civer. Okay, Civer I
think a lot of people look at as a deck
that can definitely challenge at the
top, but has a few problems when it
comes to time. Both in terms of its own
management of time cuz there's a lot of
memorization of deck orders, but also in
terms of other players playing into it.
Volibear, big boys,
>> big guys. Big guys,
>> big guys.
>> Oh, they're the bare necessities.
Bringing everything and saying, "I'm
going to ramp hard, play some really
heavy units. Can you deal with them?"
And Civer, well, I think they can, but I
think it's going to be very, they've got
to be very cautious of their timings.
>> Yeah, totally agree. I think it is
understanding what is a big threat and
what isn't. Uh you've got in the volar
deck, you know, cad grins, vol obviously
volars, magma worms, kind of snap jaws,
dead bloom predators, ferris,
forrunners, minotaurs. There's a lot of
stuff that you have to really think
about. And we are going to jump onto I
was about to say summoners rift. That is
a uh a muscle memory moment there for me
as a caster. Going to jump onto
summoners rift for the first game of the
riftbound bologna. Now in the laning
phase, what we expect to see is these
players uh channeling a few runes,
awakening their runes, beginning and uh
also drawing cards.
>> And then from there, we'll see. Oh, with
an obelisk of power and a sigil of the
storm, we have pretty electric
battlefields.
>> Very, very true.
>> Who's going to deal better in the storm?
The battle mistress or the bear?
>> Well, that is the question. It seems
like game one did go towards the battle
of mistress c mercenary doing a lot of
work with this deck at least with the uh
kind of pseudo miracle version that we
have seen predominantly what you're
trying to do is cycle through your deck
as quickly as possible and then almost
memorize slash write down the exact
order of the cards that you are looking
for. I believe we saw a sabotage off the
top there and maybe an Ezreal. I didn't
quite see what the third card was, but
Jensen went out to an early lead in game
one. Volley on the other side is, you
know, you're catalysting. You're trying
to get to late game. You're mobilizing.
Can play those Auroras as well. And I
have to see if this list does include
them. Some lists don't these days. Some
some lists are just about I want to get
to high rune counts and then I want to
play big stuff.
>> Yeah. And I think that's what this is
going to be about realistically is who
can who can utilize that quickly. Uh the
nice thing about Civer is it does go a
little bit slower. You kind of set up
for the mid game during the early game
and develop the civer dig for those
sabotage which we managed to get already
which is great. Ezreal seals and then
you kind of start flying and that might
give Volibear time the time that it
needs to ramp these runes as quickly as
possible so they can get to those bigger
units. But a very typical Volibear t of
do some runes and not much else.
>> Yep. I will put my runes down and then I
will unfortunately not have a catalyst.
Catalus of Aons when you have that uh
>> obelisk of power is such a nice play on
turn one if you're going second is a
really strong position to be in but
unable to get there. Looks like we're
going to have the seal of discord
>> early seal from Jensen into tapping
three and going to play out our first
Ezreal of the game.
>> Wow, this is a phenomenal start. Really
pushing exactly what Civer wants to be
doing. We want the seals early. We want
to see the Ezreal. We want the card
draw. We want the seals to become those
like kind of infinite resources.
>> Absolutely phenomenal.
>> Yeah. And having the seal actually
allowing you to get out that Ezreal and
the seal cuz you were lacking in terms
of chaos power only had body runes
remaining.
You can see how important sorting your
hand is. Like organizing exactly what
you want in your hand at any time. With
the traveling merchant coming down after
you've just discarded one and drawn two
from the Ezreal on the hunt getting
discarded. Slightly surprising. Minur
Beckham was going to come out though.
Well, first of the big boys.
>> I think it was kind of all we could do.
Like otherwise Vol was just in
hibernation for a whole another turn
where you couldn't really play anything
cuz everything costs too much. So we
wanted to utilize channeling that extra
rune with our legend ability.
>> Getting the uh minor out as well. It is
nice into decks that like to avoid
combats where they can sorry Civ does
like to do that from time to time. You
know, you go in, you then manage to
fight a flight, get things retreated.
units can't move to base really stops a
lot of that from being able to happen.
Can't always be can when it comes to
riftbound.
>> But what's the next step? We've had a
really really strong civer kind of
guideline turn. Like if I could pick
what cards I played roughly in order
with Civer, this is kind of what it
might look like, especially against
Volibear. But now we're going in with a
sabotage. Beautifully timed. Knowing
that kind of we're not really getting
anywhere with playing these big units.
There must be some big brutal bits in
there. We're going to jot them down cuz
we can we can not take quick. We're good
with that. But you reveal their hand and
then choose a nonunit card from it. Now,
a lot of these are units. I think
they're all units, but we can jot them
down. We know what's coming and we can
prepare for that later.
>> Yeah, it it's one of those. Kadrian is
pretty nice. uh if you start to get a
few other units down, drawing you a card
for each mighty unit you have when you
play it,
>> but sabotage kind of sucks when you only
see units, right? I think hoping to see
an Aurora was really what you're hoping
for there% or even I mean if you had a
mobilizer, if you had a catalyst, you
would have played it by this point as
the body player. So, not the end of the
world for Gen 6 and knowing exactly what
your opponent has in hand is obviously
very helpful. We saw a scrap heap
discarded earlier on as well for that
extra draw.
Civ going to get exhausted to uh make
that gold token. Is that
>> has that happened on this turn? Why is
she still exhausted right now?
>> I think that was on this turn. Yeah,
because the golden
>> Oh, did we use the other gold token last
turn? I didn't see that getting used.
So, it's fine. We made one last turn as
well, I believe. But I must have just
missed where it was used and that is
entirely on meat. We have judges at the
table so we'll be making sure all of
these things are happening correctly
anyway.
>> Absolutely. But yeah, at the moment
we're just doing kind of pretty typical
civ things. We've got the Azreel out.
We've got our seal. We're pretty happy
with the traveling merchant moving over
there, taking the first point of the
game, of course. Yep. A natural uh kind
of progression here is now bringing out
our Civiver mercenary. Yeah, the ability
for Civ Mercenary when you're making so
many gold tokens at to
use that power and then have Civ gain
ganking get plus two just makes you so
much stronger overall and it gives you
kind of like that late game insurance
where six might and ganking can work
through a lot of things with the
Minotaur Beckner out though it becomes a
little trickier cuz you don't have as
much easy removal with the fight or
flights and then allowing Civ just to go
in and gank for the points. So, we'll
see how Gent is going to work their way
through the fact that this minur
beckoner currently exists. Something
like a challenge uh a punch first like
Arasa going down into one of those would
give you enough might to work your way
through the uh the minur.
>> Yeah, Elgato
Vodkas has uh got a lot of runes now, a
lot of power to go and we've got a lot
of big units in hand ready to go. So now
this is where volar shines, right? We
just have big guys. They go down.
They're aggressive. I'd say this is like
the highest natural powered deck of the
format. It's again not a deck that we
were expecting to see, but I'm not mad
about it. I'm enjoying seeing Voli Blair
doing great. I'm bringing down of course
our render thundersong for six and five
power of course and your opponents can't
play cards this turn now. So we can go
in a little bit more uncontested.
>> Yeah. I think it's one of those ones
where Brinher in a lot of decks is
defined by her ability text. Yes,
>> when you play me, opponents can't play
cards this turn. Super impactful
>> in this deck. I feel like that helps,
but she's also a five might creature.
>> And she just she looks like she should
be in a Volibear deck. And so I think
she should be in a Volibear deck. You
know,
>> she seems to fit the vibe. She's very
volar coded.
>> Yeah, she definitely is.
>> Have we passed the Volibear vibe check?
These questions we must ask.
>> 100%.
>> Another point over to Jensen for that
traveling merchant holding right now.
Now we're going to channel our runes and
we'll see exactly where we want to go.
Did see another catalyst or a first
catalyst in in Elgato's hand. Uh
importantly for them, even though they
have channeled so many runes, if you
can't channel two runes with uh the
catalyst, you do get a card draw out of
it. So it's not a dead card at that
point. You just, you know, you channel
at least up to two runes. And if you
can't do two, you you draw a card.
>> Ooh, a cold shot there.
>> I believe it's a Russ in hand. It's a
cool shot and a rasa. Oh, we got Yeah,
Russer as well, which kind of is not
great right now. You want that later.
You need that late game. We're not quite
there yet. But then, do you want to
Yeah. recycle it? I don't Oh, what got
chosen there? I didn't quite see.
>> I think it was the cord shot went into
hand.
>> Yeah, I think that would be my I think
that would be my cold shot, too. But I
uh it it feels bad putting Raza to the
bottom of the deck.
>> And you see Jensen there trying to move
the traveling merchant back and uh was
like, "Excuse me, Minur exists. You
can't move. You don't get your discard
draw. You don't get it.
>> No moving.
>> It It negates a lot of what Jensen wants
to do at this point. Another Ezra is
going to come down for the discard
double draw, which will start to fill up
our trash a little bit more. Currently
looking at five cards in there
>> by the look of it. And that'll be six
now.
>> Okay, we get rid of the challenge. We're
not going to try and kill off the minur
like that. can still play something like
a rebuke just to knock it back to base
and then allow us to uh get that
movement around from things like the
traveling merchant. But we'll see if you
want to go that. I think that's a
downwell actually sitting in hand as
well there for Jensen. The ability to
bounce all of these big units which
means Elgato then has to take a much
longer time to play them all out. Like
if you're a a weenies deck is what we
used to call it in Magic, right? It's
like small creatures that have like
three energy cost, four energy cost
>> as opposed to a 6 to 12 energy cost
deck. It's like I would very much have
very much more want to have my four cost
bounce than my 12 cost bounced.
>> Absolutely. And that's how the rush deck
can be really effective. But in this
instance, Elgato Convulkas is doing
almost the opposite where they're
saying, "I'm going to have all of these
big creatures that do have effects that
stop you doing what you want, and we're
going to make you much less mobile." And
then I'm going to go ahead and start
targeting those down. I'm going to take
these battlefields and then possibly
hold them. So, of course, we've gone in
there. Yep. Gone ahead and taken down
>> the uh the only unit at any battlefield
in this game so far. And power of the
canvas snap jaw just comes in, snaps its
jaw as is in the name. It's one of those
like, you know, sometimes as biologists,
you just name things after stuff.
>> It's like, oh, what's it do? It snaps it
jaw. Cool. Call it a snap jaw.
>> It's a snap vine in this instance, but
that's okay.
>> Snap vine. Sorry. Yeah. No, that's okay.
It's It snaps. It's a vine. It's
carnivorous. It's the same thing.
>> Uh, and what does a um a Venus fly trap
do? It traps flies. Therefore, fly trap
snap vine.
>> And this exactly what it did. and it's a
strong unit, but it costs a lot. And so
it doesn't often see place in a lot of
decks unless you've got this kind of
ramp of your runes so that you can
afford to be playing these really heavy
cost units at this stage of the game.
And we got another Minotaur movement is
going to be delayed harshly.
>> Movement.
>> Hey, very good.
>> Utterly ridiculous that joke. Utterly
ridiculous.
There's uh
>> I can't believe you've put me in this
spot.
>> Yeah, I'm sorry.
>> No, it's okay. I'll do it to you later.
>> I think Alistister needs to be added as
a a card in Riftbound.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. It's a great League of Legends
champion. He's a cow in
>> Oh, perfect.
>> So, yeah, it's uh likes to bounce people
around. I could see it being a you play
an Alice on a battlefield, it fight or
flights an opposing creature, you know.
>> Nice. back to Riftbound as uh those
minister of economics are going to be
difficult to deal with. One of the
problems is though your units also can't
move to base. So that here is stuck at
the obelisk of power. You can see both
of the players avoiding sigil of the
storm like the plague right now. Don't
want to be
>> going in there. I think Gen 6 starting
to think about whether that downwell is
a good option. Okay.
>> All right. Ezreal going on their
adventure. Anyone need a map? We're
heading on in uncharted territory.
I mean for the the civer at least you're
making a gold when you are recycling
right so true it's uh less impactful
than it would be on others as goes in
we'll have that rune recycled from the
sigil of the storm tap the civer make a
gold nice enough overall
>> Mhm. I think having almost battlefields
that your opponent doesn't really want
to touch is a great thing. Even if it's
not even if it doesn't exactly help you
in your scenario, having to detriment
them more than yourself is worthwhile.
So playing playing a battlefield that
isn't great for you, but it's awful for
your opponent is quite advantageous.
>> Yeah, it definitely helps you out. Uh, I
guess there's an argument for Algato is
like if you have a good enough board
state, you have things like Calalist,
you have things like mobilize, maybe it
is worth trying to fight for the sigil
because
>> you can repopulate, but the the
repopulation for you is harder generally
than it is for the civ player.
>> 100%.
>> Yeah, it's uh
>> this is kind of what you expect from
both these though. Both of them do like
to go slow. It's not about Yeah. gaining
a huge amount of points at the start.
You're just going to be ekking out as
much advantage as you can and then
working out exactly when to use these uh
tools in your arsenal. I saw the
confront in hand as well. Is it going to
be double move into the brin here?
Thunderstorm
into the obelisk of power. Yes, here we
go. Double moving in there. Just
challenging. I don't think there's
anything that can come back from that. I
think it is just a very simple Yeah,
going ahead and trading there. But
Ezreal, Ezreal stands firm in the
obelisk of power taking that. We've got
double Ezreal in play proving why he's
here at this tournament. Absolutely
doing wondrous things and taking the
battlefields by storm right now. Up to
four points to one. It's looking like
Gen Zig has definitely started to put
the pressure on for Elgato. It's going
to need to respond quickly and pretty
efficiently to be able to tackle down
these Ezreals and start to bring the
favor back into their hand.
>> Yeah, I do think they have the tools to
do it right now. You can see 16 might is
there. There was always the risk as well
that Elgato could have had something
like a skysplitter or a challenge on
that move in and that would have been a
little bit trickier for the Gentic to
deal with in those moments. So, you are
taking a bit of a risk. Uh, also tapping
out of all of the runes.
>> Okay, quite a bit.
>> What do we got? Is it a Raza coming out
maybe or Oh,
>> it's going to be the downwell. Okay,
down well. Bouncing all units and all
gear into their owner's hands. And this
is what we were talking about. It's the
idea of, okay, I'll set myself back, but
I'm going to set you back further.
>> Further. Exactly. And that's that's the
troublesome thing here is it's like,
yeah, okay, well, I don't really mind
too much because again, I've got some
units that I can play a little bit
cheaper. There's the Raza. And because
we had plenty in discard, now it just
became even cheaper to play as they cost
less for each card in your trash. So
those huge units, although they normally
cost 10, you actually don't need quite
as much. And for six might, that is a
very great contender into a volar deck.
And now as the Voli bear, you're
thinking, well,
>> what do I do now?
>> I can play maybe two Minotaurs this
turn. I can try and get a little bit of
power back onto a little bit of might
back onto the battlefield, but it's not
going to be the easiest thing for me.
I'm looking down the barrel of two six
might units. Okay, we'll go for the
mobilize, get that card draw. There's
the sky spplitter. A turn too late to
deal with that Ezreal.
>> That's a shame. That is that feels bad
when you pull the card from the top deck
the turn after it's useful.
>> That happens to me a lot. We did go for
the double minotaur. Really good call
there.
>> But is it too little too late?
>> It might be. I The thing is Jensen is
still two turns away from winning and
would need to split up their roses to
get there.
>> That is a fact.
>> Do you want to try and double hold?
Probably not. You can't. As soon as you
go in, you can't move back doubly. So
>> you're stunk. Yeah, you are absolutely
landlocked. So, it's probably going to
be a push 12 in to one of the
battlefields. Obeliska power makes the
most sense cuz don't really want to be
recycling on that sigil of the storm.
>> And then at that point also
>> if Minur Reena if two of them come in
>> with a sky spplitter which is uh five
damage to a unit as a battlefield
reduced by the highest might amongst
units you control. So it would be three
energy and a power to play. Okay, we
played a confront. So we got the draw
one and units now enter play ready.
>> So we do have at least that we can play
this Ezreal. Nice. Okay. And that comes
in ready. So now maybe there's a little
bit more splitage that could go on that
could occur.
>> True, true, true. But even then I I'm
cons I guess it depends on how much Gen
Sig knows volley decks.
>> Yeah.
>> Because it's the edge you're going in
just for the singular point makes sense.
gets you to five. Double roster the
other side would get you to six and then
you'd be one turn away. But at that
point, you are you are looking at things
like dead bloom. You're looking things
like sky spplitter. You're looking
things like challenge
>> which can be really hard to deal with.
Keeping the back I think is a
conservative but understandable move.
>> I agree. And they're far enough ahead.
They don't need to use resources. They
don't need to put things at risk.
>> Elgato of course going in with the
minotaur going, "Yep, okay, I'll have
that back. I need points at this stage.
I need to win this game. I'm going to
need to at some point have these
minotaurs fight my battles. And he's got
to go in with it. So, it's a really
simple showdown at that point. And I
think this really differs from the last
round that we cast together where they
were so complicated in a beautiful way.
Uh with all of the spells that were
going on, this is two raw power decks at
this point going.
>> Is my guy bigger than your guy? Yes. No.
>> Yeah, it's pretty much what's happening.
There is a punch first in hand. Uh
rebuke as well for Gen 6. So there's a
few options for them if we do get into
that massive
>> battle of fisty cuffs. Yeah,
>> absolutely. But at the moment, Elgato
just really needs to get some points on
the board. One is not enough when you're
staring down at five points on Gen 6
side with very powerful units in play
and like you say, some chaos uh
abilities that are going to allow for
those more confrontational
>> uh styles of combat. going in with the
other minotaur as well. Just really
trying to to focus in on that one
battlefield.
>> And there's the Kadrian. So that's going
to draw us two cards, I believe. Oh,
it'll be three cuz it counts itself.
When you play me, draw one for each of
your mighty units. So
>> Oh, fantastic.
>> Three card draw, but a huge investment.
Uh Volley will give us an extra fury
rune channeled out. We have three left.
There's the three cards.
>> Didn't quite spot them, but hopefully
they're good. We've not got a lot of
runes left to work with this time.
>> Importantly now Skysplitter. Oh, there's
the challenge. Huge challenge, but who's
going to challenge who? I imagine.
>> I mean, Kadrick getting onto Arasa,
doesn't
sky spplitter now basically free. Will
cost one fury power to play because we
have a unit with over eight might.
>> Beautiful.
>> The comeback begins. I mean, it's a slow
roll for a Volibear, but he is used to
being that oncoming storm, that
relentless storm.
>> Uh, rolling thunder, the name of his
queue in League of Legends, by the way.
So, that's a fact. I know
to bring out right now.
>> Very apt. The Thunder started way away.
It's getting closer now and it's getting
a lot more uh a lot scarier really for
Gen Zig because although we've had that
really early lead, it's the can I now
keep up with this? Can I continue to put
out the fire that these lightning
strikes are causing?
>> It's a tricky one overall for Elgato
looking to step towards that three and
one. Currently sitting at two and one
both these players. Jensen did win round
one or not round one, match one, game
one of this series.
>> So just needs one more to go to that
three and one. And I think you have to
assume someone coming on a volley bear
deck is not expecting to top eight. This
is a a best of attempt last, right? So
>> that can get the back as well.
>> What a fantastic card. Probably one of
the strongest gear in the game.
>> Also allows you to put cards back into
your deck. So, there's a few options
that you can go for here. The idea is,
do I just put cards back in that I don't
really want because I haven't gone
through enough in my deck. I haven't
been able to get the, you know, the the
draws that I was looking for, the stack
decks and um
uh core shots and such. So, I'm just
going to put in things that I don't like
like the scrap heap or do I put things
back into my deck like the Russa cuz I
need to get more units back available to
me. Here we're going to attack in and
then look for the conquer and try and
play that Russa out of the trash.
>> Trash. We want it from the discar. We
want that back. You've got to conquer or
hold to be able to play the unit from
the trash.
>> Punch first bumps us up.
>> Oh, is it going to be enough?
>> It's got to be the sky spplitter onto
>> deal five damage. Looking for the trade.
trying not to allow for that last rights
to have that ability.
>> Question is where do you go? You have a
rebuke in hand as Jen Sig that avoids
the minotaur and it's an Aurora deck and
we haven't seen one for so long.
>> It's been forever,
but it doesn't look like there's much
else there.
>> It's going to be a rebuke.
>> It is. It's got to be the rebuke that
takes out that Minotaur
>> and it keeps Rasa out of kill range
right now. If there was another sky
spplitter for Elgato, this would be the
perfect time to use it. But that
Minotaur is going to die.
>> Doesn't trade with the Rasa. Rasa now
gets the last rights trigger.
>> The last rights trigger being absolutely
fundamental to this core of the deck
right now, especially because we're late
game and we need those large surprise
attacks from uh from Raza. And now we're
going to be able to bring one back into
play. And we get the plus two from the
last right still. I just I think that's
absolutely exceptional. You got you got
plus two and a badass effect. Like
that's incredible.
>> Yeah, you do have to recycle from your
uh trash to be able to equip it, which
is can be a bit of a cost sometimes, but
when you are putting so many cards into
your trash like in a civ deck doesn't
matter too much. Put that scrap heat
back on the bottom. Make another gold.
And now if you're Elgato, you're looking
at it, it's like, well, I guess I could
look for the Aurora next. Oh, no gold.
Did we accidentally trigger Civ twice on
a turn? I believe we may have done.
>> And that's easily corrected. Down to two
body runes though for Jensen Sig.
>> Going to use one of them for a stack
deck or are we not?
>> I'm not sure at this point. I think
having just the two body runes is kind
of scary.
>> You punch first, right? Yeah. Yeah,
exactly. Yeah, that that's what you were
talking about earlier was that kind of
pricey cost and now we're in the
situation where Elgato could now kind of
stampede forward with their units
because they just have more to play.
>> It's such a difficult position to be in.
I did I see a dead bloom in there
>> because you kind of want to play Aurora.
You kind of want to start getting those
units off the top, but you are so close
to losing out on the game.
>> It's not an ideal situation, I think,
for either player here. Yeah, it is.
>> There's a clear divide in points, but
the strategy that both of these are
going for has actually been untangled by
one another rather well at this point. I
think if anything, Volibear's in a
slightly more advantageous position in
regards to cards in hand and what they
can do, what they can play, what's
available, but then actually we don't
really have that presence on board or in
points right now. so far behind in
points and it's getting really close for
our
civ player
>> really close and I just don't know if
they're going to be able to keep it up.
>> Yeah, that's I 100% understand. Uh no
dead bloom predator in hand. Makes it
hard to immediately contest the
battlefield unless you just go in with
Kadrian
which is nine might. On the other side
we have a last rights on a rasa. Can't
remember if there was anything else on
that battlefield. I don't believe so.
>> I don't believe so either.
>> So, is it do you just
>> I think it's just a it maybe is just a
heavy kind of hard cast of a large unit
>> and start to attempt to contest the last
rights. You don't want the last rights
to hold, right? That's the thing.
>> That's the thing. You need to get onto
that battlefield. And if you can't, then
you are
>> hardressed. No, you just lose, right?
Yeah.
>> You just lose.
>> I was saying it politely, but yeah, you
just lose.
>> Incredibly hardressed. I mean the other
option is you go to Sigil of the Storm
and try and hold there into the Rasa
coming in.
>> Yeah.
>> And then you have to recycle. Maybe you
dazzling and then play whatever's coming
out onto there as well, but then you
risk the being rebuked, being fight or
flighted, just getting bounced away from
the battlefield
>> with no min out,
>> but it might be worth a reward. But then
if you don't get what you need off of
that dazzling, then it was a waste. And
cuz the the right cards to play here are
going to potentially be a win or loss
situation.
>> Yeah. Where are we going? Okay. Going to
Obelisk. Taking the fight to this Rasa.
>> Seeing if there's anything that they can
do to kind of outweigh the just nine
might the the strength of that where
we're six seven to eight. So eight to
nine. Like just going for it seeing if
it works and it is stuck. That was all
it needed to happen. Last Rice of course
stays in play but it needs to be
reattached later and we won't get that
effect on the hold. And I think that was
such a a tough decision to make and you
could see it in both players eyes that
actually Elgato was like I really don't
know if this is the right thing to do
cuz if I lose this unit it could all be
over
>> and it makes it a lot easier just to
play out the dazzling Aurora as your
card for the turn.
>> Much safer. Much safer. Now
>> it's so it sometimes feels so mean for
Volibear decks and these Aurora decks.
is like this is your card for the turn
and then Civ's like I will play six
cards this turn and we'll see what we
can do. But we now reveal from the top
of the deck assuming Elgato decides to
move to that step and uh see where we
get in terms of another unit to play
>> and see first. Yeah,
>> cuz we've got quite a lot of units in
hand. I think that's the thing. So, how
long will it take us to get there?
>> Oh, okay. Ferris 4unner
>> not bad at all. I'm not mad at Ferris
4Runner. We've discussed earlier in the
day how instrumental Ferris 4Runner can
be to keeping a hold of battlefields and
it's really difficult to remove not just
because of its might but because of its
after and death nail effect where when
it is defeated we put two three power
mech tokens into base and then they can
just kind of take its place.
>> Mhm. Mhm. Gives you 12 might for six
energy and one power cost. Seal into
seal. Have a fizz in hand as well.
Sealing to seal into seal.
>> Okay. Yep.
>> Do the class.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> We have a a stack deck as well for
Jensen Sig. We can try and get through
the cards. Try and get through this
deck. If we do play the fierce, there's
a rebuke in graveyard. Could try and
bounce the cand back to hand. put the
Rasa with the last rights equipped up
against that first 4erunner would get us
a conquer which would get us a return of
a rasa.
>> Is it worth it? Do we want to just kind
of go into the other battlefield and
just be like, well, I guess I'll hold
here and then bring things back and kind
of stick it out infinitely.
>> I think the risk is dead predators if
you go in Aan
>> to steal the Aurora.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> Beautiful play and this is why Axan is
so powerful into so many meta decks.
You're not only stealing equipments,
you're also stealing gear. Take away the
Aurora. You can reveal from the top of
your library or top of your main deck at
the end of the turn.
>> That's horrifying.
>> Yeah.
>> If I was If I was Volibear right now,
I'd be like, "Oh, you mischievous thing.
That's awful. I can't believe
>> it took you eight turns to find the
Aurora and it immediately gets stolen
after.
>> You let me do it once."
>> Yeah. Yep. Yep. Yep. And it's just owned
as well now.
>> Yeah. That's it. It is just gone. Did
have to use two body runes to get there.
>> I think it was worth it.
>> I wonder if there's a way for the volley
to deal with that Arkan. Uh Skyplather
is at a battlefield. Something like a
challenge could work. But uh
>> start to kind of whittle away defenses.
>> I guess I think that's might be what
we're going for. Or something similar to
because that's what we need to do is
start like removing numbers here. we
need to remove might from Battlefield so
that we can go in. Um, and obviously
taking the dazzling away is a great way
to kind of give yourself a little bit of
insurance on that. You're like, "Oh,
actually, okay, at least you won't be
able to filter through from the top of
the deck every turn." You've got what's
in your hand now.
>> Yeah,
>> that's all.
>> Yeah. Yeah. There was a lot of stuff in
Elgato's hand, though, which is nice for
them. I think we are equipping last
right onto the Aan getting him up to
six. Ross is gonna go in solo.
>> I like it. I like it. I like going in
solo, taking the battlefield to be like,
well, you don't have any units to put in
there right now. Yeah. Okay, you have
units that can accelerate or just play
straight into there, but like right now,
I don't know if I mind. I just want to
go up to seven. I just want to score
seven points now.
>> And now I have the recycle trigger from
the sigil of the storm.
>> Beautiful.
>> It's a really nice all round dazzling
aurora. Remember the trigger. As a
player, you do do these from time to
time. It's a
>> fizz. This Fizz is great. Going straight
in there and bolstering that power.
Incredible.
>> Yeah, I like the nine might at that
battlefield. Makes it really hard. You
can't just go in with something like a
ferris 4runner. Uh Fizz when it's played
does get you the ability to play a spell
from your graveyard with from your trash
with uh power uh energy cost three or
less. You ignore the energy cost, but
you do have to pay a power cost. Is it a
sabotage? You recycle it after you've
played it. We play the sabotage. We're
going to have to recycle another rune.
Problem is sabotage once again doesn't
hit non units.
>> So, we've only got two to choose from,
but
>> you could take the sabotage.
>> The mobilize or the catalyst.
>> Mobilize. Sorry, I was thinking
mobilize. Yeah. And
>> yeah, I think the mobilize is is the is
the nice one there because again, you're
limiting what your opponent can do and
how they can react to your now seven
points to three.
>> Yeah. And you have nine at the
battlefield. So, is there anything that
can get ready quickly is the question.
>> That's a question on everyone's minds.
That's what we want to know. We want to
know, can anything actually start to
kind of hurt this play at this point?
And I mean,
>> like
deadl Predators can be played into
occupied enemy battlefields, so they're
great, but again, they're really high
cost. So, we're not going to be able to
get more than just that eight power and
now going up to nine on that
battlefield. That number nine is really
imperative to stop those.
>> Didn't even draw anything off the top.
Uh, no new Aurora for a Dead Bloom
Predator. No Dead Boom Predator itself.
We're going to sabotage.
>> Going to have a look at the hand.
>> It's a double Ezreal fears in a stack
deck and only the stack deck can be
removed.
>> They can have a peek at the rest but
can't touch it. The stack deck, you
know, it's it's a great card. We've seen
it very very
helping our uh competitors this weekend
already. But we do have natural card
draw in hand with Ezreal anyway. So
doesn't feel that impactful.
>> It really doesn't. Elgato needs to
influence this top battlefield. If uh
Jensen is able to hold on to it, they
will just win via hold. Now the Kova
Snapvine does allow you to choose an
enemy unit at a battlefield and do the
damage. So, it's going to be six onto
the rasa. Killing off the rasa.
>> Lovely. A little trade.
>> We We do have another snap vine in hand.
>> I believe
>> we can afford it.
>> Uh, can we? I think that was six.
>> Yeah. Pay the five.
>> Oh, lovely.
>> Recycle two bodies. So, we'll get rid of
that fizz.
>> And fizz is out of here, too. They're
fizzling out now.
You you have buckets and you are just
shipping all the water over the side as
quickly as you can. But it is working at
the moment for Elgato.
The second Snapvine coming down, killing
off the Fizz, surviving itself cuz it is
a deal damage. Both units deal damage
each way. So,
>> I respect it. The comeback is the
comeback is clean, man. It's it's here.
It's here to stay. We're giving it a go.
And I think it's really respectful at
this stage of the competition to not let
anything down. You're like, I've decided
to come in with Volibear and I'm going
to Volibear. And I've got to say some of
these classic uh cards that we've seen
from set one as well really shine in
this meta in Spirit Forged. It's really
nice to see.
>> It really is. It really is.
>> But we don't have a lot of runes left as
Jenzu.
>> There's an easy rasa play though. You go
in with ashan, you you conquer, you seal
for the rasa. definitely have more than
10 in your trash, right? And you could
just try and hold the sigil of the
storm. Issue is you are recycling a rune
when you go in there.
>> Um, you do have your dazzling. Could use
Fizz to try and get something like the
on the hunt back
>> giving the ability to enter ready.
>> Yeah, I think you're right though. I
think we don't really have a choice. I
think you've got to keep the pressure on
here. You've got to get the big units
back. You've got to go for the Raza.
You've got to go for the last rights
going into the battlefield for the
conquer.
>> Yeah, we're happy. There it goes.
>> And
>> away with you.
>> Yeah. Can't recycle a body. Has to be a
chaos.
>> You just flip it over to show. Yes, this
is going to the bottom of my rune deck
as soon as I
decide what I want to use the energy
for. We'll bring the Rasa back.
>> Yep. Lovely. There's our gold token.
Raza going straight in there as well.
Just trying to make that kind of that
stronghold position again.
>> I mean, you know that a couple of snap
fls have just come out.
>> Yep. I can't. We had a snap vine earlier
as well, but was it rebuked or is there
one in the trash?
>> I think it's in the trash. So, I think
we are out of snap vines at this point.
I could be wrong, but I'm pretty certain
>> and so the threat is minimal.
>> Yeah, I mean you could The problem is
for Elgato everything costs so much cuz
you could magma worm which means your
other unit center ready and then you
could play something like a volley bear
or a dead bloom predator. Dead predator
doesn't matter as much but you a minur
get that extra might and then go in
ready. But magma worm is eating a a fury
rune. Aiden fury power, right? It's all
so pricey.
>> Now a fully stacked up
>> sigil of the storm. We're going
searching. We'll find a roster from it
with the dazzling aurora.
>> That's 6
>> 12 18
21 might holding down the fort for Civot
at that top battlefield.
Where are we going? Elgato.
>> Gent stole Elgato's
>> one of the best cards on their field and
just went,
>> "Oh, anyway, I'm going to I'm going to
use it now and be better."
>> Y
>> that's wild.
>> I would like to take this and it will
serve me well.
>> It's not even like you're just taking it
away from them like taking something
that someone shouldn't have. You're
like, "Oh, actually, I could use that.
Can I borrow that, please?" Thank you.
>> It's not even can I borrow that, please.
It's I am borrowing that. I will take
that. Good luck.
>> The rich get richer.
>> Yeah, that's, you know, capitalism,
>> right?
>> Minister of EO coming out will mean that
units can't move to base. I don't think
Jensen Sig had any intentions of moving
units to base.
>> I think they are happy to be there and
wanting to say no. Okay, you managed to
push me out last time, but I'm staying
this time.
>> I mean, it's it's got to be over, right?
What are you trying to draw off the top
here?
>> I'm not even sure. Even something like a
challenge, it's not enough.
>> There's the handshake. Jensen taking it
away with a battle mistress versus the
bear. And guess who won?
>> The battle mistress.deed.
>> I don't have the guess. I was there.
>> We were here, but honestly, fantastic
showing. Taking from their opponent,
using their own instruments against them
was absolute genius work in play. And
I'm so pleased that we got to watch all
of that unravel. I'm glad we got to see
a volley bear.
>> Yeah. So am I. I I was I was hoping for
more. I feel like the Aurora coming down
as late as it did was really
unfortunate. No early mobilizes, no
early cataclys catalysts either. Um but
really good sideboarding action with the
Axan coming in. We have to expect that
with sideboarded cuz you don't really
usually run Axan as a main uh in the
Civex. Really nicely done by Jensen.
They'll go to three and one. We'll see
uh
>> our Volibear player go to two and two,
which isn't out. It's not bad. You want
six wins really. 18 points I believe is
the cut off,
>> but also going for that best offrising,
right? Like a Voli Bear doing this well
early in the tournament and we saw they
had some fantastic plays. Their deck is
geared up. We know kind of what the
expectation of Volibear is, but that
doesn't stop its ferocity coming at you
and I think that's a wonderful thing.
You can just kind of roll with it and I
think that best uprising is still very
much in the in the claws there. I think
we definitely can still achieve it. So
>> the claws amazing.
>> Thank you. We're going to go to a short
break with a wonderful bit of video. Go
away. Come back in a bit.
>> Welcome roofbounders to the first ever
European regional qualifier here in
Bologna. And my name is Leonard Kunik.
I'm going to bring you through this
coverage. Also, we're going to interview
a few players, viewers, league enjoyers
here right at the venue in Italy. So,
I'm going to ask a few random people
like this fell here. Hello there. What's
your name? Uh, my name is Martin.
>> Martin, nice to meet you. So, I have a
few questions about Spirit Forge. Are
you ready?
>> Yeah, I am.
>> All right. So, the first one is, how
much death do you think has been added
to the game of Riftbound by equipments
being added in Spirit Forged?
>> Pretty much. Uh, I think you can make a
whole more unit more valuable if you
can, for example, the two drops equip
with more might and when they die, you
can reattach them. So, a lot a lot more
death. Yeah.
>> Yeah. There's a lot of stuff you can do
with equipments. Next question is, which
legend do you think changed the game the
most?
>> I would say Draven. I would say Draven.
The winning combat is really, really
good.
>> I think so, too. You can do a lot with
the Draven itself. Thank you so much.
And uh enjoy the tournament, mate.
>> All right, we're going over to the next
person.
>> Hello there. Do you want to answer a few
questions for the stream?
>> Uh, yeah, sure.
What's your name?
>> Uh Josh.
>> Hi Josh. So first question, how much
depth do you think was added to the game
of Riftbound by adding equipments?
>> Depth. Uh a lot of depth. I guess it's
they added so many different equipments.
It's definitely completely changed the
game from Origins. So I mean it's I I
can't even put it into numbers to be
honest, but I think it's added a lot of
things. So
>> and this is the first tournament where
Spirit Forge is legal. The first big
tournament. How did you prepare for it?
How did I prepare? Uh went to a couple
of pre- riffs. Um definitely been uh
really training on TCG Arena a lot. Um
playing with the mates. Well, I'm here
today and also back at home. Shout out
them. Um but yeah, honestly, it was only
a week ago, so I wish I prepared more,
but I tried my best, so why not?
>> What's your favorite legend?
>> Legend from Spirit Forge.
>> From Spirit Forge. That's a good
question. Good question. Loki, it might
be Aurelia. I don't play Aelia, but I
think the the legend's cool, but I'm not
smart enough to be playing that legend.
I can't lie.
>> You know what? I agree. Thank you, Josh.
And enjoy the tournament. All right,
everyone. We're going to ask I think a
group of people over there. Let me just
see if I can get in here some. Hello.
Are you guys ready to answer a few
questions for me?
>> Sure, sure.
>> Sure.
>> All right, great. So, I'm going to start
with you. So, what's your favorite
legend from Spirit Forged?
>> Oh my god. Uh I I don't know. There's
just so many to pick. Uh Spirit Forged.
Um, I mean,
yeah, I I love Rumble and I love Jigs to
be fair. They're both my favorites.
>> Right. So, you're a Fury player, I
assume. So, next question to you, a
little bit harder. How much depth do you
think has been added to the game with
equipments?
>> That's a difficult question, but I do
think it changed it quite a bit because
now cards that usually weren't that
great, like salvage, you would I'm now
playing the main board. I think that
says enough. So yeah, I do think a lot
has has been added.
>> All right, nice. And now the last
question for you. This is the first
tournament, the first big tournament
where Spirit Force is legal. How did you
prepare?
>> I'm just practicing with friends a lot,
going to Nexus Knights and skirmishes,
trying to win, do my best. Uh, yeah,
just practice a lot, I think. And on
online mostly, but we also practice with
proxies before it was even released. So
just to get familiarized with actually
playing physical. But yeah, since it's
been out, we've been practicing even
more with having the cards there. So,
just practice, practice, practice.
>> All right. Thank you so much for your
answers. All